hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we'll be
taking you through the javascript and
react.js full codes
this course is designed in such a way
that it will cover every important
aspect from the basics of both
javascript and react to some advanced
level topics javascript is a scripting
language used by the programmers to
create dynamic and interactive web
content like
applications and websites
react on the other hand is an open
source javascript library that is used
for building user interfaces
specifically for single page
applications
by the end of this full course tutorial
you guys will be able to implement
javascript and react in different ways
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply learn
so without any further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial we'll start this
video with an introduction to javascript
and why one should learn javascript
following that we'll cover basic
javascript topics like arrays loops and
functions in javascript along with some
advanced level topics like promises in
javascript we have some specific
projects waiting for you guys we'll
create some games to understand
javascript in a better way
upon completing javascript we'll move on
and cover react
we'll cover everything you need to know
and understand about react we'll see
what is react and cover fundamental
topics like react components react props
and statements
following that we'll create an app from
scratch using react we'll then go
through the comparison between
javascript frameworks like angular view
and react at the end of this full course
tutorial we'll understand what react
native is and work on a project that
will help you understand the library
much better
let's start this video with an
introduction to javascript
javascript was developed in the year
by a person named brendan ike
brendan was working for netscape
communications while he developed
javascript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javascript initially it was moca which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became javascript
the start of javascript wasn't that good
as so many developers who were using
java at that time
they considered javascript as a language
for designers and non-engineers
no one ever knew that this small side
scripting language would have a great
future today more than 90 percent of the
websites out there they are using
javascript somehow many of you guys gets
confused with java and javascript let me
clear it for you that both java and
javascript they are different languages
they have almost nothing in common many
people say that javascript was named
after java as a part of a marketing
strategy to gain wider acceptance and
recognition in 1995 java was a buzzword
when javascript was developed that's why
they renamed javascript after java let's
move on to what is
javascript have you guys ever been
through a website where you can see
images that slides automatically one
such website is amazon the home page of
amazon where we can see different types
of ongoing sales is an example of
javascript
in layman language javascript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when javascript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
javascript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
android or in ios but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for android we have to learn java
and xml and swift we have to learn for
ios but with the help of javascript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
tech giants like google paypal amazon
and youtube they are using javascript
these days the evolution of javascript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
gmail let's suppose
so gmail is a single page website which
looks more like a desktop software than
a website so gmail is based on
angular.js
it is a popular framework by google
which is free of cost and it is totally
based on javascript now let's go over
some of the features of javascript these
features are actually why it is
considered that using javascript is
advantages over other languages
so let's start with some of these points
javascript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python
so there are few other languages like c
plus plus and java they need a compiler
to work but with javascript you don't
need a compiler once you are done with
the script
it will interpret and show you the
output in the browser directly
next up is lightweighted javascript can
provide programming facility to some
extent in javascript you don't need to
specify any data type or return type
which helps in making development more
quicker that's why it is known as light
weighted
javascript is both client-side as well
as server-side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
javascript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the backend as
well there is a way to validate the
user's data before sending it to the web
server and we can do that with the help
of javascript the data will be checked
for correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition to check the data
javascript is also platform independent
although originally designed to work on
browsers only but now it is a platform
independent language which means once
you are done with the script you can use
it on any browser or platform without
any problem javascript is an object
based scripting language although many
programmers do not consider javascript
as a true object oriented programming
language due to its lack of class
concept
it does support other features of object
oriented programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
javascript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions javascript differentiates
between capital and lowercase letters we
have to keep this in mind while
programming
now i will quickly go over some of the
javascript applications where javascript
is currently being implemented
first one that comes to every person's
mind is web development it was also the
main motive behind developing javascript
we have technologies like angular we
have node.js we can create beautiful web
pages
also javascript can be used along with
html and css to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
javascript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
javascript can take over traditional
android and ios app
one of the most important and unique
application of javascript is in
smartwatches the bengal.js is an open
sourced smartwatch powered by javascript
gordon williams the man who is currently
working on this project it is said that
this new open sourced stack built around
javascript will replace the onboard
firmware soon the next application of
javascript is client-side validation as
we discussed earlier javascript is used
to validate the user data whether the
user's input is correct or not by cross
checking it with the given condition
like the user wants to enter in your
website and you want it to be a user
with at the right gmail.com in his email
id so you will give that condition to
javascript and it will cross check it
with the user's information like when
the user will try to enter in your
website it will check that if at the
rate gmail.com is there or not in the
user's email id so it can validate the
user also apart from that one more
application of javascript is game
development javascript can be used to
make fully fledged 2d or 3d games using
different libraries although most
javascript game development focuses on
creating games used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
javascript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
javascript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use javascript the
first one is the basic knowledge of html
and css to use javascript along with
html and css you first need to know how
html and css works see html is used to
create the structure of a web page while
css is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with javascript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn javascript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css
it's better to have a web browser that
supports javascript like google chrome
or mozilla firefox or you can use safari
as well if you are using a macbook you
will need an operating system like
windows linux or mac operating system to
learn javascript a computer with minimum
512 mb of ram would be enough for you to
start learning javascript but i will
recommend you a computer with 1gb of ram
or 4gb of ram for a better experience
you can use any text editor you have
notepad which is free and is already
available for windows
if you don't want to use notepad you can
use other free softwares like sublime or
you can use visual code in this
particular course we will be using
visual code and i'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
javascript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
javascript let's start this video with
some facts about javascript
javascript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the market at that time just
like java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser javascript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of javascript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
websites back-end javascript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95 of
the internet was powered by javascript
means almost every website out there is
using javascript in some way or another
do you guys know about stack overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
overflow states that javascript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers
let me quickly run you through the
reasons why one should learn javascript
and then we'll briefly elaborate each of
these reasons
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks
javascript is constantly growing and is
a well-paid job
javascript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
javascript provides wide range of usage
as well
let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to
design a website like gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design ui
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful javascript
frameworks
next up is constant truth one of the
main reasons behind one should learn
javascript javascript is one of the
fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
mobile market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is possible only with the help of
javascript
that's why javascript is continuously
growing and there is no way that
javascript will go down shortly
the developers working in javascript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn javascript it
is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
javascript jobs section
javascript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages
like java python and php javascript
provides easy entry points to the world
of programming the best thing about
javascript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
javascript which means you can start
coding right away
javascript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is
the more help you would be likely to get
currently javascript has the biggest
stack overflow community it has
overtaken java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn javascript by knowing
javascript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with javascript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning javascript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in usa and in india
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in india but if you are a full
stack developer in u.s you can earn up
to 100 000 dollars per annum which is a
huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer
but the amount of money a front-end
developer earns in a year is decent a
javascript developer works on the front
end and sometimes back-end also
a javascript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a js developer in us
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a ui is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a ui ux designer earns in india is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely
let's start this video with the
introduction to dom
dom stands for document object model it
is an api for html and xml documents
which helps javascript to understand
what is there written inside the html
document
api stands for application programming
interface to understand api better let's
take an example of a restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what api does it works as a
moderator between javascript and the
html document
dom defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript so that
other javascript functions can work over
it
it represents the entire document in the
form of object and nodes whether it be
elements or text or anything stored in
the document the entire page content can
be accessed or manipulated by javascript
dom is not used with javascript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model
every browser uses dom to make the web
page of the document accessible by
javascript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example
i believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of html and css a prerequisite
for this codes let's start things off
with a basic html example here we have a
code that consists tags like html head
body heading tag etc we have the html
tag here the opening html tag and the
closing html tag
inside the html tag we have the head tag
which contains the document's header
part inside the head tag there is a
title tag that contains the title of the
web page
then comes the body tag which contains a
heading tag and two div tags with ids as
div 1 and div 2. a div tag defines a
particular section in the html document
the id used within the div tag it is an
attribute basically that has to be
unique within the document to make the
element unique from other elements next
up we have a paragraph tag with a class
attribute within it css and javascript
uses classes to select and access
specific elements don't worry guys if
you have no idea about it
let us first see the output of this code
before going to the document object
model
of this whole document so guys this is
the output of the previous code we just
came through here we can see the title
of the web page as well as heading after
it there were two different div tags
used in the code
here is the output of both the div tags
the question here is where are those id
and class attributes seen in the output
the answer to this question is there is
nothing on this web page that can show
both of them we can use them in our css
file or through javascript to specify
the containers in which they are used so
we have concluded how a normal document
works and how the browser interprets the
html code but how javascript uses this
code is a bit different that's where dom
comes into play when the actual html
document is loaded in the browser
another representation of that document
is created known as document object
model here's the model you can see on
your screen
each of the tags used in html document
is correspondingly represented as object
in the dom
like starting from the html tag and
covering all the other tags like head
title body and few more
the same hierarchy as there was in the
html document goes with the document
object model also
document object model is simply the same
html document with different
representation
the reason behind this different
representation is that it's easy for
javascript to interpret this format
javascript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects javascript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
function for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
the heading tag with javascript
you can also work on the style of this
text with the help of javascript as well
javascript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model
there are many types of nodes present in
the dom the basic three types are
element node attribute node and text
mode the element node consists of all
the tags used in html document like the
head tag and the body tag the attribute
node contains the attributes used in
html document by now i hope you have
understood the concept of attributes so
javascript can access these attributes
as well and the user can work upon them
as per requirements
the text here in the html document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
javascript it is the value of that
particular element
before installing vs code let's discuss
a few things about what is an ide
so ide stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshop makes it easier for us to
edit photos in the same way ide makes it
easier for a programmer to write code if
you want to write code ide will help you
write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of ides present in
the market today we have sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this code so first of all vs code is
free to use as it is an open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it vs code will do it for you
this property is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
mac it is available for linux and
windows as well i think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code
so for now let's move on to the
installation process the installation
process for vs code is pretty simple
just go to google and search for vs code
the next page which will open here you
can see that the first link available is
from the official website click on that
and you will go to their official
website here in the front you can see
the download this you can download the
stable version from here only
or if you want to download it for you
according to your pc's specifications
you can click on the download button
present at the top right corner of your
screen here you can see that vs code is
available for different platforms it is
available for windows for linux and for
mac as well you can download it from
here as well so if you want to download
this for windows you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
conditions you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it
this window will open where you have to
select the location you want your vs
code to locate
any id you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want
but for now i'll be leaving it as it is
and i'll click on next now this will
open and you will click next from here
now it will ask you some questions like
if you want to create a desktop icon or
not select all of them and click on next
now click on install and it will install
vs code for you sit back and relax it
will take time so once you are done with
the installation process click on finish
and the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor
this icon here is explored so vs code
works with the folders in your system
click on open folder
and just
search any folder or you can take any
folder of your choice so here in my pc
i'll go to work and i'll
take javascript
as my folder i'll select it and see it
will open the folder and i already have
a few programs written over here like
this
and i have a few more programs like this
and this
you can open any program from that
folder by using this explorer option you
can open any program present in that
folder so basically what it does any
program you make in visual studio code
you will save it in this folder only so
it will be easy for you
to open any program anytime next up we
have the search button
to find any keyword or word present in
your code whatever you write here it
will show you where it is present in
your code or in your document
so let's suppose i write here simply
learn see it will show you simply learn
in your main screen so you have a
shortcut key for this also press control
plus f from your keyboard and write
anything here like it's written simply
linear press enter and it'll show you
the result the third option here is for
version control if you want to use any
version control like you want to use git
vs code has very good integration with
kit the next button here is for debug or
it will run your program once you are
done with writing the code click here
and run and debug just open it with
chrome you have a shortcut for this as
well press f5 from your keyboard and it
will do the same the next button here is
for extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
community they are free to use for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is html css support just click
on the search button write html css
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few more you have to
install javascript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way i'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
just
close it create a new file we will name
it as
new
dot html
so it's new.html here one thing you have
to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with dot html extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic html code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as i have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with javascript enabled in it so
if you are using google chrome it's
quite easy to enable javascript let me
take you through open google chrome go
to settings and just write javascript in
the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
javascript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so i'm
good to go
once you have downloaded the editor and
you are done with the environment setup
and all you can start writing the
program so let's go
to escort we will open a new file here
and save it with the name let's open a
new file and we will save it with name
first dot html make sure to save your
file with dot html extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an html file so
in the last video we installed an
extension named live server let me tell
you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic html program or
just press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic html
program
we have not done anything yet just edit
it a little bit we will add a heading
tag and inside the heading tag we will
write a heading let's suppose we are
writing
hello so now right click on your desktop
and click on open with live server
what this will do
it will open your program in the browser
see it's the basic thing
so let me tell you what its benefits are
it will open your program in the browser
and whatever changes you are making in
the programs will be directly shown in
the browser the moment you save them see
just use google chrome or whatever
browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we will
be using it side by side now
let's suppose we'll change something
here let's add a word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we will be using it during our whole
code so now we are done with that let's
start with the program so here we are
with our basic html code which has only
tags in it it will print that thing if i
remove this heading tag let me remove it
and moment i save it it will print
nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these html
tags are used to render html files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
html tags
you can use as many tags according to
your requirements in our first program
we will write a single line statement
over the browser for that we will need
the script tag don't worry if you don't
know much about script tech let me tell
you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
javascript with html this is where html
and javascript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or point towards the external script
through the src attribute we will see
the src attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
our program so let's start with this
first
let's
start the script ad
we are done with it now the script tag
we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a javascript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document.write
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press ctrl
s and the moment you save it here it
will be reflected on your browser here
you can see in our browser it's written
over here hello world welcome to simply
we can define javascript in an external
file as well let's see how we can do
this how this script tag will point
towards an external javascript file here
what you have to do you have written
script just before type use an attribute
src
and give it the source of the file but
till now we don't have any javascript
file so let's create a file first name
it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with dot js extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong i guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that javascript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was script
dot js
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here initially it was hello
world welcome to simply code but now it
is hello world welcome to simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed javascript with
html and now let's see some of the
features of document.write
so let's suppose you are you have
written this text here let's erase it
and see what else it can do let's give
it a task to add two numbers let's
suppose we have given here 9 plus 3.
let's see if it works
see
it will give you the output directly
here document.write 9 plus 3 it will
give you the output as 12. similarly you
will do
any mathematical task any calculation
you want to do
let's suppose
seven
multiplied by
eight
see
you can see here twelve fifty six square
let's
give it another one nine multiply five
minus let's suppose 3 and save it 3 9
into 5 is 45 and if you minus 3 from 45
you'll get 42. here is the answer for s
56 is for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and
12 is for 9 plus 3
so with that we are done with how to
embed with uh javascript with html let's
move on to another concept in javascript
that is console.log console.log is a
function in javascript that works the
same as document.write
but it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try
let's
clear this and
suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
plea code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browser's console
go to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use control
plus shift plus i which i normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles sources network and many more
but for now let's focus on console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things
we don't always know what to expect as
the output maybe we expect a particular
result but we might get something else
one way of debugging our code is that we
can pass a value to this function here
only and we can check the result of that
value out of the code let's add two
numbers here so if you don't understand
it basically what we are doing for now
we are writing a small piece of code
like the program is not that big but
later on when we are good with
javascript and we'll use javascript as a
primary language the
size of the program will go longer and
longer so not every time you are
supposed to
check the output of your code by doing
that only so if you are using any
variables or you are using any functions
you can check the output here only if
you have to use that variable in that
way or you have to change something so
you will get it here only that's the use
of console.log
let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to five and let
b's value is eight
suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we will do we will
write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b
let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is
13 you can do any complex calculation
here in the console it will give you the
correct answer you can see here script
dot js colon 4 the number after the
column is the line in script.js here in
our file we can see that the console.log
command is in line number 4. so here it
is written that it is line number 4 here
so if you click on this
you can see the script.js opened in a
very small window and you can edit it
from here as well so this is not a
random line number to prove this let's
go on to a program and let's move this
to another line see now the console.log
is in line 11.
save it and here you can see this also
changed to 11 so let's make this more
complex add another variable c we'll add
another variable here let suppose we had
c here we'll give it a more complex
equation let's suppose
let c equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer
oh no we are done with the equation
let's change it here also
the value of
c is
let's see if it works or not press ctrl
s it's saved and the value of c is 7.
let's see if this value is correct or
not the value of a was 5 5 into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27
27 plus a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus
25 is minus 20
27 minus 20 the value of c is 7 c it's
correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document.write
so console.log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program so variables are named storage
that a program can manipulate as the
name suggests a variable is a value that
can change according to conditions
variables refers to those memory blocks
inside the computer where we can store
information let's suppose you want to
store any value inside your computer so
variable will represent the location of
that value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript we can
say which is the updated version of
javascript variables were declared using
a single keyword only which is where
we'll try to declare a few variables
here we'll see how where keyword works
so let's comment this thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to
15 will declare
where b and the value of b will be six
we will declare where
c and the value of c would be
a plus b so here we have defined three
variables a b and c
a is a variable with value 15 stored
inside it and so is b the value of b is
but c is a variable that will contain
the value of a plus b let's try to print
this on browser
document.write
and we will print the value of c
save it and here you can see the value
of c is 21
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we'll copy this line
we'll paste it for
a and
we will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of c is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of b
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
two more ways were introduced to declare
a variable these are let and const we
shall discuss these two terms in the
later part of this session let me show
you how to declare a variable there are
a few things you have to keep in mind
while declaring a variable name here we
have seen we use three variables a b and
c that was an easy task to do but giving
a variable any name like something other
than a single alphabet so you have to
keep a few things in mind while naming
them start them with a letter underscore
or a dollar sign
you can't use any sign except underscore
or dollar
so if you are
giving a variable name
you can't use any other sign except the
underscore or the dollar sign
you can use these two signs only you
can't use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in javascript javascript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
javascript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name
but you can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in javascript
we'll save it
and see here it throws an error
unexpected token class
but
you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because javascript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital g this
time javascript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for javascript as
javascript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variables let's comment this part as
well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as lightning where
bike name
and press enter
if we leave this variable without
assigning it any value the by default
value will be undefined let's try to
print the value of this variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value to assign let's suppose we'll
assign it
yamaha
semicolon and press ctrl s to save this
and here you can see the output as
yamaha
you can also assign a value to the
variable during declaration as we have
done in the previous examples here we
have assigned the variables value at the
time of declaration only let's move on
to let and const
so we will discuss let and cons but
first we will compare let with where let
is also used to declare a variable just
like where is used but there is a
limitation to use let
let is not accessible outside the block
in which it is declared
so we will use let here only let bike
name equals and we will change this
value as well we'll change it to hero
let's say save it and here you can see
the output as hero but if we try to put
this code inside a block
let's suppose we put this code inside
this block a pair of curly braces
and we will again try to access
document.write we will try to access
bike name again from here from outside
the block we try to access this save it
and here you can see by name is not
defined it is an error in line 18. so
what's happening here basically you
can't access a let variable outside the
scope you can't access it from here but
it will work with where we try to
replace that with where and save it here
you can see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of where due to its
limited scope let variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for loop or in while loop we will learn
these loop in future let will not allow
you to redeclare any variable let's
understand this with an example here is
the code as well we have declared
where bike name and we'll remove this
and first we'll try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to
tvs control plus s it says hero and tvs
so the variable name the bike name is
same in both cases here and here as well
these are same but with where keyword
you can do that let will not allow you
to do this if we use let here in place
of
where we'll write let here as well and
we'll change the value as well we will
give it as
kawasaki
and
let's suppose suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same let variable in
different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
redeclare any declared variable so let's
move on to const we use const when there
are values we don't want to change or
that will never change basically so the
keyword constant is little misleading
as it defines a constant reference to a
value not the constant value we can't
change the primitive value but we can
change the properties of constant
objects
let's write another piece of code for
const keyword
so let's declare a
variable const
x
is equal to
comma y is equal to
7 let's say fonts
so here what we have done we declared a
variable x and a variable y with value
as five and seven we declared this time
with const keyword and variable z which
is x plus y
we printed z on the browser and it shows
the value as 12 which is x plus y 7 plus
5 is equal to 12. now what we will do
const will let you do this but if you
try to update the value of x let's
suppose we try to
update the value of x as x equals to x
plus 10
we'll print
x this time
x let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24. so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to re-declare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier x has already
been declared this thing you can do with
const the scope of const is the same as
let it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable
the type of variable is holding
basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that javascript is
a lightweight scripting language because
we don't need to specify any data type
in javascript after all all the
variables in javascript are loosely
packed or we can say javascript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
javascript
so javascript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in heap
i don't want you to go deep in these two
terms as if you are new to programming
so we'll leave it just keep one thing in
mind that primitive data types are base
data types whereas non-primitive data
types are objects or we can say they are
derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings boolean
undefined null non-primitive data types
or complex data types we can say on the
other hand they are divided into two
parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where x and give it
the value as 16
we'll declare where y
and we'll give it value
hello wool
we'll declare one more let's say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of javascript which i mentioned earlier
javascript variables are loosely packed
and javascript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables
x we have defined variable x
we have defined variable y and flag as
well
the values for all three variables is
different from one another
see variable x is holding a value that
is 16 variable y
is holding a value hello world which is
a string so 16 is a number hello world
is a string and variable flag is holding
a value that refers to a boolean value
in place of true we can also write false
here
so
what's happening here here you can see
there is no data type if you are coming
from a c plus background or a java
background
this will be a little bit weird for you
guys because in c plus and java we used
to do it like we will define an integer
let let me show you
so how we will define integer in c plus
plus or what we'll say we'll use int x
equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
karen c plus plus but here in javascript
we have no data type we are only using
the where keyword that's what we call as
loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in javascript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
javascript
which are number
boolean value and string
so let's move on to the next one which
is undefined we'll define a variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable p has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
i'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable p will check the type of p
so to use this operator you have to use
it with document dot right now
so we'll do document.write and we'll use
two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like if you want to
know the type of variable x let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three time and let's change the
value here from x to y in this line
and room x to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable y it
says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character
for
variable flag it says boolean so it's
defined as true or false and
for variable p it's written here
undefined with this we are left with
only one primitive data type the null
data type there is a difference between
a null value and an undefined value
undefined means lack of value whereas
null means the absence of any value
suppose you are using null as the value
for any variable the type of operator
will return this variable as an object
but if you are not giving any value to
this variable you are leaving it after
declaration the type of operator will
return undefined here is an example for
this c
we'll declare one more variable here
we'll declare where
num let's name this variable num and we
will give it the value as null
we'll use document.write type of and we
will check with the help of type of
operator that what type of value the
variable num is holding so let's give
here
num
we are good to go press control plus s
and c
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object
we'll talk about the complex types or
composite types in further videos we'll
have separate videos for each of these
types in any programming language an
operator is a symbol that makes the
computer understand that it needs to do
some specific task
like if we want to perform an addition
between two numbers let's say we want to
perform addition between four and five
so guys
if you see the plus sign here this is
known as the operator and the two terms
which are four and five these two
numbers these are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication and many more other
operators as well
so there are many more operators present
in almost every programming language
which is present out there like it
operators are present in java they are
present in c plus in c almost every
programming language out there has the
concept of operators it's essential for
you to know how and where to use any
operator despite of the language you are
working on one needs to understand which
operators are available right so in this
particular video i'll take you through
the basic types of operator present in
javascript i'll let you know the types
and we'll learn about how to use them
and of course i'll take you through the
different categories of operators
present in javascript so in javascript
there are basically eight categories
into which operators are divided
which are we have arithmetic operators
we have assignment we have string we
have conditional we have logical bitwise
comparison and type of operator
we'll discuss the first three types in
this video that is we'll discuss the
arithmetic operators we'll discuss the
assignment and the string operators
rest we'll talk about in the following
video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic
right
so
arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well
so here are the few operators you can
see on your screen the plus operator
minus asterisk division we have modulus
we have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first so guys i want to
mention one more thing here i want all
of you to make a separate file for each
topic we'll be covering from now on like
for operators will create a separate
file will create a separate one for
control statements and other topics will
cover in future from today so i want you
to create a separate file because you
know in future if you want to access
these topics it will be easy for you to
access those files instead if you are
using a single file for all the topics
it will be quite confusing so let's
start with the arithmetic operators
first let's take two variables we are in
the javascript file let's take two
variables let's say where
x equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we will perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication i have
commented the division because i have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's 6 plus 4 similarly
for subtraction and multiplication it is
6 minus 4 and at 6 multiplied by 4.
for division i have left division
because i hope you guys know the
difference between division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll commend these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll
paste this here and we'll use the
modulus here so
now let's check the output what it says
for division and modulus see
we have divided 6 by 4
division it says it's 1.5
6 divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying two because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in
division it gives you the quotient as
the answer so keep this thing in mind
guys keep this in mind always take a
note of it so we are done with division
and modulus next up we have the
increment and the decrement operators
let me show them to you real quick
so what we'll do will declare another
variable let's say where z equals to 5
and we'll use the increment operator
here
we'll use again document.write
and here we'll let's say we write
increment how to use increment operator
for increment operator you have to use
plus plus whatever variable you have
used so we'll use plus plus z
and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens
let me give some space in between them
so that you won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
is 5.
so you can see here the functioning of
decrement and increment operator the
increment operator will increase the
value of z by 1 and the decrement
operator will do the opposite of this it
will decrease the value by 1. so we are
done with the arithmetic operators next
up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different javascript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators cf here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals 2
and we have
multiplied equals 2 we have divide
equals 2 modulus equals 2 and a few more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every
single operator out there which is
present in your screen so let's move on
and see let's move on to the programming
part so here we are guys let's declare a
few variables let's say we are declaring
a variable a
and we are giving it the value as 10
suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where b and give it the value
5.
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator
mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10. this
means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
i hope you guys are getting this keep
this in mind
so we have the value 10 and we are
assigning this value to the variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10
and similarly the value of b is 5 so
let's do one more thing we will assign
the value of a to b how to do this let's
change the value here only let's suppose
we are using the value of where a s13
okay and the value of where we will be
providing as let's say a
so
now let's try to print the value of b
here we will change
will print the value of b only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of b is 13
because we have assigned b the value
present at variable a which is 13 that's
why it is showing the value of b as 13.
this is what assignment operator is
let's try other assignment operators as
well
let's take another variable
so let's say where
even
equals to let's say 51
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of a1 first so
how to
do this let's say a1 equals to
no it's a 1 plus equals to 9
and
we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of a1 is 60 here
we have given that a1 plus equals to 9
see a 1 plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here a 1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to
a 1
plus 9
both of these lines are same both these
statements means the same they are
performing the same tasks
so a 1 equals to a 1 plus 9 is same as a
1 plus equals to 9.
that's what i want you to understand
with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform even
minus equals to you can do it as well
so let's say a1 minus is equal to 5 and
we'll copy this line from here paste it
here again and save it now let's see the
output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of a1 so in the
first statement when we tried to print a
1 here the initial value was 51 then
this statement was performed and the
value was updated to 60
then after that one more statement this
statement is also performed and the
value updated to 69 it's 51 plus 9 plus
9 and the value we have here is 69 now
what happens if we are using the minus
equals 2 operator what it will do it
will
decrease the value of a1 by 5 it means
that
a1 equals to a1 minus 5 the value of a1
is 69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of a1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this
so we have so many operators we have so
many of them like let's try a few more
so we have multiply equals to we have
division equals to we have modulus
equals to so i'll write these and then
we'll see the output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for a3 a4 and a5 you can see
for a3 we have used multiply equals to
for a4 we have used divide equals to and
for a5 we have used modulus equals two
let's check the output here save it and
see it says the value of a3 50
it here we have taken a3 s5 it's 10 into
5 because a3 equals to a3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of a4 is 3.75
because we have used here 4 so instead
of 4 let's try to use 3 and save it see
here you can see it divides it and gives
you the quotient and the value of a4
divided by 3 is 5.
so
similarly for a5 it shows the value of
a5 is 6
because we have used the modulus
operator here and 20 divided by 7 we
have 6 as remainder
so
i hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in javascript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part
so here you can see we have two
variables where str1 and where str2 the
value of where str1 is hello and the
value of where str2 is world so what
we'll do we will add str1 and str2 so
let's check the output here save it and
see here you can see the output as hello
world
but there is no space between hello and
world keep this point in mind guys so if
you are adding two strings just like
this there will be no space between the
two string so if you want to add any
space between these two what you have to
do you have to mention it here
separately
and this this is a syntax if you want to
add space between your strings
so let's save it now and see here you
can see there is a space between hello
and world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another
string let's take it as whereas tr3 and
we'll give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do
we'll use the plus equal to operator
here str3 plus equals to
let's say
to
simply code
and
what we'll do we'll print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now see here you can see it says
hello world for the first str1 plus str2
it says hello world
for str3 it says welcome to simply code
see here the space is already given so
it will show this in the output but
between welcome and 2 if you want to add
space you have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here as well
plus sign yes
save it now and see here you can see
it says welcome to simply code with
proper space now we will cover the rest
of the operators now we are left with
five more these are the first three
operators now we are left with
conditional operators
logical operators we have bitwise
operator and we have comparison and
finally we have the type of operator so
these are the five operators we are
going to cover today
before we start with the operators let
us first discuss associativity talking
about associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity
let's understand it with the help of an
example
so here you can see i have taken three
variables i have taken variable a
and i have assigned it value as 12 i
have taken variable b
and the value assigned to b is 8 and
finally i have a variable result which
stores the value of a plus b
lastly what i am doing is i am printing
out the result variable inside the h1
tag here you can see i've used the h1
tags
and
i have used the plus operator to
concatenate the strings right i have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result
so the plus operator here is doing two
different tasks right
here you can see it is performing the
addition of two numbers right and here
you can see
it is used to concatenate two strings so
now let's talk about associativity
because i guess you guys are clear with
string operator till now we have
discussed them in the previous video
right so let's talk about associativity
now so certain operators have right to
left associativity
and certain operators have left to right
associativity
so when i say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left this is what we
are known as right to left associativity
and assignment operators like equals to
this have right to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable c
and we are giving it the value as
five and what we'll do will update
result as well let me first show you the
output of this particular program see
the output will be value of result is 20
and high there high there is
concatenated with the string value of
result is n20 is the actual answer the
20 is the value of result
so let's add one more variable here
let's say we are adding a variable c and
the value of c will be five
what we will do now we will update
result as well here you can see i have
done a plus b plus c
so
save it and here you can see the value
updated
to 25 the value of result is updated
right
so the plus operator has associativity
from left to right till now we have
talked about right to left as for
assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of c will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25
we know that javascript is a loosely
typed programming language right
which means that we don't have to
specify data types every time
like we are using if we are using any
data type we don't need to specify it
every time like
let's do one thing let's add a string
here so what we'll do we'll add a string
let's suppose i'm adding hello
so practically the answer would be hello
plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as hello
12 8 and 5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting
as string here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do
we'll
remove this string from here and we'll
add it somewhere else let's say we are
adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable d and the value will be 10
and what we will do we will perform a
plus b before the string and then we'll
perform c plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it
it says 20 hello 510
so when it reached out the first
variable it finds out that the first
variable is a number so it added the
first two numbers right it added 12 and
8 the answer is 20 then it came across
this string hello and then finally it
assumed that everything ahead of this
will be a string so that's the output 20
is the addition of a plus b and then the
string hello and finally we have the
value of c and d as string so we have
the value 5 and 10 not 15 right i hope
you guys get this
so
let's move on to conditional operators
the conditional operators assign a value
to a variable based on a certain
condition like it contains a condition
and you know for every condition like
there exists only two possibilities
either it can be true or it can be false
there is nothing else you can do with a
conditional operator so it works the
same as if else statements which we'll
cover in further videos the only
difference between if else and
conditional operators that it takes less
time or we can say its usage is pretty
easy
so here is the syntax for conditional
operators
so it seems pretty straight forward
right so here you can see we have a
variable name we have a condition
depending upon the condition we have two
values
here's the example as well
c
you can see we have a variable voter
next up we have a condition if h is less
than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15
so it will check if 15 is less than 18
it's true then it will print 2m or if
the value of h
is greater than 18 then it will print
false or you can say it will print old
enough here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 30. what we'll do in variable y i
have given it a condition so it will
check for x which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equal to 50.
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if you update the value of xcl let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60 save it now and see the output has
changed to true because 60 is greater
than 50 right
also if you want to write a message here
only you can do it write it here as
so we'll copy it from here we'll copy
document.write
and we'll paste it here
just remove this document.right and we
what we'll do we'll
use this bracket
here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write
value of
so
and now what we'll do we'll
save it
see it says value of true
so
or you can write any other message here
as well you can write value of x is
greater than or you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is
and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now
see here it says value is greater value
of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing and conditional
operators has three different parts
right
and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a
condition like here it is it's it has a
condition and it has two values right it
has true or false so that's why it is
also known as ternary operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables or values we can say we use
logical operators to check whether
multiple conditions are true or false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in javascript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or not are the three
operators present in javascript
the end operator here you can see
it it is holding two values right it
it has x less than 10 and y greater than
one
so the end operator will return true
only if both the conditions are true
like x has to be less than 10 and y has
to be
greater than 1 so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why
the output of the end operator will be
true for our operator the case is a bit
different so if any one of these two
conditions like we have two conditions
if any one of these two is true then the
output will be true and if both are
false then only the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to y if the
value x is holding is equals to that of
y
if the value is not equal then it will
return true
i hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value x and y
holding
if they are not equal then it will
return true if they are equal then it
will return false
right
we'll understand the programming concept
of logical operators in further videos
when we learn about control statements
we primarily use logical operators with
the if statement through which we'll
come across in the following video in
the next video we will go through the
control statements so we'll understand
the programming part of logical operator
there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen
these are the different types of
comparison operators present in
javascript we have equals 2 we have not
equals 2 we have equal value and data
type we have greater than less than and
we have a few more so
i hope you guys must remember from the
previous video that a single equals two
operator is an assignment operator so if
we are using a single equals to then it
will be considered as an assignment
operator for comparison we have to use
double equal to keep this thing in mind
whenever you are using any operator in
javascript or especially the equals 2
operator so if you want to compare two
values you have to use double equals to
because single equals two is used to
assign values this is an assignment
operator so let's move on to the
programming part now
so guys here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 10.
this code seems a little bit longer to
you but that's a simple piece of code
like i've used almost every comparison
operator we came across in the previous
slide i have used each one of them
and i have used the document.write after
every
comparison operator to put some spaces
in between so that you guys don't
confuse between them
so let's check the output now see as you
can see i have used the double equals to
the triple equals to i have used x not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with it
and 10 and 8 are not equals to so the
output will be false as similar for 10
and we have used the triple equals 2
operator which means equal value and
data type so
both 10 and 8 have equal data type they
both have the same data type that is
number but the values are different
so it will print false
for x not equals to it it says 10 is not
equals to it yeah 10 is not equals to it
actually so it will print true similarly
for x
naught equals to equals to it it will
check that
both the values are not equal but the
data types are equal right so it will
print true for this as well
for x greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater
than 8 so it will print true
similarly for it will check for x
smaller than 8 and it will check for x
greater than equals to it and also for x
less than equals to it
so
by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you
put to the right of it like
if you are using any data type and you
want to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say so you can
use the type of operator it will tell
you the actual data type of any variable
so
in javascript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see i have used four
different variables which are i've used
variable x
variable y and variable flag and
variable p so the values are different
the x is holding 17
y is holding hey there and flag has the
value as false and i have defined p but
i have not assigned it any value till
now so what i'll do i have used the type
of operator to find out the type of
every variable like here i have used it
for x for y for flag and for p
let's
check the output now
save it and see it says number string
boolean and undefined
see here we have given x the value as 17
so 17 is a number then it says it is a
number
for haiti it says it is a string for
false it says it is a boolean value like
in boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable p it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to
any variable like you are using the
variable as it is like here we have not
given it any value so if you are doing
this the type of operator will return
undefined so let's take an example of
null as well
let's declare another variable let's say
where
abc
and we'll give it the value as
null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable abc is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost seven
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers
if you know the numbers are stored in
binary format
bitwise operators work on 32 bit numbers
and we have decimal numbers like we
understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then converted back to a javascript
number
so
here you can see on your screen
we have four different
bitwise operators we have the and
operator we have or we have not and we
have zor or we can say exclusive or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see
we have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have x as 5
here you can see axis first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work
let's take an example of bitwise
operators
so here you can see i have taken two
variables i have taken variable x and
the value of variable x is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then i have used
all the four bitwise operators like i
have used x and y i have used x or y
i have used not x and i have used the
xor operator between x and y so let's
check the output now
here you can see
if we talk about the output
see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4 so
for x and y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for end
operators
it will return 1 if both the values are
1. if any one of the 2 values are 0 then
it will return 0 so what it will return
here it will return 0 for 0 0 for 1 0 it
will also return 0 similarly for 0 0 it
will also return 0 and for 1 month it
will return 1
which is the binary equivalent of one so
the answer here is one
for x or y it will return one if any one
of the two values are one
see if both are zero it will return zero
if any one of the two values is one it
will return one
it will return zero again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and zero one zero one is the binary
equivalent of five that's why the output
here is five
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as
minus x minus 1 so minus x minus 1 will
be
see minus x minus 1 will be
minus 5 minus 1 which is minus 6 so this
is a bit different here the not operator
here is a bit different
for
xor operator or we can say exclusive or
it will return 4
why it will return 4 it will return 1
when
any one of the 2 values is 1 if both are
1 then also it will return false it will
return 1 only in 1 condition if any one
of the 2 values is one then only it will
return one that's why the output here
the output here will be zero one zero
zero that's why it's written as four
which is the binary equivalent of zero
one zero zero the term control statement
is pretty self-explanatory and
straightforward right we came across
javascript statements in previous videos
javascript statements are the
instructions that tells the browser to
perform specific actions
control statements are also instructions
and they govern the flow of control in a
program
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right
so this is the basic flow right from
statement one till statement n and it
will execute each statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu
every time
for example let's suppose
you are in line 5 and you want to print
this line 10 times so what should you do
you can write this line 10 times or
you can copy paste it right okay let's
forget about 10 times let's suppose you
have to use this
code or we can say let's suppose you
have to print this statement 100 times
doing this like copy pasting it for 100
times or writing this statement 400
times that's useless and unnecessary
right so that's where control statements
comes into picture we'll discuss them in
a while let's assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in javascript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity
like if we want to perform a certain
activity n number of times or if you
want to make a certain decision making
kind of scenarios in your program that's
where we need control statements in
javascript
in javascript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's where we use conditional
statements we have two different types
of conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times
instead of writing them again and again
we use loops so loops are basically
statements
we use loops to perform any activity n
number of times with specific conditions
so in javascript we have four different
type of loops we have for loop while
loop do while loop and foreign loop
so the for loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages
but this foreign loop this is a new type
of loop present in javascript
we use foreign loop with objects we'll
go through objects in
upcoming videos and of course we'll be
looking at each of these control
statements in detail
will have a particular video for each of
these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements
the break is used to exit a switch
statement or loop like when used in a
loop
it breaks the loop and continues
executing the code after it
and
on the other hand the continue statement
breaks a single iteration when used in a
loop when we use continuous statement in
a loop it breaks a single iteration and
it breaks the iteration only if the
specified condition occurs and then it
will continue with the next iteration in
the loop
so the if else conditional statement is
used whenever we work with condition
it can be either a single condition or
maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic program
with a single condition
so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
else if statement so we'll create a new
file today so
i hope you guys know the importance of
creating a separate file for every topic
you know it will be easy for you to work
or to find out that separate file later
if you want to revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable x and the value of x is
10 so what we are doing in this program
is we are checking if the value the
variable x is holding that is the value
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is
greater than 10 so we have only two
conditions either the value can be less
than 10 or the value can be greater than
10 or equals to 10 as
so here in this program what we'll do
will
first will update this value as 8 so the
variable x is holding the value 8
so to check the output let's save it and
here you can see it says the value of x
is less than 10 of course the value 8 is
always less than 10 right so for 8
that's fine it will say the value is
less than 10 and similarly if we do the
same for let's say 11 save it now and
see it says the value of x is greater
than 10
so that's quite simple right but what if
we are giving the value as 10
we know 10 is equals to 10 so save it
now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
this is happening because what we did we
as we told the interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only x is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10
so here what it is doing it is checking
if the value is less than 10 so that it
says okay let's print this statement if
the value is less than 10
or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals to or greater than
10 it will print the value of x is
greater than 10.
to avoid this type of misunderstanding
we use an elsif statement so the concept
of elsif statement is the same as if
statement what we are doing we are using
multiple conditions right we are giving
it more than one condition so how to use
elsif it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value x is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10
and what we'll do will update it is
let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to 10 right so i hope you guys
are getting this
the execution flow for this program will
be like it will check for the first
condition if x is less than 10 if yes it
will print the value of x is less than
10. if no it will move on the to the
following condition like under the else
if statement it finds a condition that
if x is equals to 10 it will check for
it if yes if x is equals to 10 then it
will print the value of x is equals to
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that
if x is less than 10 or if x is equals
to 10 now we'll take a look at some
basic programs other than this one we'll
take a look at a few more basic programs
so here is the another program
what we are doing here is we are taking
a variable x and the value of x is 5. so
what we are doing is we are checking if
the number is an even number or an odd
number
thing you have to keep in mind is the
logic to find whether a number is even
or an odd number so to check uh whether
a number is even you what we do will
divide that number with 2 right what
basically we want is we want
the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written x mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the remainder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2 else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even an odd number
so here we are with another program
here it says we have a variable y and
the value of y is
let's say
and what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or zero
so we have three different conditions
either number can be positive or it can
be a negative number any number greater
than zero is a positive number right and
any number less than zero is a negative
number and the third one is
a number zero it's neither positive nor
negative
so let's check for the number eight save
it and see here you can see it is a
positive number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative
and at the same time we'll check for
even and odd also
if we are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether the number is
positive or negative and
order even
so the two methods we will discuss them
one by one the first one here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement
so this one here you can see right in
front of your screen is
the
nested if method so here you can see we
have used the if statement we have given
one more condition inside another if
statement so first it will check whether
a number is positive
or not for x greater than 0 it will
check if the number x is greater than 0
then if yes if it will find it that yes
this number is greater than 0 then it
will move on to the
nested if and it will check for odd or
even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number
is positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so
here you can see the difference what the
interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd
so if it finds that the number is even
it will print negative and even
otherwise it will print negative and odd
and the last condition is for the number
zero
let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as
it
so save it now here it says the positive
and even so 8 is a positive number and
even as well
let's update the value of x as minus
save it now it says negative and odd
number minus 5 is a negative odd number
right so that's how it will check for
positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program
we have an alternate method as well here
you can see on your screen we have
written a program and here we have taken
a variable x the functioning of both the
programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and
order even
so
here you can see i have taken a variable
x let's say the value of x is
it will check for
x greater than 0 and x
mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so we
have 4 different conditions right a
number is
greater than 0 that means a number is
positive and
even a number is positive and odd a
number is negative and even a number is
negative and odd and the final one is a
number is zero
okay we have five conditions and we have
to specify these four conditions here so
here we you can see we are using the
logical and operator this means it will
print this statement let's suppose for
this statement it will print this only
if both the conditions are true
right if the number if the value x is
holding is both greater than 0 and an
even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and odd
so the number 7 is greater than 0
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser
it will print this line because the
number is
positive and odd
right the switch case is another
conditional control statement and just
like the if else control statement there
is a difference between the usage of if
else and switch case statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use switch case
over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user for
an input between 50 and 100 a numeric
input basically and in the output we
have to print the textual form of that
number suppose if the user enters 75
right the output will be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else
or we can say elsif control statement
but the program will be so lengthy and
not so clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have a number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option
we'll get to know why in a bit
so let's move on to the programming part
and today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number
so we have 12 months in a year for
example if we enter 4 then the output
will be april and if we enter 8 then the
output will be august because august is
the 8th month of the year right so i
hope you guys are clear with the
question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using if else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario so let's create a
variable first let's say we are creating
a variable where month and
you can
give any value to this variable from 1
to 12 you can provide it with any
initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month
and
the value we are providing it one as the
hardcore initial value for simplicity
again we are not taking the input from
the user or from the browser to do so we
have to first go through the dom
manipulations and we'll go through it in
later videos so let's start with the
switch case now
the syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as 1 for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so
next up we have an open and curly braces
for the body of the switch case we have
to test for 12 different conditions
inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value
month variable might hold like 1 2 3 and
so on followed by a colon right so we
have to write the value 1 and
a column not a semicolon but a colon
keep this thing in mind guys
and below that we are going to write
what we want when the value is one like
what the output we want when the value
is one so we have to write document
dot write
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is january so we are
writing here
january
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is one you
will get the output as january save it
and here you can see the output is
january
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
january
right next we'll use a break statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is
once we are done with our output we get
our output right once we are done with
case 1 we get our output as january this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case so to understand this
much better let's write here one more
case
so let's say we are
writing here one more case as
case 2
and the output will be
document
dot write
the second month is february right
and february we can write so
we'll include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says january
so if we don't include this break
statement here when the interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is one
right so it will print january
but it will print other statements as
well so for example if we remove this
break statement and save it now see you
can see here the output as january and
february january and february both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here see
the value is 1 and if we include break
statement here
the moment the interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as january it
will come out of the switch case
so i hope you guys are getting this
similarly will write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be june if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
october and so on and so forth
now the question here is what if we try
to write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that
if we try to write any value other than
these 12 values from 1 to 12 if
if we leave these values then if we try
to write another value like if we write
here 13
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see
there is no output and there might be no
error for this as well so if you try to
check for an error go to inspect and
check out
see there's no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here
default
with the colon and write
document
dot right and
let's suppose we are writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right
in else statement we don't need to
specify any particular condition any
condition other than the if condition or
else if condition will fall inside the
else statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so
you must include this default case in
your program every time by using
switchgear because it's quite useful you
know
okay
so this is the complete program to find
out
the month by accepting its number
if you try
and save it now it will say june if you
try 10 save it it will say october if we
try 12 save it it will say december so i
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because
the switch case in javascript works
differently from other languages like
switch case is also present in c plus
plus and java but in javascript it is a
bit different so in javascript
switch case can accept numbers it can
accept strings and boolean values as
well
now let's have a look at how the switch
case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is june right and you can use
this string in case as well so here you
have to give the case as a string value
right because we are using switch case
statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be june the output should
be 6th month and when the value is july
the output will be 7th month so let's
check it out if this is working or not
let's save this program and see for june
it says sixth month and similarly we can
check it for july as well let's check
for july
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to
it will be similar like there is no
difference for default case let me show
you how
we'll write here wrong input
and save it and now let's try to change
the value here let's say we are using
may
save it and see it says wrong input but
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for two as well
it will give you the output when the
value is either june or july
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for boolean values
so what you have to do instead of 2 you
have to give here a boolean value let's
suppose you are writing here true
and for true you have to change the case
as well for true
you have to change the output as
let's say for true it the output will be
one
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now
and see here for true it says 1 the
output you can see here is 1
and if you try to do the same for false
like let's write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says
you can see the output is correct right
we will discuss
our first iterative control statement
that is the for loop in javascript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements will make our
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for loop which is a first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that
we use for loop when we are clear with
the number of iterations in advance
so let's start with our first program in
this program we will print the
multiplication table of 10
from 10 into 1 to 10 into 10
let's start with coding
first we write the for keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization which is separated by a
semicolon next up we have the condition
and finally
we have the increment or decrement
so this is the syntax for for loop
next up we have the open and the closed
curly braces for the body of for loop
we'll change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one
so we'll what we'll do we'll leave it
here only we'll change it from here so
in the initialization part what we are
going to do is we will create a variable
let's say we are creating a variable
where a and the value of and the initial
value of a will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use
because sometimes what happens is the
loop runs forever because of a wrong
condition which will ultimately crash
our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for loop should execute here in
this case
we want to print the table of 10 right
we want to have 10 iterations
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to 1 and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10
it will start from
a equals to 1 and it will go till a less
than or equals to 10 and next up we will
use the increment operator we want to
increment the value of a by 1 every time
right so we'll use increment operator a
plus plus or we can say a equals to a
plus 1 both are the same things right so
here the condition will be like this for
variable a equals to 1 a less than
equals to 10 and a plus plus
so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will be increased by
1 every time
because we have used the increment
operator right next up the body of for
loop will go like so what we want to
print here we want to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot write and inside document dot right
we'll use the h1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so we'll
multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser
so we'll close the h1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100.
so what is happening is firstly the for
loop is also known as the entry control
loop it means
that the condition is checked initially
the first time the for loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value stored at variable a is
one initially the value is one next up
it will check for a less than equals to
10 is a which is 1 is 1 less than equals
to 10 then true the control will be
shifted to document.write and it will
print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2 now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now and after that it it will
print 20 here and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10 now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10
no we know that 11 is not less than
equal to 10 right then it comes out of
the loop and it will print nothing after
that so this is the basic working of the
for loop we'll go through one more
program wherein we'll print the odd
numbers
between 1 and 10.
so what are odd numbers odd numbers are
those numbers which are not divisible by
2 right so we have the odd numbers as 1
3 5 7 9 and we want to print them so the
difference between each number is of 2
the 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right
so what we have to do is we have to
write here a
plus equals to 2 we have to increase the
value of a by 2
and instead of writing here 10 into a
because this time we don't want to
print any multiplication table we want
to print a number only right so we'll
use a only
save it and check the output it says
so these are the odd numbers present
between 1 and 10.
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for loop
while loop is also an entry control loop
which means that the condition will be
checked first so the question here is
how while loop is different from the for
loop if you guys remember when we
discussed that we must know the exact
number of iterations then only we can
use the for loop right so the while loop
is preferred when we are not aware of
the number of iterations or we can say
we don't know if the condition will be
true for a certain number of times
we'll start with the programming part
now
and then we will discuss more about when
to use while loop over for loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program
we will print odd numbers up to a
specific number
let's say we want to print all the odd
numbers up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right
we came across the same program in the
previous video as well but this time we
will use the while loop instead of for
loop
so the syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use
the code goes like we start with the
while keyword
then
opening and closing round brackets and
finally the body of while loop in curly
braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we used the for loop we
had three different parts right we had
the initialization we had conditions and
the increment decrement part here we
have only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize a variable first let's
say we have a variable x and the value
of x will be 1.
we used here 1 because
1 is the very first odd number right
after that inside the condition what we
want to do is we want to print the odd
numbers
up to 50. so while the condition will be
like while
x
less than equals to 50
so the loop will go till x is less than
or equals to 50
or we can say x less than 15. that
depends on us if we want to check for 50
or not so the odd numbers will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to
50. so the last odd number will be 49.
so inside the while loop we will print
the value of x so here we will print the
value of x let's print it
document
dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the h1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well then we had
the condition we have a condition here
as well and then finally it has an
increment or decrement part right so
here we don't have that same increment
or decrement part we have to do it
separately so we'll increment the value
of x here only so here we will write x
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as
x equals to x plus 2 you guys are aware
of it right so
the reason is simple because we want to
go from 1 to 3 to 5 and so on that's why
we use x plus equals to 2. we
incremented the value of x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says 1 3 5 7 9
and
so on and so forth till 49 so 49 is the
last odd number before 50 because we are
checking between 1 and 50 right so 49 is
the last
odd number
let me show you how the program goes
into an infinite loop
so for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see
it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
loop looks like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to
open a new tab and then again we have to
run the program with
correct increment part so here you can
see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
up to 50 and the last one is 49
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for loop so where to use
while loop
over for loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is why we
want to do something let's say we want
to print something on the screen or if
the input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do while loop in
javascript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for loop and the
while loop are entry control loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do-while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the
loop's body thus an exit control loop
executes at least once even if the test
condition fails or we can say the
condition is wrong
the loop will execute once
using the do while loop is relatively
easy it seems like we are giving the
system a command to do something while
the condition is something
so let's start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we will write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the do-while
loop the do part and the while part or
we can say the condition part while part
is the part where we write the condition
so let's define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable x and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken five as a random
value you can take one as well now
inside the condition part of the do
while loop this is the condition part
where we are using the while keyword so
we'll give a condition let's say we are
using while x greater than 5 it will
check for the condition that if the
value of x is greater than 5
or if the value of x is smaller than or
equal to 5 it will come out of the loop
in the do part we will write what we
want to do let's say we want to print a
single sentence here
we write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always so if
we try to save this program and let's
try to run this
here you can see the output is welcome
to simply code a single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the do-while loop
will perform this
particular statement when the
document.write will be performed after
that it will check for the condition if
x is greater than 5 or not
if we use here 6 instead of 5
let's try to write here 6 instead of 5
and if we run this program now it will
go into an infinite loop because we are
not performing the increment decrement
operator here right
as we have discussed in the previous
videos the importance of increment
decrement part
so we need to do it here after the
document.write part so what we'll do
here we'll write x minus minus today we
are using x minus minus and for the
other two loops we use the plus
increment operator right so the x minus
minus is the same as x equals to x minus
1 let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition
and it will print here welcome to simply
code for the first time when the loop
will start executing it will first
perform this statement and it will write
here welcome to simply code so then it
will perform x minus minus means the
value of x is now 5 because we are
decrementing the value by 1. so when the
value of x is 5 then it will check for
the condition if x is greater than 5 or
not so here we can see clearly x is not
greater than 5 because x equals to 5 and
it is equals to 5 right so it will come
out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose
we use here 10 instead of 6 now
and let's print the value of x as well
it will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x
and we'll use a
space
so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the brtech and now let's
try to run this program
here you can see the output goes from 10
to 6 and it prints welcome to simply
code every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do while loop when we
want the code to output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
do-while loop this video is just a
syntax demonstration
we'll go through the examples
of all the three loops present in
javascript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each loop
we'll go through
so let's start this session with the
first problem statement so the first
problem statement goes like this so here
we have to write a program to check
whether a number is prime or not i hope
you guys are aware of what prime numbers
are right so a prime number is a
positive number that is only divisible
by 1 and itself for example
2 3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right
if we take an example let's say we are
taking an example of 7 so 7 is a number
which is divisible by 1 and 7 only no
other number can divide 7 right so here
in this code we have to check whether a
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first
so we have a variable number and the
value of variable number can be any
random value like any number you want to
check if the number is prime number or
not you can give that value to the
variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime
whose value is a boolean value right it
can be true for a prime number or it can
be false for a non-prime number
so we have used comments in this program
to make it easier for you guys to
understand so here we have used the if
statement to check if the number is 1
because we know that 1 is neither a
prime number nor a composite number
right so we have to check if the
user enters the value 1 or if we are
giving the value 1 we have to check for
it so if user enters the value 1 it will
print this statement that 1 is neither
prime nor composite
here in elsif we are checking if the
value of number is greater than 1 or not
so if the value of number is greater
than 1 the control will be shifted to
for loop present inside the else if
statement right here you can see we have
the for loop here the control will be
shifted to this for loop so here you can
see we have initialized the variable i
and the initial value is set to 2
that's because any prime number is
divisible by 1 as well right so it won't
make any sense to include 1 here
we'll start from 2 and we'll check until
the value of i becomes half of the value
of number so if we take an example of 10
we'll check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now i hope you guys are aware of
how to use for loop and why we are using
for loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
loop so then we have the i plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of i by one after every iteration until
the value of i becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent i equals
to equals to 0
so here is the main condition to check
if the number is divisible by
i or not
so the execution will be like if we are
taking here a number 10 it will start
from 2
and it will check if the remainder is 0
or not so if the remainder is 0
then the value of is prime will be
changed to false and it will come out of
the loop
next it will check for the value of s
prime if the value of s prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print
n or we can say then it will print that
the number is a prime number else it
will print that
the number is not a prime number if the
value of is prime is false for example
when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of s prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0.
or we can say the remainder will be zero
so the value of s prime will be changed
to false and for false it will print
number is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than one if the number entered
by the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take here minus 5
so it will print the number is not a
prime number
because by the usual definition of
prime numbers
any negative number
cannot be a prime number that's a usual
definition right so we have to keep this
thing in mind and here in this else loop
we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and
the output says 83 is a prime number as
83 is not divisible by any number except
1 and 83 for example if we take here any
number which is divisible by so let's
say we are taking 75 save it now and see
it says 75 is not a prime number okay
here's a spelling mistake it says 75 is
a not prime number so here we will
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically
so let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking
minus 7
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now
so it says the number is not a prime
number
or if we want to try for one as well
let's take it as one
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that 1 is
neither a prime nor a composite number
you can try this program with the help
of other loops as well
so let's move on to the second problem
statement but before that let me take
you through
the same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the while
loop for the same instead of for loop
here you can see we have used while i
less than a
number by 2 and we have given the
increment condition here and we have
initialized the value of i
at
the start of the program so if we try to
run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in javascript
to check whether a number is an
armstrong number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program before proceeding
to the coding part let's have a look at
what is an armstrong number so an
armstrong number of three digits
is an integer such that the sum of the
cubes of its digits is equal to the
number itself
so for example 153 is an armstrong
number since
1 into 1 into 1 it means the cube of the
digit 1
plus the cube of 5 that is 5 into 5 into
5 which is equal to 125 and
the cube of 3 which is 3 3's are 9 and 9
3's are 27 so it will go like 125
plus 27 plus
1 so which is equal to 153 so an
armstrong number of three digits is an
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself so here we have the code for the
same this is the code to check whether
the number is an armstrong number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an armstrong number
next up we have taken a variable sum and
the initial value of sum is 0. we have
used the variable sum to store the value
of the cubes
and next up we have a temporary variable
so that we can break a three digit
number and we need
the number after all this all this
program all these loops and all will
need the number we'll need the original
number to compare it with the sum of the
cubes which will be hold in sum
so
but we need to break the number as well
right so we need a temporary variable to
break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than zero so the initial
value of temp will be one five three
here in this particular case the initial
value will be one five three and the
loop will run until the value of one
five three is greater than zero
next up we have a variable remainder
that stores the
last digits value as we are dividing 153
by 10.
so
the remainder here will be 3 so the
value saved that variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen with we are updating the value of
sum and the new value of sum will be
0 plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are 9
and 9 3s are 27 so
the
updated value of sum will be 27 next up
we are
removing the last digit from the number
so
for example we have here 153 and if we
divide 153 by 10
the answer will be 15.3
that's why we are using here percent
because what percent will do it will
convert the float value into an integer
so if we try to perform a simple divide
in javascript like if we try to divide
153 by 10 it will give us 1 5.3 it will
give us a float value but we want an
integer value right so pass it will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be 1 5
then again this loop will be executed
and
for this time the variable reminder will
hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5
which is 27 plus 125 right so the new
value of sum will be 152
and then again it will go to the temp
and it will divide 15 by 10 and it will
change the value to an integer so 1.5
will be changed to 1 and next up the
final value of temp is 1 which is
greater than 0 right so it will divide
10 by 1 and the remainder will be 1.
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10
using the power sent but this time the
value will be 0 because there is no
remainder
right next up we'll compare the value of
the sum and the number variable so the
sum variable here it is holding the
value as 153. we break this number into
three different parts then we took the
cube of these three number and added
them so the final value of the variable
sum is 153 and the initial value of
number or we can say the value we gave
to the variable number is 153 so right
it will print here that 153 is an
armstrong number
or if we use any other number instead of
153 let's suppose we are using 121 so it
will print 121 is not an armstrong
number let's
check out the output once let's save it
and see the output is 153 is an
armstrong number so if we change the
value of one five three to
one to one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the answer here will be 10 because the
cube of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8
and the cube of the final one is 1 so 8
plus 1 plus 1 is equals to 10
so that's why 1 2 1 is not an arm strong
number
let's move on to our last problem
statement
where we'll use the do while loop to
find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program to find
the factorial of a number
so factorial of an integer is the
product of an integer and all the
integers below it or we can say before
it till 1 so if we take an example of 5
so the factorial of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be
5 into 4 into 3
into 2 into 1
or if we don't include 1 that's totally
fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two we did
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable i which is
initialized as one then we have a
variable n which is five and then we
have a
variable f whose value is 1 f is for
factorial and n is for number we want to
check the factorial of and i is for
checking the condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where if we for example if we are taking
5 then the loop will go from 1 into 2
into 3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that
number it's not
like if we are using
from 5 towards 1 but we are going from 1
towards 5
the answer will be same right because we
are multiplying all the numbers in both
the cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable f and the value of f
is also one as you know
so here we are using the do while loop
for the first iteration it will perform
this so the value of f for the first
iteration will be f equals to f into i
which means f equals to 1 into 1 which
is 1
so the value of i will be increased and
it will become 2 and now it will check
for
while 2 is less than equals to n yes 2
is less than n so it will again go up
and it will update the value of f
and the new value of of f will be 1 into
2 that is 2 then again the value will be
increased and it will become 3
and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of i will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5
and then it will multiply 4 with 6
because the value of f was 6 right so 4
into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of i will be 5 and it
will check if the value of i is less
than or equals to 5 right while i is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of i will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of the number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120
because see here we have used the
factorial of n n is 5
and the factorial is 120 so if we
try to give any other number here other
than 5 let's say we are using here 10
save it
it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
or it's 36 lakh twenty eight thousand
eight hundred so if you try to multiply
ten into nine into eight into seven so
on till
two or we can say 1 the answer will be
this you can check it you can google it
or you can go through it in your
calculator the typical definition of
function states that to work in a proper
or in a particular way
similarly functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions
so a function has a particular name and
we can reuse that block of code again
and again in our entire program
for example
let's suppose that we have to add two
numbers in a program that's a basic
program right sum of two numbers so
let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable x and the value
of x will be 10
then again we are going to take a
variable y and the value of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be
x plus y
so
the last thing
we are going to do is we are going to
print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15
so what is happening is
the value of x plus y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right
now consider a scenario where we have to
do this addition for n number of times
at different intervals so we have to
perform the same task of addition at
different intervals so in that case what
we can do is we can copy paste this same
code repeatedly but the length of the
program will increase because of that
right and it doesn't make any sense to
copy paste the same code again and again
so this is where functions come into
play with the help of functions we can
create a separate function to do this
particular task and we can call that
function again and again i'll take you
through it so basically a function has
three parts will go through each of them
a function has function declaration then
it has function definition and then
finally it has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions
so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function
so let's move on and see how the
function looks like how the syntax of
function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets
which denotes that this is a function
this is the way to write a function
next up we have a pair of curly braces
for the body of the function so this is
the basic syntax of how a function looks
like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
javascript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program
this is happening because we haven't
called the function yet right so to call
the function we have to write a single
word just write sum
with
opening and closing
round brackets and save it now now you
can see the output here is 15 so this is
known as function calling the program
already knows that there is a function
by the name sum
it will go and check for the same if the
function is there or not if the program
finds it it will execute the function
next up a function can also have
parameters what do i mean by parameters
is we don't have to declare these
variables variable x and variable y here
instead of declaring them here we can
pass these values to the function let's
say we are passing x and y here or we
can pass a and b any variable you want
to pass
you can pass it here
now we can remove this variable x and
variable y
we have to write here where because we
still need the variable total and next
up we have to pass the value for these
variables when we call the function so
we have to pass the values here let's
say we are passing the values as
and
so
let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output as seven
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of four if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome to
and instead of three will pass
simply code right now let's save this
program and see the output it says
welcome to simply code we don't have to
worry about the data type we'll use here
because javascript is a loosely typed
language right so the function will
automatically adapt to the data type
according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable x holds the value welcome to
and the variable y is having simply code
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as
parameter passing in functions
let's move on and discuss the return
types in functions
so a function can also return a value
right now
we can see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document dot right from here and we'll
paste it somewhere else on the program
outside the function so we'll paste it
here right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there's nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and global variable
we will discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so
here you can see it says total is not
defined right so now what we have to do
is we have to write here
return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to and simply code
right
so these parameters will go as x and y
and we are getting the
concatenation of welcome to simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function
the value of this total variable will be
given out of the function
so there has to be a particular variable
to hold the value returned by the
function
we'll
use a variable here let's say we are
using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the lhs and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this
that whenever we are using an assignment
operator the assignment will be done
from right towards the left
so whatever value the function will
return upon calling will be assigned to
the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of simply code we'll use a
15 and we are going to print here output
on the browser because the variable
output is holding the value returned by
the function right so let's save it now
and see the output is 50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in javascript
with a quick small program we already
know that javascript is a loosely typed
scripting language right that means we
don't need to specify the data types
every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed whenever needed in this
particular video we are going to discuss
the scope of variables in javascript so
what does this scope mean in variables
so scope refers to the life of a
variable in a program
there are basically two types of
variables present in javascript local
variables and global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable variable may have two different
types of scope so let's have a look at
these two different types of variables
with the help of examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable where a and the value of a will
be 5. so we have created a variable here
and let's print the value of this
variable in the browser so what we'll do
we'll print this value in the
browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a
so here you can see the value is 5.
so we can print the value of this
variable anytime and anywhere in our
program right so if we try to copy this
line from here
and we'll paste it somewhere else in a
program let's say we are pasting it here
so if we try to save it now see here you
can see that we have two values of a
because we have printed a twice here
right once we have used this a here then
we have used this a here so here you can
see we have two values of a five and
five so this variable a is a global
variable which means
its life is available throughout the
entire program or the entire script we
can say
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll
make a function here let's say we are
creating a function
function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where x and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
but we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5. so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable x which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now
the same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a javascript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for global
variables so global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the programs
running
or we can say until the tab is open
the next exciting thing about global
variables is
that we can access global variables from
inside the function so what we'll do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here
so now what we'll do we'll declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
a variable where y and the value of y
will be
15.
so
copy this line
and paste it again now what we will do
we will try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15 10 is the value
of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared x inside the function whereas
variable y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what global variables are one more
exciting thing i want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in javascript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
var1 okay we have not used any var
keyword so what we are doing is we are
declaring a variable and the value of
where one is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the where keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function
okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and we'll comment this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here
var1 save this
and see if
you don't understand it let me change
the value of where1 let's change this
value to 20 save it now and see the
output here is 10 and 20. so where one
is a variable which is declared without
using the where keyword right so we can
access this variable from outside the
function as well any variable which is
declared without using where keyword is
a global variable keep this thing in
mind guys we came across the different
types of data types present in
javascript
in the previous video where we came
across the types of primitive data types
in javascript we discussed number string
and we had boolean null and undefined
right so these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
javascript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where x and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have hi there as the value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and we'll print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable x so
i hope you guys are aware of that if
you're not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
javascript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable x and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right i hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and
here we'll use
type of x
so let's
save it
and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable x so strings are
helpful
for holding data that can be represented
in textual form so let's move on to a
first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in javascript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of html
tags in javascript right for example we
use the heading tag so often
like when we are using the
document.write to print anything on the
browser we use heading tag quite a lot
right so the thing to notice here is
that these tags behaves as html tags
right we use them inside the double
inverted commas just like strings but
they still act like html tags so let's
understand this with the help of an
example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
dot right and we'll write here hi there
and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic html tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the break tag i
hope you all are aware of the break tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we try to print
a sentence and we are using the br tag
right so let's print it on the browser
so we are using the break tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to simply code
so
we use this break tag in a string right
so the output
what we were expecting was hi there and
the br should be written in
string but there's a difference in the
output right the br tag is actually
functioning as an html tag
so here the break tag works the same as
it did for html so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
html tag inside the javascript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of escape characters present
in javascript
so
let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we will remove this break tag and
suppose we want to print this on screen
so we want this on our screen and we
want the welcome to be inside the double
inverted comma in output as well
so if we try to run this program now
there will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if
it gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error
it says missing
after the argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome
so if we try to run this program as it
is it's not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma in the syntaxes we
have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right so that's how you can print this
on a screen next up if we want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we'll print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma now we'll write
s
the output will be it's all right
so
we have to use them because
we need them in our program at times
right so to avoid any confusion one must
know how to use this sequence character
in javascript let's save this and see
if we try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it's in similar way
without using the backslash escape
character
lastly if we want to put a backslash in
our string if we want to put a backslash
we want to show it in the browser so the
syntax for that will go like
we have the document.right right so here
we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes
is called
backslash
so let's try to print this
so here one thing you can notice
only a single backslash is printed on
the browser the first one is used as a
backslash escape character and the
second one which we have used will be
printed on the browser
we have a few more escape sequence
present in javascript like the backslash
and or we can say newline
we don't use them quite often i'll let
you know if we use them in future so for
now it's enough for escape sequences
present in javascript so if you guys
remember we discussed data type in
previous videos right so data types in
javascript are of two kinds we discussed
the primitive data types and the other
type is non-primitive or we can say
complex or composite data types right so
an array comes under the category of
composite data types or non-primitive we
can say
so
the basic definition of array states
that an array is a collection of
elements stored in contiguous memory
locations so array is a list of similar
type of elements or in javascript array
acts a bit different from other
programming languages we can discuss it
later so let's understand the concept of
arrays with the help of an example will
move to the programming part directly
let's consider a scenario
where we have a collection of similar
types of variables suppose we have a
list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be
let's say
honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car 2 and the value of car 2
will be kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car 3
and the value of car 3 will be let's say
ford so here we have taken three
different car manufacturers we have
honda we have kia and we have four and
we have three different variables right
so if we want to print all three of them
what we have to do is we have to use the
document.write method right so we have
to use the document.write again and
again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot write and we will print the value of
all three variables
so here we have printed the value of all
three variables right we have carbon the
value was honda we have honda here we
have kia and we have ford as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have 100 values here instead of just
three values or maybe we can say we have
thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right
that's where arrays come into play what
we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable by
doing this we don't have to access each
and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to define an array here first
so the syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
we'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use honda kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as honda the next one we
have is
kia
and the last one we have is
ford right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have honda we have kia and we
have four
so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of hundred car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
area so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here
paste it here
and the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes
and now let's save this program
and see here you can see we have all the
three elements of the array we have
honda we have kia and we have ford as
well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type
with one single name and can hold
multiple values here the array name is
car and it stores three similar values
right here we have three string values
we have honda kia and 4 so this array
can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array
so what if we want to print a single
value from these three values we have we
have honda here and 4 right so if we
want to print kia let's suppose so it's
easy to print this on a browser all we
need to know is the index number of that
value so the index number in the case of
arrays starts from zero and
goes further
so we have three values here
as we can see so the index value
for these variables will be so for honda
the index value will be
zero and for kia the index value will be
1 and for 4 the index value will be 2.
so the index value starts from 0 and
goes on further so one thing to keep in
mind guys whatever number of values an
array is holding the last index value
will always be 1 less than the number of
values so as here you can see we have 3
values right so the index number of the
last value will be 1 less than 3
it means the index number will be 2
because the index number starts from 0.
let's try to access the element present
at index 1
so we have kia here right all we have to
do is we have to put square brackets
here in the document dot right here we
have to put square brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here 1 and if we save this program
now so here you can see we have kia only
it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
kia
we can also loop through this area using
the index values let's say we want to
print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here i hope you guys are aware of the
for loop by now we'll write here so
we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for loop here and we will print here
for will take a variable i
and the value of i will initial value
will be 0
and then we'll give the condition the
condition will be i less than 3 because
we know there are three values only and
it will go till 2 only because it's
going for the index value and the final
condition will be i
plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces
because this is the syntax for
for loop and the i value will iterate
through the array and print all the
values present at indexes till the index
2.
so the same thing goes for 100 elements
as well we can use the for loop to
access all the 100 elements in separate
lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing kia kia and kia because
we have
particularly mentioned here cars
present at index one so we have to
remove one here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here i
and
if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the i
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2 so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array
we can use the same iteration concept
for doing so
so guys there's another way to represent
an array in javascript it goes like this
we have a let's say we have a variable
this time we'll take the variable as
well fruits
so the syntax will be like new we have
to use the new keyword and then we will
use
new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay
and we can access the elements of these
array with the help of a for loop we can
use the similar for loop here so if we
copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars
we'll use a
fruits
right and we'll give the value as i
because we want to
i trade the variable i through each
index so we have once again the index
value as 0 for apple one for banana and
two for mango
let's comment this program as well so
that it will be easy for you guys to
understand
let's save this program now
and see we have the list of all the
elements present at array fruits so we
have apple we have banana and we have
mango printed on our browser
so this way of array representation or
declaration is less recommended because
the other way which we discussed earlier
like when we discuss the car
manufacturers
so that way is a bit easier to use so
i'll recommend that way only because
this way is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys errors in
javascript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like java and c plus plus so errors in
javascript have dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime
just like we saw the string methods in
the previous video for arrays also we
have a few methods like if we want to
add elements into an array or if we want
to delete an element from an array we
have the push and pop methods available
to do such tasks
to add an element into an array we use
the push method and the syntax for
pushing elements into an array goes like
so we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push
something inside the array
right
we'll write here the variable name dot
we use the push method and we'll push
whatever value we want to push let's say
we are adding another car manufacturer
let's say we are adding nissan
we have to change the value here as well
because what will happen we have used
the condition i less than 3 so it will
check for indexes till index 2 only it
won't check for index 3 so if we write
here i less than 4 it will check for
nissan now let's save this and see a new
value is pushed into the array which is
nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the
pop option now if we use car.pop and
let's run this program
and see it says undefined this is
happening because as you can see we have
pushed the value nissan into our array
so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular
element now if we pop out that
particular element so if we try to use
cars.pop once again
let's save it now and see it removed the
element forward as well so
let's try to push one more
value in this particular scenario let's
say we are pushing a value as
hyundai
and now let's run this so you can see
here it have inserted hyundai in place
of ford because we have used the pop
method to put food out of our array
so i hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
areas in javascript which are already
predefined to do some specific task
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in javascript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length property is used to
find the length of the array so if we
use it in a for loop in place of this i
less than 4 so
here you can see we have used i less
than 4 now if we write here
array dot length so if we write here
car
dot length so
now we don't have to change this value
again and again so if we are inserting
any value or if we are removing any
value from this for loop so if we are
removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is
let's say we have the length here 3
right so it will check for the length
and it will be 1 less than the length of
the array so if we run this program now
it will work fine i hope you guys
understood the concept of array methods
present in javascript the other main
difference
array has in javascript which makes it
different from c plus plus or java is we
can add elements with other data types
in javascript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we'll push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push
a numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car
so we can
use
any data type inside array in javascript
objects are the most powerful and the
most used data types in javascript so
far we have seen that we can use a
single variable to store a value the
value can be a string or a number or any
other type of variable after that we
have seen arrays in which we can store
multiple values like we can store list
in arrays
so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be already a string right
next up we have another variable let us
say we have a variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from od is q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car and the price
will be
let's say
50 000 us dollars all right next up we
have a function
let's say we are using a function
that is all wheel drive
so we are having a function all wheel
drive
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all wheel drive function we are using
document.write
and here what we will write
will write let's suppose
this car comes
with
quattro all-wheel drive
quattro i hope you guys are aware of
this word quattro it means that four
wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here is the data about a particular
car from a particular brand od right so
the car model is q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 us dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of general front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive
so this function is the behavior of the
car right
it shows that the car is four wheel
drive things are pretty sorted here
right we have the data about the car and
a function associated with it so let's
save this and we can see the output here
the car comes with quattro all wheel
drive so this is a basic piece of code
right
we have been through functions we know
how to use functions we know how to call
them so that's quite easy for now right
the problem occurs when we have a list
of cars let's say that we have to
maintain 100 different cars with all the
data of car manufacturer we have car
model price and then we have different
behaviors for different cars not all
cars have the all-wheel drive property
so
what we will do in such a case where we
have to use the same property again and
again for 100 different cars or 100
different entities we can copy paste
this same piece of code repeatedly and
we have to change the value every time
we copy paste it so we have to change
the variable name the car manufacturer
the car model and the price as well
imagine we are doing this for a list of
cars then it goes on and on so this is
the most inefficient way of tackling
this problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play
these objects help us to bundle all
these properties and attributes about
one particular entity if we talk about
this particular example of a car we can
put all these properties and many other
properties like car weight we have car
color and so on together under
one name and make it an object
let's move on to the syntax for objects
in javascript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use
objects now let's go ahead and have a
look at the syntax for objects
so before we start
there are few ways in which we can
create objects in javascript we are
going to discuss two different ways of
doing so
the first one is the literal way also
known as the literal object way
so the syntax for literal object way
goes like this let's say we are
declaring a variable where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object
inside this
we will define all the cars properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's
use them here so we have
car manufacturer
and
the car manufacturer is
od
right
next up we have car model
car model is
q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the syntax for
that will be
we have to write here all wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write your function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll copy it from
here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document.write now this function will
return this string that this cars comes
with a quattro all wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
used this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this
so this is what an object looks like our
object is entirely ready what we did
here is we bundled all these things and
coupled them we bundled all these things
we bundled all the three variables we
bundled this function we bundled all of
them together inside a single variable
and now this particular variable car is
an object now if we want to access these
properties of the object like car
manufacturer car model etc whatever
properties we have here so what we have
to do is we have to
use document.write so it is quite simple
so after this object we'll write here
document
dot write
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the
object name with the dot operator and
the property name so if we want to let's
suppose
we'll use here
car dot and property name will be car
underscore
manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite
easy you can see here we have used the
car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says od
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if we want to access this all wheel
drive function
we can do it simply by writing here car
dot and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write here all wheel drive and
we are good to go so if we save this now
so here you can see it says this car
comes with four wheel drive so it is
quite easy to access these properties of
an object so we can do it by using this
now suppose we call this function
normally with the document.right inside
the function in place of return so if we
write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write a document.write
inside this function and we can call
this function by the normal method like
if you are calling this function from
outside what we'll do we'll write here
car dot
and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't use any h1
tag or h2 tag so
you can spot the difference right
so that's how you can call a method of
an object from outside this is the
normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture
in which we use something different
known as object constructor that's a bit
different from other object oriented
programming languages so don't worry if
you don't know about it also in the
newer versions
javascript supports the concept of
classes and object
so what we used to say earlier is
javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed javascript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference
so we'll comment this that's why we are
not removing it but we can remove this
piece of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object
now we will create multiple objects
using a single template which is known
as a constructor function
let's have a look at the syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties s parameters so these are the
properties we have car manufacturer we
have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only
now inside a function these parameters
are known as arguments so if we talk
about the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically
so what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
constructor function we will pass
specific values
like the car manufacturer car model and
the price all of these values so all
these values will be present at the rhs
so let me write this first let's say we
are using this
dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will write here
car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so
this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object
for now let's mention here the other two
properties and method as well so
let's
use the other two properties which were
this dot
car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this
dot
price
we'll write here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this we'll use this
dot all wheel drive
and this is a function so we'll write
here function with the opening and
closing round brackets and then we have
the body of the function
inside the body of this function we will
write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete constructor
function now using this constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
c plus plus and java
so let's create an object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable c1 now we
will use the new keyword and along with
the
constructor function so we'll use here
cars and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have
the car manufacturer as od and next up
we have the
model as
q7 and the price is
50 000
okay so we have created a variable we
have passed the
values for the properties
and now
if we want to access this function if we
want to access this all wheel drive
function we can access this as well we
have to write here c1 dot all wheel
drive and
this is how you can call a function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four wheel drive
so if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here h2 tech
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where c2 and the syntax
will be same for this as well we'll
write here new cars and we'll pass the
values here so let's say we are using
bmw
and next up we have the model as
x7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 usd so
if we want to access any particular
property of any object like if we want
to access the car model or if we want to
access the car manufacturer so we can do
it the same way as we did previously as
we did in the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name dot
and whatever we want to print let's say
we are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here x7 is
printed on the browser because x7 is the
value of object c2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print here car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have bmw as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000
so this is how we can create multiple
objects in javascript we'll continue
with the previous program we made so
today we will use the literal object way
because this method of creating objects
is a bit easier than the other one we
discussed which was the constructor
function method so here we created the
car object which has three properties
car manufacturer car model and the price
of the car we have a method here as all
wheel drive when we use this method here
we use this method with the dot operator
and we called that function we called
that method
with the help of the object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video
if we talk about objects in javascript
a lot of things we know about in
javascript are basically objects like
the boolean values numbers strings and a
few more so
many of these things can be objects if
we define them with the new keyword
basically any of the data type other
than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we define
them with the new keyword
so we have a few predefined objects as
well we have the math object the date
object and the regular expression are
also considered objects in javascript a
lot of things are objects in javascript
we'll use objects in dom manipulation
which we will go through in further
videos so that's why it is pretty
essential to understand the whole
concept of objects right so next up
let's look at how we can use different
data types as objects in javascript
so the syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in javascript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so stringer is a data type which we
will be using as objects for now so this
is the complete syntax of how to use a
data type as an object in javascript if
we'll write here str
1 and we'll use the dot operator so here
we can see we have the object methods as
well right
so i hope you guys are aware of the
methods present in javascript like we
had the string and array methods right
we have methods for object as well like
the index of method we have seen the use
of index of method when we went through
the string methods in javascript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in javascript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring so there are few ways to
determine if a variable is an object or
a primary data type
so the easiest way to do so is to use
the type of operator
so let's use it here and check the type
of variable str1 will write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the h1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we
write here any string let's suppose we
are using a string here let's say we are
using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between
a primitive data type it was a string
earlier but when we use it with the new
keyword along with
the string and
this is the basic syntax of how to
define a primitive data type as an
object so if we save it now here you can
see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and
the other predefined objects we talked
about like the date object and the math
object will go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can say we have written here
150 line of code so
i'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in javascript
we can add a particular property to an
object outside the definition also we
can add a property to an object anywhere
in a program the syntax for that goes
like this
we'll write the
object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say
black
right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so what we will do we will write here
document
dot write
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on a browser so we have used here
car.car color let's save this program
now and see
here you can see the output is black so
this is the property of the object car
now and if we comment this line let's
say if we are commenting this line
let's save this now and see here you can
see
it says undefined we can add more
properties similarly like if we want to
add another property here we can go like
car dot and the property name whatever
property we want to add let's say we
want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll
see it will go like car dot let's say we
are adding a new function
let's say we are adding the function nu1
equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
added
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so i hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object so it's pretty easy to
do so in javascript we can use the
delete keyword object name and the
property name after the dot operator
let's suppose we want to delete car
model here we want to delete this
particular property of the object car so
we what we'll do we'll delete this car
model so the syntax for it is quite
simple so we'll remove this for now and
we'll delete a property let's say we are
using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here
car model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so
we'll write here car dot
car underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know javascript is a loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write
so we have to write here car dot
price
and
update the value of here let's say we
are using 70 000 and
we have to put a semicolon it's the same
thing we do to update the value of a
particular variable right so if we try
to print the value of price now we'll
get the output as 70 000. let's try to
print it on the browser so we'll cut it
from here
we'll paste it here and we'll print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property
what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string
earlier it was a number but now it is a
string so all these things can be done
dynamically in a program wherever we
want to do them so that's the benefit of
having objects in javascript we have
been using the
document.getelementbyid method for the
past few videos right
we know it is used to access an html
element with the help of an id which is
uniquely provided to each element
so we use that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then we
select boxes as well
so today we are going to use a method
that is somewhat similar to
document.geteleme
method
so we'll be using the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name
like if we have a few div tags present
in our program and we want to change
each div text style we can do it with
the help of this method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between id and tag name method
so let's move on to the programming part
directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use css for that but in javascript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are
writing it this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the javascript
part
so we'll
write here
let's use the br tag and we'll write
here
input tag again we'll write a input type
is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say our function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button is let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button
so next up what we are going to do is we
are going to add functionality to this
submit button for that we have to move
to our javascript file and we have to
create a function over there
so we will write here
in the javascript file we will write
here
function
fund 2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do is we'll take a variable x and
then we'll write here
document dot
get elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so
in this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in a html document we can access
paragraph tags we can access anchor text
and any tag we want to basically
so
save it and here now we have a variable
x that holds an html collection of all
the div text present inside the html
file
this means that we have an array of
references of all the div tags here
inside this variable x
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the
first div tag of html document because
we know arrays start from zero
and at zero the first element will be
present so this div tag will be present
at number 0
and then we are going to use the style
property so we know that x here is not a
variable only actually x here acts as an
object and we know that different
objects have certain properties in
javascript so style is one of those
properties and next up we'll write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the css part with properties
present in javascript so let's say we
are changing our font to
courier new
right so this is a font name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button
the font of this particular section the
font of div 1 will change to courier new
so let's try if it's happening or not on
clicking the submit button you can see
over here the change between this line
and other three div tags clearly the
font has changed the new font is courier
new and what we did here is we changed
the font family of this particular div
tag so similarly we can make more
styling changes to other div tags as
well so let's do it here
and we'll
make changes to each of the div tags we
have in a html file so let's say here we
are using the color property and we want
to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and the index number will
be 2
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing a
font
style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for a
for the repeat so let's say for the last
div tag we are using the background
color
fine
and we'll write here the color name is
red
so we are good to go now save it and we
have four different properties over here
for section four we are changing the
background color so
three will be the index number of the
last
array variable so save it and on
pressing the submit button you can see
the change over here so for section 1
the font is changed to courier new for
section 2 the font color is blue let me
zoom it out a bit to show you guys you
can see over here the color is blue and
then we have italic text in section
three and finally for section four we
have the background color as four right
so you can see how we are accessing any
particular element of the array
now
why we are using these properties
separately for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in javascript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable x is holding an array of all
the div text present in a html file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
loop
so how this for loop works so we'll
write here
for
and then we'll take a local variable i
and the initial value will be 0
then we'll write a i
less than
x dot length because we want to traverse
the whole array right and then we'll
write here the condition
i plus plus
so we are good to go then we have this
body of for loop and inside here we'll
write x and the index number will be i
because it will keep on changing and we
are in a loop
so
we'll write here dot style and then
let's say the style we want to
do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font
bolder
fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me zoom this
and if we click on this submit button
you can see the font is more bolder
right
so if we are using another property here
let's say the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div text for all the
four section is changed to yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once
now what we did is we started a loop and
traversed every element in the array and
applied the same property to each
element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of
tag name method in javascript now what
if we have hundreds of similar elements
like div tag present in our website
and all of them are present at different
locations so let's try to do it and what
we'll do is we'll insert certain
different elements in between these div
tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted two
three more elements and between these
div tags so save it and you can see
after each section we have something
else here we have a form with two
different text boxes we have name and
age and then we have a submit button as
well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two
then after section two we have radio
button and the value is a then we have
another radio button b
and in between we have all the dev text
present so basically what we want to do
is we want to change the style for each
of the div tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section 1 2
3 and 4 will change to red so let's try
to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as
red so this is working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of id attribute for each element
so we are saying this for a long time
that the id for each element should be
unique why so although we saw in the
past videos that we can use the same id
for two different elements when we did
the same for accessing a css styling
property using the id attribute but if
we try to do the same thing with
javascript we'll get an error for
example if we try to access the value of
any particular element with the id
attribute but we have two elements in a
html file with the same id so it will
throw an error in that case basically
and this is the reason why we use the
tag name method in javascript so that if
we want to access multiple elements of
the same name we can do it with this
method because it's not possible to use
the id method separately for each
element present in the html document
right
because we have certain same html tags
present within an html document like we
have the div tags here similarly a
website is long enough to have multiple
similar elements present within it so
that's why we use the
document.getelementsbytagname method in
javascript so guys in the past few
videos we use two different methods of
accessing an element from an html file
using javascript properties so we know
the difference between the id method and
the tag name method right today we will
use another method to access a
particular element in javascript that is
the class name method or we can say the
get elements by class name method in
javascript so before discussing the
class name method in javascript let's
look at why accessing an element is
important in javascript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change
add or delete html elements we saw
earlier that we could change html
elements or the css style of any element
in the document with the help of
javascript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the id method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in javascript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the id attribute used in html
we know that id has to be unique for
each element but we know that many
elements in an html document can have
the same class right so we used class to
access specific css properties in the
previous videos
and that is the only benefit of using
classes in javascript so we can say that
a single class can be used by many
elements within an html document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so
we'll write here in the html file we'll
add five different
elements
so let's say we are writing here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one
we'll copy this
we'll paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
p tag we'll write
this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four and
five
so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph text in
between the
div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in our
html document three of them are the div
text section one two and five are div
text
and two text in between are the
paragraph tags so now
let's suppose we want to change the
style of three of these elements let's
say one four and five so we can do it in
two ways right either we can use the id
method or we can use the class method
however we can use the tag name method
as well but
we have to use two different variables
for that right that will be a lengthy
process why two different variables
because we have two different tags
present here right we have to create
separate variable for the div tag and
separate one for the paragraph text so
that will be a lengthy process so we
will consider id method and the class
name method for here
so considering the id method the
document.getelementbyid method we have
to provide a unique id to each element
so we have to provide unique id to this
div tag then we have to provide to each
in every element here right because we
need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the id to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an html file
so we'll use the class attribute in each
element we want to access
so let's say we want to access section 1
2 and 5.
so we'll write here class let's say the
class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are
the div text so we can access these with
the help of tag name method as well so
we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a html
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
funcon
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it
and here you can see
in the browser we have five sections
over here we have section one two three
four and five then we have a submit
button which will call the function on
clicking so we haven't added
functionality till now so let's move
ahead to our javascript file and we'll
add functionality to our
html document
so inside this javascript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name is
function
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
html file
so we'll write here
where x is equals to
document dot
get elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1
till now what we did was we took the
references of all the required elements
and stored them inside a variable named
x in the form of an html collection
so now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section one that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0
then we'll write dot
tile
and this style is a property dot
then let's say we want
to
change the font style so we'll write
here
font
style
font style will be
italic
save it so this piece of code will
change the font style of the element
present at index 0. save it and on
clicking the submit button here on the
browser
we can see the change in this section
right so if it's not visible so let me
zoom it a bit for you here you can see
guys the font at section 1 is changed to
italic right
so in this case we have all the three
elements present in our array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index 1 now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again 2 times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it 2 and we'll write here 1
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we will change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bolder
so we'll write your bolder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the
font weight as bolder so you can see the
change over here so this is how we can
make change to each element separately
and we can also make changes in all the
elements at once as well so for that we
have to use the for loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right
so for that we'll write here so let's
comment these three statements first
and then we'll write here
for and
it will take a local variable here we'll
write here where
i is equals to 0 i will start from index
0 and i will go till
x dot
length
and then we have the condition is i plus
plus
so inside the body of for loop we'll
write here
x and
instead of index number we'll write here
i because we want to traverse the whole
array then we'll write here style
dot
and let's say the style we want
is background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow
fine
so this is how we can use the for loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser
the background color for all the three
sections that is 1 2 and 4 is changed to
yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelementsbyclassname method
to access all the elements present in an
html file with a particular class next
up let's discuss the difference between
the id method tag name method and the
class name method
so we'll discuss when to use which
method so
let's start with the id method so the id
method is used when we want to access a
single element and we have to provide a
unique id to that element in order to
access it so the id method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods
we can either use the class name method
or the tag name method for more than one
element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name
we can access all the similar tags
present within an html document with the
help of tag name method the only problem
is we can access similar types of tags
only at one time we can't access two
different types of tags with this method
so this is where the class name method
comes into play we can access more than
one element with this method and the
elements can be different just like we
did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so
the section 1 2 and 5 are from div text
and the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
javascript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the html file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so by now i hope you guys
understood the concept of all the three
methods which we have discussed
the
id method the tag name method and the
class name method in javascript we can
use any of these methods according to
our needs functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task we use functions for
different purposes right whether it be a
button click or we want to zoom out our
image by taking the mouse cursor over it
we use functions for all these tasks
in javascript we can use functions as
objects at the same time we can pass
objects to functions as parameters right
so similarly we can also pass a function
inside another function
if i take you through the programming
part of this concept the syntax will be
like we'll go to a javascript file and
the syntax will be like will
declare a function let's say the
function is function abc
then here we'll pass a parameter let's
say we are passing call as parameter for
this function abc next up what we'll do
is we'll call this function inside this
function abc
now what we did here is really simple we
created a function abc right next up we
passed a function call as a parameter to
this function and then we also called
this function inside the function abc so
this syntax is valid in javascript and
also this particular code here is known
as the callback function in javascript
so if we talk about the definition of
callback function it states that a
callback function is a function that is
passed to another function as an
argument
and that particular function will get
executed later in the program
now you guys might have heard in the
previous videos that javascript is a
single threaded language or javascript
works over a single statement at a time
or we can say javascript works in a
particular top to bottom order
so if we talk about the sequence in
which javascript actually works while
coding so let's take an example for this
and we'll see the sequence in which
javascript will work so what we'll do is
we'll comment this code and we'll start
writing our new code here so let's
suppose we have three functions in a
single program so let's say we have a
function as function1
and then we have two more functions so
let's say the second function is
function2
and then we have
function
three as well
now if we write something inside these
functions so we'll execute the program
and what will happen is all the three
functions will be executed sequentially
so let's try to do it first
so what we'll do is we'll
right here inside the body of function
one so let's say we are using console
dot
log and
inside this will print
function one on calling this particular
function
so we'll do the same for other two
functions as well so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it here and here as well so
for function two it will print function
two
and for function three it will print
function three
so let's save it and before checking the
output so what we'll do is we'll call
these functions as well so let's say we
are calling function one then function
two
and then finally function
three
right everything we have done till now
is quite understandable and we have
three functions here and all the three
functions will get executed in the
sequence in which we call them so here
in this case we have called function one
first followed by function two and
function three
so let's check the output
save it and we'll open the console in
the browser so we'll right click here go
to inspect elements
and here you can see we have a console
here so here you can see we have the
output as function one function two and
function three so we have the output in
sequence we call function one first so
we have the output as function one but
if we call function three before
function two
so we'll cut this from here and we'll
paste function 2 after function 3.
save it and here you can see we have the
output as function 1 then function 3 and
then function 2.
so javascript will execute these
functions in the order in which we call
them right now what if we use the set
timeout function with function1 so let's
try to do it first
so instead of calling function1 alone
here we'll write here set
timeout
then we have to pass two parameters here
one is the function name so one is the
function name here
and we'll write here the time so time
here will be in milliseconds so 2000
milliseconds here represents two seconds
this means that the function will be
called after two seconds
right
so
this set timeout function will call
function one after a specific period of
time that is in this case two seconds
what will happen is javascript will
start executing all the functions and
the system will find out that there is a
timer with function1 so in this case the
system will leave this particular
function on execution
and will move ahead and execute other
function so function one will be
executed automatically after two seconds
so let's check the output
save it and you can see here we have
function three and two over here and
function one will be executed after some
time so i hope you guys got this here we
have used the set timeout method and
function one will be executed after two
seconds
now let's consider a scenario where we
have only two functions let's say we
have function one and function two so
let's remove this function 3
and we are left with only two functions
so let's say we have function1 and
function2 now
now what we want is we want to execute
these two functions
but we have certain conditions
so the first condition is function1 will
use the settimeout method and it will be
executed after 3 seconds
and second condition is function 2 will
get executed only after function 1
executes so till now what we have seen
is if we are using these two functions
and if we are using the settimeout
method with function1 what is happening
is
javascript will keep this function on
execution and it will execute this
function till then so what we want is we
want to execute function 2 only after
the execution of function 1. this is
where the concept of callback functions
comes into play so we have to ask the
computer to execute function2 only after
function1 is done
so let me write the same code in another
way we'll use the settimeout method
within function1 so what we have to do
is we have to change
it here
to one we'll call function1 from here
and inside this function1 what we'll do
is we'll write here set
timeout then we'll pass the first
argument is function
and then inside the body of this
function we'll write this console log
fine and we have to pass two parameters
here right so the next parameter will be
in the time so time here will be
3000 seconds so here we are and we are
done with our set timeout function now
this is another way of using the set
timeout method in javascript so what we
did here is we have passed the function
here as an argument and then we have the
body of function1 inside the set timeout
function
what we want to do next is we want to
execute function2 once function1 is
completed so before that let's do one
thing let's check if it is working fine
or not so we'll save it and here you can
see we have function2 executed before
function1 right so it's working totally
fine now what we want to do is we want
function2 to execute only after
function1 is done right so let me tell
you a shortcut for that guys it's not
callback functions but it's kind of same
thing it will do the same thing as the
callback functions but it is a different
concept
so what we have to do is we have to cut
this function to from here
and we have to call this function inside
here
inside the set timeout method
so we'll paste it here and we have to
call function2 inside the settimeout
method so save it and now if we wait for
three seconds and here you can see we
have both the functions function one and
two executed
on time so both the functions are
executed after three seconds
and this is not callback functions but
this is a shortcut for that what
happened here is
when function1 is being executed the
system came to know that the function2
is called inside the settimeout method
so what will happen is it will first
execute the set timeout method and then
it will execute the function 2.
so what we did just now is not callback
functions but the functioning of a
callback function is also the same
this is the same thing we'll do with
callback functions but the syntax will
be different
now by the definition of the callback
function that we came across earlier it
states that a callback function is a
function that is passed to another
function
as an argument so keep your focus on
this word argument
and that particular function will be
executed later that function which we
passed as argument will be executed
later
so here in this definition later means
once the system is done with the first
function or we can say the primary
function
it is now free to perform function 2 or
the secondary function or the callback
function we can say
so we have kept it on hold till now so
let's take an example of that as well
what we'll do is we'll create a function
and we'll pass an argument inside this
function
the value will be provided while calling
the function so
let's do one thing first let's comment
this code
and we'll write a new code here
so we'll create a function let's say a
function is function
person and we'll pass an argument here
so let's say the argument is friend
fine
next up we'll work on the body of this
function what we'll do is we'll again
use
console.log
and we'll print something so let's say
we'll
write here
my
friend's name is
and then we'll use the plus operator
with the
value of friend
we'll write your friend
and with this we are done with our
function person next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
function
person
2 and we don't have to pass any argument
here so inside the body of this function
will again use console.log and we'll
write here
my
name is
caution
fine
so
next up what we have to do is we have to
call these functions right so we'll
write a person
and inside this we have to pass the
value so let's say the value here is
simply code it's fine next up we'll call
person2 and will save this program so on
saving this program you can see we have
the output as my friend's name is simply
code so if you want me to zoom it you
can see here now
here it says my friend's name is simply
code and the second function says my
name is caution
right so this program is working totally
fine this is a basic program wherein we
created two function
and now what we want to do is we want
the function person to
will get executed after function person
so for that we have to pass function2 as
an argument in the function person
so we'll change the code
we'll pass this
function person2 as an argument so we'll
write here
person 2. we don't have to use brackets
here so because we are passing it as an
argument
now
we did it we passed this function as an
argument the next step is to tell the
function person about it right
we have to pass another argument in the
function so
we have to tell this first function that
we also have another function which will
get executed after this particular
function
so we'll write here
we can use any name we can use another
name for that or we can use the same
name as of function person2 so we'll
write here
person2
and then what we have to do is we have
to call this person2 function after this
right
now we are done with this code now we
are done with a callback function here
in this case this function person2 is
known as the callback function so save
it now
and
okay
what we have to do is we have to remove
this line from here so save it now here
you can see we have the output totally
correct we have the output as my
friend's name is simply code and my name
is caution
now we are done with almost everything
we are done with the callback functions
but
you might not see any change in the
output right to witness the change what
we have to do is we have to use the set
timeout method again because we want
this function to execute only after
function person so what we have to do is
we have to write here
inside function person we'll write here
set
timeout
and
then we have
to write your function
and then
inside the body we'll do the same we'll
cut these two brackets from here and
we'll paste them here
and inside here we have to write the
time so let's say the time is
three thousand fine
now what we did is we use the settimeout
method with function person and
inside the body it will print my
friend's name is and the friend's name
is simply good and it will be executed
after three seconds right
so let's save it
and we'll count four three one two and
three so here is the code you can see
here the output says my friend's name is
simply code
and my name is caution so
this is working totally fine
so this is how the concept of callback
functions in javascript works the word
promise seems a bit familiar we make
promises regularly right if i say i
promise you that will cover everything
on promises in this video now this
promise that i made can only have two
possible outcomes either the promise
will be fulfilled or resolved or we can
say the promise can be failed or
rejected the promise will be resolved if
we'll cover everything on promises in
this video but if i left out some topic
or there is any subtopic within promises
which we forgot to cover in this video
that will be a failed promise or we can
say a rejected one
now there is another term in between
these terms that is pending
pending is the time in which the system
works on the promise so just remember
these terms as you may hear them during
an interview
so let's move on talking about a proper
definition of promises we can say that a
promise is an object which will produce
value sometimes it either gives us a
value or an error with a proper reason
there is no specific definition for
promises in javascript you will
understand the topic much better while
working on the syntax
so let's move ahead and we'll go through
a simple example first to understand a
promise in javascript
as we mentioned earlier that a promise
is an object so what we have to do first
is to take a variable and declare an
object so for that we'll go to our
javascript file and we'll write here
we'll take a variable let's say a
variable name is prom and we'll write
here new
promise so this statement here is a
promise we have an object named prom
next up this promise will take a
callback function we have already
discussed the concept of callback
functions in the previous video so if
you haven't watched that video yet i
recommend you to watch it so a callback
function is a function passed to another
function as an argument remember so
we'll write here
inside this
object we'll write here
function
and
now this callback function here will
have two arguments one to resolve and
another for the reject that's because we
can have only two possibilities in a
promised right either it can be rejected
or it can be resolved so we'll write
here
resolve and then after a comma we'll
write here reject fine then we'll have
the body of this function
so this is how
a promise will look like you can change
the name of these arguments instead of
resolve or reject you can write here
anything but we have kept it simple for
now so that it will be easy to
understand next up let's use a simple
condition here let's take the example of
driving a car fine
what we'll do is we'll take a variable
drive and we'll check if the user
learned how to drive a car if yes then
the promise is fulfilled otherwise the
promise is rejected
so let's do it here we'll write here
where
drive
and let's set the value of this drive as
true for now let's say the user learned
how to drive a car
so next up what we'll do is we'll use
the if else conditional statement to
call any one of the two functions
we can either call resolve or reject
right so we'll write a if and the
condition will be
drive so if we left it with drive here
it will check for if drive is equals to
true
right so we'll call the function resolve
if the condition holds true
and then we'll use the else statement
for else we'll write it else and then
we'll write here
reject
fine
any value other than true will call the
reject function here so what we did here
was an easy task we know that the value
for the variable drive is true so in
this case the resolve function will be
called if we set this value of variable
drive to false
then the function reject will be called
the next part of the program is to
execute this promise so this will be the
longer part as we have to use two
methods here so for that the syntax will
start with the promise name and then
we'll use the dot operator so let me do
it here we'll write here
prom and then we'll use the dot operator
next up we'll use the then keyword so
this then keyword or
it is a method actually
it is called when the method is resolved
or when the promise is resolved so we
have another method for the rejection of
promises that we'll discuss afterwards
so we'll write here prom dot then
now this is a method so we will use
brackets here
when this method is called it means that
the promise is resolved we'll use a
callback function within this method so
we'll write here function and
then we'll use
the resolve function here so we'll write
here
resolve fine
and then we'll have the
body for resolve so
this is how the execution will look like
for promises and on filling the promise
there will be a statement printed on the
console
so it will be like we'll write here
console.log
and we'll write here something so let's
say we are writing here
resolve
and
let's say
the user
knows how to
drive
fine so we'll write here this
now we are done with the part in which
the promise will be fulfilled one thing
i forgot to mention here is we have to
pass
this resolve here so whatever value
we'll write here will be shown in
console so let's say we are writing here
for true value we'll write here yes
fine now if we save this program and
check for the output we'll get the
output as yes the user knows how to
drive we can check it so let's save it
and here you can see in the console we
have the output as yes the user knows
how to type let me put a space here so
let's save it now now it's clearly
visible so it says yes the user knows
how to drive
so this is working fine now the next
part will be for the condition if the
promise gets rejected so just like we
had
the
then method for resolving the promise
similarly we have one more method for
the rejection part
so for the rejection part we have the
catch method so we have to change this
method here only after the then method
so we'll come here and we'll write dot
catch
and the rest of the syntax will remain
same so we'll write here function
and then we'll
call
reject
then we'll have the body of this reject
part and we'll write here inside this
console.log
and we'll write here reject
plus
the user
does not
know
how
to drive
fine the catch method uses the reject
function and the output will be no the
user does not know how to drag so before
that we'll have to pass an argument here
so we'll write here
no
and save it now so for now it says yes
the user knows how to drive
to check for the reject method we have
to set the value of variable drive as
false
so let's change the value here let's say
we are using
false here now save it and you can see
here the output says no the user does
not know how to drive
fine so this is working totally fine now
you guys might be thinking that this
program we just did is so easy we could
have done it with if else conditional
statements then why are we using
promises for this
the syntax is extended and we have to
remember a lot of terms and methods for
a promise right
the good part is this was just an
example to make you understand the
syntax of promises in javascript next up
we'll go through an example wherein
we'll discuss the dependency of promises
as well so let's move ahead and in this
example what we'll do is we'll create
three separate functions
let's suppose we want to learn promises
in javascript
but for that we must know about the
concept of functions and callback
functions in javascript then only we can
go through promises
so what we'll do is we'll create three
functions in which the current function
will depend upon the previous function
if the user knows about functions he can
go through callback functions and if the
user knows both functions and callback
functions he is good to go for promises
so let me take you through the code guys
so here is the code we have three
functions the first one is for functions
topic so this functions is the topic
similarly we have callback and promises
as well so the first function is for the
functions topic and
if the user is done with functions in
javascript then he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so we have three different promises for
each function right so each function
here like the first function returns a
promise
right similarly all the three functions
are returning a promise here we are
directly resolving it we don't need to
wait for the user to learn functions
completely otherwise we can use here the
reject function as well for now we are
just resolving it
which means that the user learned
functions in javascript already the same
goes for callback functions and promises
as well
next up what we have to do is we have to
execute the promise that once the user
is done with functions he can move on to
callback functions and then to promises
so for that we have to execute promise
like this only
but the syntax will be different so let
me show you guys
so here is the code for that as well
what we did here is we use the first
function here
so functions is our first function and
on resolving we call the function
callback with the result and we did the
same thing again for a callback on
resolving the callback function it will
call the promises function and finally
it will print
this good to go message on the console
with the previous messages returned by
the resolve method
so we are basically working on the
dependency of promises in javascript
now let's save this program and we'll
check the output on the console so
save it and here you can see it on the
console it says
good to go and then it says learned
functions learnt callback functions good
to go for promises in javascript
now this same program can be done with
the help of callback functions as well
but the code will be so confusing
because we have to nest all these
functions inside a single function and
then it will be a mess right the code
with promises is clean you can see here
the code is clean all we had to do here
was to create functions then return
promises on call and then we can execute
those promises with their dependency
so this is how promises in javascript
actually works we have been using
functions in almost every video since we
came across this topic whether it be
dom manipulation or using an event in
javascript functions are everywhere
right
so this concept of arrow functions
is just a change in the syntax of
declaring and defining a function
so let's go through the concept of
functions in javascript quickly so that
it will be easy to change the syntax
later what we'll do is we'll create a
function with multiple parameters and
then we'll create another function with
no parameter at all
so we know these concepts already so
let's write the code here
so we'll go to a javascript file
and we'll write code here so we'll write
a function let's say the function name
is
func one
and then this function have two
parameters a and b
now this function will return something
so we'll write here return
let's say this returns a plus
b
fine now the code we wrote here is to
find the sum of two numbers right we'll
pass the two numbers as arguments while
calling the function so let's check on
the console once if the code is working
fine or not so we'll save it
go back to the browser go to inspect
and then we'll go to a console and we'll
write here
function name and then we'll pass
certain parameters right so let's say
the parameters we are passing are 15 and
so the output we are expecting is 40 and
the output is correct we have the output
as 40. you can see here we have the
output as 40 here
so this function is working totally fine
next up we'll create another function
first and then we'll move to the arrow
function syntax so for the second
function we'll write your
function let's say the function name is
funct2
and this function will have no
parameters at all right so let's say
this function prints something on the
console right so we'll write a
console.log and then
let's say this
function prints
welcome
to simply code
we are done with it so let's do one
thing we'll call this function here
we'll write a function calling the
function is pretty easy we can do the
same thing here as well
so
let's save it and check the output here
you can see we have the output as
welcome to simply code in our console
so this is how we were using functions
till now the simple syntax for functions
right so let's move on to the concept of
arrow functions
now this function over here has two
parameters right this function has
parameters a and b
and what we'll do is we'll change the
syntax of this function and the new
syntax will be more simple once you get
used to it so let's write the newer
syntax just below the previous one we
don't need the function keyword with
arrow functions so all we have to do is
we have to take a variable so let's do
it first so let's say we have a variable
where
arrow one fine so this is a variable
this statement is simple we have a
variable named arrow
and this will be the function name so
arrow one will be the function name as
well right when we use the function
keyword in traditional syntax of
functions it automatically creates a
variable with the function name here we
have to declare the variable by ourself
next up we have two parameters here a
and b as you can see here we have a and
b
we'll write the parameters within
parenthesis now so what we have to do is
we have to write
parameters so let's say the parameters
are a and b for this function as well
so these are the parameters we have to
write them within parenthesis
now we'll use an arrow that actually
makes this variable a function now this
is the main concept to create an arrow
what we have to do is we have to write
equals to and
then we have to write this so this is
the arrow mark which makes this whole
statement a function
and then we'll write the body of the
function
so the body of function will remain same
so we'll copy the body from here
and we'll paste it here so this function
here this function arrow one here is the
same as function function and the output
will be the same
this arrow function here has only one
line here so the advantage provided by
arrow functions in this case is quite
help
what we can do is we can make this
function up one liner if we remove this
return keyword and the curly braces here
so we can remove these curly braces as
well what we have to do is we have to
make this function a one liner right so
there will be no difference now so this
is how the arrow function for this
traditional function looks like now both
the functions will return the sum of two
numbers the only difference is in syntax
let's check the output for the arrow
function as well so what we'll do here
is
we'll save this program and we'll
go to a console so let's do one thing
we'll call func one first and the
parameters let's say are
5 and 15
and then we'll call the arrow function
with the same parameters so we'll write
a arrow
comma
15.
now we have the output as 20 in both the
cases right so these two functions are
working similarly these two functions
are same the only difference is in the
syntax
next up we have another simple function
here and what we want to do here is to
convert this traditional function into
an arrow function right now we are
talking about function function so let
me comment this first function here what
we'll do is we'll command this and now
we are good to go
so we have function funct2 here now what
we'll do is we'll create an arrow
function for this function
we'll write here
let's say we are writing here where
arrow two
and then we have no parameters so empty
parenthesis and then we have
the arrow
operator
so the body will remain the same we'll
copy the body from this function
and we'll paste it here
now we have used empty parenthesis here
because we don't have any arguments here
let's try to run this code we'll call
the function here only so
for this we have to write here
arrow two and we are good to so save it
and the output we are expecting is
welcome to simply code twice because we
are calling funct2 as well right so save
it
and here you can see the output is
welcome to simply code let's change
something here so what we'll do is for
arrow function we'll write here
simply learn
fine
so save it now and here you can see we
have the output as welcome to simply
code and welcome to simplylearn let me
zoom it for you if it's not visible so
here you can see the first output for
function it says welcome to simply code
and for arrow 2 it says welcome to
simply learn
that's working fine
now before we wrap up this video let me
tell you another benefit of using arrow
functions so we already discussed that
we don't need to use the return keyword
if we are writing a one-liner function
similarly if we have a single parameter
we don't need any parentheses we'll
create another function here so let's
say we are writing here
where
arrow 3
and let's say it has only a single
parameter as new name
fine
then we'll
use the arrow operator and then inside
the body of this we'll write here
console.log
and then we'll write here
here there
plus the name provided by us in the
argument so
now we are good to go this function here
will give us the output as hey there and
then whatever name will pass while
calling the function so let's check it
let's call this function as well so
let's say
we are writing here arrow 3 and
the name let's say will be
caution
save it and here you can see it says hey
there caution for arrow function 3 so
this is also working fine
and i hope you guys are now clear with
the arrow functions in javascript it's
not essential to use arrow functions
everywhere but now that we are clear
with promises and callback functions it
will be good to write minimum code and
arrow function will help you with that
have you guys ever heard about
validation or pattern matching in
javascript we come across these terms
when we hear about passwords mostly
right
so we say that we can use the if else
statement to match if the user's
password matches with the one we already
have for that we write if password is
equal to is equals to some sort of
string or characters
and then we see if the password matches
will let the user enter otherwise the
entry will be denied so we are
discussing all that because regular
expressions are objects used to perform
pattern matching or if we want to search
for something in a string or even if we
want to replace something from a string
we can do it all with regular
expressions
so we'll go through the syntax for
regular expressions and some more
important things about regular
expressions in javascript so regular
expressions are present in almost every
programming language it's not limited to
javascript only and the concept remains
the same everywhere the syntax may
differ a bit between different languages
but the logic behind them will always be
the same the name might be a little bit
confusing but
the reality is entirely different they
are pretty easy to use and if you
understand the basics clearly you'll
face no problem while working on
advanced topics
so let's go through the regular
expressions before we move on to
validations using regular expressions in
javascript so let's understand the
concept entirely so that it will be easy
for you guys in further videos so
consider a scenario where we have a
string and we want to find a particular
word in that string or we can say we are
in a static website i hope you guys are
aware of the term static where we have
the search option to find some word in
the entire html document we have to
write the word in the search box and it
will return us the location of that word
in the html file or in the website
right what we'll do now is we'll use a
word and we'll find that word in a
string will make some changes to that
word with the help of several functions
used along with regular expressions in
javascript so the syntax for regular
expressions goes like this we'll move to
a javascript file and we'll take a
variable here so let's say the variable
is where
rejects and we use two forward slashes
for it generally we use the double slash
for comments but it will be recognized
as a regular expression in javascript if
we write something inside these double
slashes so let's say we are writing
something here let's say we write here
hello
now
this word hello is present inside the
variable rejects and this word needs to
be searched in a string
so let's use a string as well so for
that we'll write here where let's say
the string name is str1 let's say we are
writing here
welcome
to a
youtube
channel
full stop
say hello
if
you are new here
fine so let's say this is the string we
have
now this string contains the word hello
in it all we have to keep in mind is to
add the main keyword in the string for
now
moving ahead what we want to do is we
want to find this word in the string
right we want to find this hello word in
this string
so next up we'll go through certain
essential functions which we use with
regular expressions and we'll see the
functioning of these essential functions
the first function is the exact function
so let me write here guys
this is the first function exec
function
now this function returns an array if
the word is present in this string
otherwise it will return null if the
word is not present in the string the
syntax is pretty straightforward all we
have to do is to use the exact function
with the variable that contains the
regular expression now in this case the
word rejects contains the regular
expression we have to use it with the
function and the string name will be
passed as a parameter to this function
so
let's write the syntax here and it will
be easy for you guys so let's comment it
out
and we'll write here let's say we are
taking another variable where output
will write here the
variable name
dot function name will write here exec
and the string will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is the syntax now this output
variable over here will have an array
and the array will return the index
number of the word hello industry fine
so let's print this array on the console
and we'll write here
console.log
output fine
save it and open the console so we will
move to a browser and we'll open console
here
see here we have an array and if we
click on this array we can see that we
have
the word hello at index 36 so if we
count from here and the counting should
start from 0 because error index always
starts from 0 so at index 36 we can find
that hello is over here and so it will
return the index of this particular word
now
if we write here something else other
than hello let's say we are writing here
2 save it now and you can see here we
have 2 present at index 8 so if we count
from here we can see that 2 is present
at index 8 so this is working totally
fine now another scenario is if we write
here 2 with a capital t save it now and
you can see here the output is null
why so because regular expressions in
javascript are case sensitive case
sensitive means it differentiates
between the capital letters and small
letters fine
but the good part is we can make them in
case sensitive as well so all we have to
do is we have to use a modifier a
modifier is actually used to make
modifications in the search so what we
have to do is we have to write here in
the beginning we have to write a single
letter and in this case we'll write here
i because this modifier will tell the
system that there will be no problem
with the case sensitivity of the word
now
it will work fine and if we save this
program
we can see we have the output as index
8. now if we change this string and
we'll write here something other than
this so we'll write here h e
l o but
the three letters of this word are
capital letters
so save it now and you can see we have
the output as
index 36 so this is working fine now one
last situation is if we write here more
than one hello in a single string so if
we write here hello and welcome to our
youtube channel now there are two hello
words present in a single string save it
and you can see we have the word hello
at index 0 so it will return the first
hello world in the string now if we want
to get access of the second hello and
for if we write here this piece of code
again what we are expecting is we are
expecting it
to give us the index of second hello as
well but it will not happen save it and
you can see it will give the index of
first hello twice you can see here we
have index as 0 in both the areas right
so it will not work
now the solution to this problem is
modifiers again what we have to do is we
have to use another modifier here now we
have to write here the letter g and save
it
now this is returning null because we
have
the string wrong here so we have to
write here hello because we have removed
the in case sensitive modifier save it
now and you can see we have both the
hello worlds with indexes as 0 and 46
respectively so this global modifier
tells the system that the word is now
global and if you find the word once and
the user tries the exact function again
then the second time you should return
the index value of the second word
so this is how it actually works now the
following function we are going to
discuss is a pretty simple one the test
function
now this function returns either true or
false nothing else
this function checks for a particular
word that if the word exists in a string
then it will return true otherwise
false it will not return the index value
or some sort of other things
it deals with the boolean value only
that is true or false so that's it for
the function let's see how this function
works actually so what we'll do is we'll
mention here this test function
and will
comment this piece of code
so that there will be no
confusion
we'll comment it out
now we'll go through the syntax of this
test function
the syntax is pretty easy we'll use the
output variable again
and we'll write here
variable name dot function name and the
string name will be passed as a
parameter
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log
and we'll print this on a
console
fine so this is the syntax for test
function save it
and here you can see in the console that
for the word hello it returns true if we
change this word here to something else
like if we write here hi instead of
hello
save it and you can see the output is
changed to false because high is not
there inside of a string right because
height does not exist according to this
history
so this is how the test function
actually work now one more thing i want
to mention here about the test function
is if we write here some part of a word
not the whole word but some part so
let's say if we write here
e l
now this is the part of hello world now
what if we save this you can see the
output here is true that's because the
test function checks for every letter
and if it finds these three letters in
any word it will return true in that
case as well fine next up we have
another function to use with the regular
expressions in javascript now the next
function's name is match function
i'll write it here
first i'll commend these two statements
and then i'll write here the name of
this function so the name is match
now this match function returns an array
of results otherwise null the syntax for
this function is exactly opposite from
the previous functions
because we'll pass the regular
expression as a parameter to this
function now and the function will be
used along with the string
so
it is completely opposite to
the syntax we used for the previous two
functions so we'll write here for this
we'll use the output variable again
we'll write here where output
and
instead of rejects we'll use it with
this string so we'll write here str1 dot
match
and
the variable name will be passed as a
parameter fine
so this is how the syntax for match
function looks like it's exactly
opposite to the syntax we used for
previous two functions the next line
will remain the same we'll write a
console.log and we'll print
output on a screen fine now we have to
do one more thing here what's that is we
have to remove this modifier from here
and we have to write here
hello so save it and you can see we have
an array over here now what if we want
to find both the words in a string if we
have if we want to check if there's more
than one word with the similar name so
what we have to do is we have to write
here g and if you save it now you can
see the output is completely changed and
now we have an array with two similar
words what if we add another hello here
so let's say we have another hello here
save it and you can see here the array
size is increased to 3 now now we are
left with one more method and the method
we are going to discuss now is pretty
important because we'll use this method
in future as well so the last method is
the replace method which is used to
replace something from a string we can
either replace the first matching word
or all the matching words from a string
if we are using the global modifier then
all the words will be replaced otherwise
the first matching word will be replaced
so the syntax for this method goes like
this
what we have to do is so let's comment
it out first and we'll go through the
syntax of final method so the final
method is
replace method
fine
so the syntax goes like this we'll use
the output variable again
and we'll write here
str1
dot replace because we want to replace
something in that particular string the
first parameter will be the
variable name we'll write here regex
comma and then we'll pass
the word we want to change so hello will
be changed with let's say in this case
hi
fine
now check over here that if we are using
any modifier so we are using global
modifier here
now if we print this on our console if
we write a console.log and
we are writing here output
if we save it now we'll get to know that
all the hello words in the string are
replaced with the word hi
save it and you can see over here that
hi and welcome to a youtube channel say
hi if you are new here and then we have
a hi you can see that all the hello
words are replaced with the word hi now
if we remove this global modifier from
here and if we save it now you can see
only the first hello world is replaced
the other hello words are here and there
will be no change in them because we are
not using the global modifier now in the
previous video where we came across
regular expressions in javascript we saw
different predefined functions that we
use for finding a particular expression
present inside a string right
like the predefined functions we also
have some javascript characters that
make the searching part easy
so these characters are used within the
expressions and help us in different
ways for example let's consider a
scenario where we have a regular
expression and we want to find a
particular word within the string
but we don't remember the whole word
let's say we forgot the word with time
and now we remember only a part of that
word so let's do the same side by side
and what we'll do is we'll go to our
javascript file
and we'll take three variables
we'll write here let regex is equals to
then we'll write here let str1 is equals
to
and then finally we'll write
where output is equals to
fine
now here we have three variables the
variable rejects will store a regular
expression within it we haven't returned
the word yet next up we have a variable
str1 to store the string and a variable
output to store the output returned by a
function the function will use will be
any one of the ones we used in the
previous video so let's do it here the
word let's say
the word will be
welcome fine
you can take any word you want now
moving on to the string let's write the
string as well we'll write here welcome
to our youtube
channel and then we'll write another
welcome here
fine
we'll discuss the reason why we wrote
welcome twice now if you guys remember
from the previous video where we have
used the test function to check the
availability of a word present in a
string or not we'll use the same
function again so we'll write here
variable name
dot function name so the function name
is test and then we'll pass the string
name as the parameter so we'll write
here str one
that's fine
and finally what we'll do is
we'll print this on our console so we'll
write a console.log
output fine now we already know the
output for this piece of code right the
output will be true that's obvious
because we have the word welcome present
in our string not once but twice
the output will remain true if we remove
the first welcome from the string let's
do it here let's save the program first
and then we'll move to the console
and you can see here the output says
true for the word welcome present in the
string str1 that's true right
and now if we remove this welcome word
from here and if we save it you can see
the output still remains true because we
have another welcome word present in the
string right
so this is how the test function
actually works we will put the welcome
word here again we already know the
functioning of this test function the
main point of discussion here is the
meta characters so meta characters are
characters with special meanings
like the dot character if we write this
regular expression like we can remove
any one character from this word and put
a dot in its place let's do it
we'll remove a random character and
write dot a so let's say
we are removing
l
fine and instead of l we are putting a
dot here
now the dot character here will replace
this character and the system will not
throw any error
it will still find the word we can also
use exact function here to check the
index number of the word so what we'll
do is we'll take another variable
and we'll do the same we'll write here
rejects dot
exec
and then we'll pass the string name as
parameters
fine
we'll copy this console.log from here
and we'll paste it here
the variable name is op
save it
and here you can see
we have the output as true for the test
function and for the exact function it
returns the index number 0 of the word
in the string now the system
automatically puts a l in place of the
dot character similarly if you want to
do the same thing for more than one
character we have another meta character
for that it's not that we can't use this
dot operator but we can use it for a
limited time like we can use it for a
single character but if we want to put
more than one character and we don't
know the number of the characters so
then we have another meta character for
that the meta character is asterisk
now this asterisk allows us to put
multiple characters within a particular
expression for example if we write here
let's remove all this
and we'll put star or asterisk in place
of all the characters in between so save
it and you can see the output returns
true
for
test function and for the exact function
the index is
now if we write here something like that
and we don't know what it is but let's
assume it so if we save it now you can
still see the output returns true for
this as well
because
now we can put any number of characters
in between w and e the only thing that
matters is the first and the last
character of the word welcome
now
the next character we'll be looking at
does not work the same way as these
characters the carrot character works
upon a whole string let's go through the
syntax and what we'll do is
we'll remove this
unwanted piece of code and then we'll
come here we'll write here
welcome again
and now we'll put this carrot character
now the carrot character is this
character so
what this character returns is this
character returns true only if the whole
string starts with the word welcome the
second welcome word does not even exist
for this meta character if we save this
program now
it will return true because welcome is
present at the start of this string
right so save it
and you can see the output is true now
if we remove this welcome from here
and if we save this program now we know
that we have another welcome present in
the string but this character does not
work
that way
and it will return false because the
string starts with
two now right
save it and here you can see the output
is false for test function and for exact
function the output is null it will not
return any index number of the second
welcome or some sort of thing so this is
how the carrot character works in
javascript
the next meta character does the same
thing but for the end of the string the
symbol is dollar and it checks for the
end part of the string this meta
character is placed at the end of a
regular expression and it checks if the
string ends with characters present in
the expression the syntax goes like this
what we'll do is we'll remove this
carrot character and we'll put a dollar
sign you
now this statement now will check if the
string ends with the word welcome or not
in this case the last word of the string
is
back right
not welcome so the output will be false
save it
save it and you can see here the output
is false and null
suppose we write here back in place of
welcome now what we'll do is we'll write
here
back in place of welcome and if we save
this program now the output will change
to true because
back is the last word present in a
string right so this character checks
for the end of the string
save it and you can see the output is
changed to true and the index number is
find the exact function will return the
index number of the word back the last
meta character we will discuss in this
video is the optional meta character
the question mark symbol represents this
meta character and the functioning be
like any character before this symbol is
treated as optional
this means that it doesn't matter if the
character is present in the string or
not for example
if we write here let's say
we'll
write here welcome again because welcome
has more characters than back and we'll
write here
welcome as well
fine
now let's make some changes in this
particular rejects expression so what
we'll do is we'll put a question mark
here
and let's say we'll put another question
mark here fine now if we remove c and e
from the string or any one of them then
also the function will work fine and the
output will be true let's do it and what
we'll do is we'll make some changes in
this particular string and we are going
to remove some characters from this
string so we have two welcome words
there and what we'll do is we'll remove
c from this one
and we have two optional characters
right both c and e are optional but for
now we are removing c only so the string
looks like this we have the word vellum
it doesn't mean anything but for
understanding purposes we have done it
so save it and you can see the output
remains true for vellum
now
what if we put any other word in place
of this character
let's say we are writing here b
fine
the output will change we have to put an
os
because o is not an optional character
now the output
will change
as we were discussing if we save this
program you can see it is true for now
but it is saying true because of this
welcome now if we remove this welcome
from here and if we save it now you can
see the output is changed to null
yes these characters are optional but we
can't put any character in place of them
we have two options only either we can
put c in its place or we can leave it
so there's no other option with the
optional characters so these are the few
meta characters present in regular
expressions which helps in validation a
lot we came across meta characters in
rejects in the previous video where we
saw how to check the availability of a
particular word or expression within a
string we know about functions as well
so today we will combine all these
things to some extent and we'll see how
basic validation actually works in
javascript
we'll see an example wherein we'll go
through the character sets and ranges
and check for some specific type of
validation in this video
now the topic character sets and ranges
itself is a pretty explanatory topic and
we can get an idea of what's coming just
by going through the words characters in
layman term refers to alphabets and
numbers right we see a character on a
daily basis and we know a lot about them
now if i write here a
we can say that this is a character in
javascript now we can use one single
character or a group of characters at a
time with regular expressions in
javascript we have a particular syntax
for it we'll go through the syntax first
and the syntax is like we have to use
square brackets and we have to write
characters in between these brackets or
inside these brackets
here we have three characters a b and c
what we can do is we can give
instructions to the system to use any
one of them in a regular expression
so let's take a small example of how
this actually works with regular
expressions and what we'll do is we'll
do the same thing we have been doing
till now we'll search a word within a
string we'll check that if a word exists
within a string or not so we'll do it
like we'll take a variable regex
that will contain the regular expression
so this is
the syntax for regular expression and
this is a regular expression which says
d e f so in actual this is not a word
but assume it as a word for now and what
we have to do is we have to include
character sets with this regular
expression right so we'll write here
inside square brackets
abc now the next thing is we'll define
the string let's say the string name is
tr1
and the string says
this string contains adef
so def
or we can say adef is what matters the
most for now so anything else you can
write on the string the next thing we
are going to do is we are going to
use the test function to check if this
particular regular expression
is available in the string or not so
we'll write here
regex dot
test and inside this will pass the
string as a parameter
now the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here console.log and we'll print
this on our console fine
we are done with it so what we are doing
here is we want to search the string for
a word which contains the letter d e f
compulsory but before def we can have a
character that character can either be a
b or c no other character will be taken
in front of def because we have defined
a character set as well right and that
character set contains only three
characters a b and c so
here you can see we have adef present in
the string and we have a along with def
so
what we are expecting is this test
function should return true right so
save it and check for the output in the
console so we will go to a console
and here you can see the output says
true because we have adef only
now if we write here anything else like
if we replace this a with the character
r
save it and you can see the output is
false because r is not present inside
this character set now
what if we write here something like
let's say we are writing here
caution def now this will check for this
letter only for this l only other
letters don't actually matters in this
case in the case of character sets the
only character that matters is the
character right before the regular
expression
so if we save it you can see the output
is changed to false and if we write here
let's say
caution adef save it and you can see the
output is true because it checks for
this character only fine
talking about ranges let's say we want
to add any character in the string
between a to z now we have two options
to do so first one is we can write abc
till z here like we'll write here d e f
g h i and so on and so forth tills it
but this task is a little bit lengthy
right and we have to spend a lot of time
in that process so the alternate to this
process is to define a range of
characters to define a range of
characters it's quite an easy task all
you have to do is write a
hyphen z so this is how you can define a
range of characters now this range will
consist every character from a till z a
and z will also be included keep this
thing in mind if we write here caution
df again so we have seen in in the
previous example that it returned false
for this right save it now and you can
see the output is still true
that's because now we have a range from
a till z
if we write here 5 now now it will
return false because 5 does not lies in
between this range in between a to z so
it will return true for any character
between a till z fine
now let's say we want to exclude some
particular characters from this range
like we don't want the user to include
def again no character from d e or f so
the syntax for that is also pretty easy
we have to use the carrot operator and
we have to write here but we don't want
to include so let's say in this case we
don't want to include def fine so if we
write here ddef now and save it you can
see
it will return false because we have
included ddef and if we write here adef
save it and you can see the output is
true now we can't include
characters
d e and f in front of this regular
expression because we have defined this
character set to not include these
characters in the regular expression
so these are characters and ranges in
regular expressions so the next thing
we'll be doing is we'll be going through
a basic validation example and we'll see
how actually basic validation works in
javascript what we'll do is we'll create
a small html form that will take the
employee id from the user and it will
check if the employee belongs to the
organization or not
so let's say the employee id of the
organization has some unique characters
present in it and the character remains
there in each employee id
the idea is simple we'll take the id
from the user and we'll use if else
control statement to check if it belongs
to the organization or not
so let's move on to the html file and
we'll create a placeholder and a button
so
let's do it
we'll write here
form
and inside this form tag
let input
id is equals to
eid
and
placeholder is equals to
employee id
and type is equals to
text fine
the next thing we are going to do is we
are going to include a button as well
button and we are going to call a
function on clicking so we will use the
on click event so we will write here on
click and let's say the function name is
employee
and the button name is let's say submit
save it and you can see over the browser
that we have a placeholder along with
the button so let me give a space here
save it now and you can see we have a
placeholder and a button so that's all
what we have to do in html part now the
rest of the thing will be doing in the
javascript file so let's move to a
javascript file
and comment
this piece of code first
now what we want is we want to call a
function employee on clicking the submit
button fine so what we'll do is we'll
define a function employee
and inside the body of this function the
first thing we will be doing is we'll be
taking
the user's id right so we need a
variable for that so let's say the
variable is
and will write here
document
dot
get element by id the id is
eid
dot
value
fine now this empid variable will hold
the value entered by the user right so
like if we write here something like
d2386 so let's say this is the id this
will be stored the value for this id
will be stored inside this empid
variable fine
now we'll use the regular expression to
check for some special characters so
we'll write here
inside the function we'll write here
where
check is equals to
inside the regular expression we'll
write something so let's say we want to
start the employee id for the
development team with the alphabets dnd
and each id will have a similar numeric
code like 253 which represents the code
for a particular team fine
so we'll write here inside the character
sets
we want de to be there before a similar
numeric code right so 253 is the numeric
code and we want to include either d or
e
before that right
and
after 253 let's say we have a range of
numbers that each employee id has a
unique two digit number the id should
look like
either
d
2 5 3
1 1 or either
e
2 5 3
6 1
something like that right
now so for that what we have to do is we
have to include here another range and
this range will be from 11
oh sorry this range will be from 10 till
99 fine
this looks a bit complex now but if you
try to do it by yourself believe me guys
you will find it out that this is an
easy task but a little lengthy we can
say now the next part is we have to
validate the id entered for that we have
to use the if else control statement
along with the test function
so we have to write here
if
check
dot test and inside this will write
amp id because mpid is the variable
which is holding the value entered by
the user right so if it's true then it
will return
an alert box with the message that
says valid
employee id
fine
else
it will
return a message in the pop-up
which will say
invalid
id fine
so this if else statement will check the
value returned by the test function if
the value returned is true it will
return a message valid employee id
otherwise the else statement will run
and the user will get a pop-up with the
message invalid email id fine
let's check the output and in the
browser here we'll write the employee id
in the
given placeholder so let's say the
employee id is d
2 5 3
1 9
submit it and you can see it says valid
employee id we can do it for some more
like if we write here e
2 5 3
9 8
submit it and you can see it still says
valid employee id now what if we want to
include any character between this range
and the unique number right so let's try
to do it we'll write here d 253
k
89 fine so let's say this is the id we
want to enter submit it and you can see
it says invalid employee id
now one more thing we want to do here is
like if we write here
d 253
okay eight nine
in this case it will return false or
invalid employee id why because we
haven't included any modifier here and
it will differentiate between uppercase
and lowercase character so to overcome
this problem what we can do is we can
include the in case sensitive modifier
and we are clearly good too now if we
write here d253
and save it if we write here now d
2 5 3
9 8
submit it
and you can see here the output says
valid employee id
so this is how we can use validation
along with regular expressions
in the last video we came across
character sets and ranges we saw how we
could use them with regular expressions
and we also saw how to validate a user's
input with the help of character sets
and ranges along with regular
expressions now in this video we'll look
at the shorthand character classes
present within regular expressions and
we'll see how they are helpful in
javascript
if you guys remember the regular
expression we used became a bit
confusing and lengthy because we have
used so many ranges and character sets
all in one right a character class can
be used to overcome this particular
problem and we have several character
classes present in javascript so today
we will go through them in this
particular video now the syntax is not
too much complicated all we have to do
is to write a single character with the
backslash and we are good too
for example if we go to a javascript
file and if we write here
backslash d
now if we write this character before
any regular expression in javascript it
means that we have added a character
class to a regular expression this
backslash d is a character class used
for finding a digit within a string
let's go through an example for this
character class
and we'll do the same thing we'll take a
string and try to find a regular
expression within that string so what
we'll do is
we'll write here
where
regex is equals to
and here we will write a regular
expression first we'll take up a string
and use some functions to check the
output so let's do it here what we'll do
is we'll take another variable let's say
the variable name is str1 and
the string says
user's
phone number
is
nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero now let's say this is the
string we are using for today's program
the next thing we'll do is we'll use the
exact function to find the regular
expression within the string so we have
already gone through this exact function
in javascript today we'll use that
function only
now we'll write here where output is
equals to
regex dot exec
and inside this will pass a string as a
parameter
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here console.log
and we'll print this output on a console
now we are good to go so we are done
with it and the next thing we want to do
is to find a particular pattern along
with the number present before that
pattern in the string so let's suppose
if we write here inside these slashes if
we write here let's say three to one
now
this statement here asks the computer to
find a pattern three to one in the
string
save it
and go to the console so we'll move to
our browser and we'll press control plus
shift plus i and here you can see we
have a console here and here we have an
array as well so here you can see it
says
let me zoom it out a bit here you can
see it says
321 is present at index 28.
now
the system finds out that this
particular string or this particular
regular expression
is present here in the string at index
number 28 obviously the indexes will
start from 0 and the moment it will find
this
3 to 1 regular expression it will show
the index number in an array
in a console
now if we add
backslash d here let's say we are adding
here backslash d
in front of this expression and check
the output here save it you'll notice
that we have a number present here right
before that expression
right we have 4 3 2 1 here instead of
just 3 2 1. the output here gives us the
number 4. this means that this backslash
d represents this number
4 in this string now what if we put an
alphabet before this expression now
let's do it what we'll do is we'll write
here a
and let's say we are adding only a
single alphabet here let's say we are
adding a before three two one now the
expected output is a three two one but
the moment will save it you can see it
says null
that's because this particular character
class works for digits only if it finds
anything other than a numeric digit it
will return an error or it will return
null in that case now if you want to
find all the numbers before this pattern
then we have to add a plus operator in
the regular expression all we have to do
is we have to write here plus and we are
good to now it will return everything
until it finds a space or any character
other than a digit now let's suppose if
you are writing here a after 9 8 7
now this particular statement will
return all the numbers till 6 the moment
it will encounter a here it will return
all the numbers after a it will stop at
a and it will not go further now save it
and you can see it says 654321
that's because
this backslash d works for digits only
now if we write here nothing
like we have a number 9876543210
save it and it will return the whole
number
six five four three two one
not zero because we haven't included any
number here
now if we write here again
backslash d after this as well save it
and here you can see we have the output
as
0 as well we have the whole number here
fine
so this is how this backslash d actually
works in javascript so this is a
character class
now
the next thing is what if we want to
find a non-digit character before a
particular pattern
if we write here
before 321 let's say we are writing here
a
and we want the system to return the
non-digit character before three to one
in that case we use capital d instead of
small d always remember guys every
shorthand character class in rejects
have an inverse that does
precisely the opposite of that
particular class like if we have small d
here that works for digits only we also
have an inverse which is denoted by
backslash capital d and it does exactly
opposite of this small d here now if we
write here
capital d in place of small d
what will happen is it will return the
character here it will return true for
everything other than a digit
now if we remove this small d from here
and save it
here you can see it says null because we
haven't included the backslash sign here
save it
and here you can see it says
a321
it will return true for anything except
for a digit even if we put a symbol over
here then also it will return the output
as true for example if we write here
let's say we are including dollar sign
here let's say we are including two
dollar sign here save it and it will
return two dollar signs that's because
we are using the plus operator here
obviously let's include as many signs as
we can
save it and here you can see we have all
the symbols present over here on our
output
so this is how capital d character class
works or we can say inverse character
class of small d this is how it works
now the next class will be going through
is the wordly character denoted by the
letter w small w and is used in place of
any character that can be an alphabet a
number or an underscore sign
we can use this character over d if we
are unsure about the character present
before the pattern for example if we
write here
let's say backslash w
ber
now here we have used the ber pattern
which is present at the end of number
right here ber is present at the end of
number now this statement will return m
only because we are not using any plus
operator here if we use any plus
operator then it will return the whole
number because it will return everything
until it encounters a space or something
like that
so for now we are not using any plus
operator so we'll be writing here this
only now here it will return m because
it can take up a number an alphabet or
an underscore sign it will return false
if it finds any space or something other
than these three these three means a
number an alphabet or an underscore sign
fine
now save it and you can see on the
console that the output says mber let me
zoom it a bit so here you can see the
output says mber right present at index
it will return null if we put a space
before the pattern like if we write here
num space b er save it you can see it
says null for this now we can use the
plus operator as well here for this
particular character class now what will
happen is it will return every character
present before the pattern until it
encounters a space or something like a
symbol or any sort of thing so let's try
it what we'll do is we'll write here w
plus b er and we'll remove this space
from here save it and here you can see
it says number what if we remove this
space from here remove it save it and
here you can see it says phone number it
will return
every character before the pattern until
it finds any space or any other let's
say
symbol so let's say we are including
here dollar percentage
and carrot sign
save it and here you can see it says an
e number so it's returning it from here
because it will not return true for any
of the symbols here
save it and here you can see we have the
output as phone number again so that's
working totally fine
like the inverse character class for
digits we have the inverse character
class for this also and it returns true
for everything other than an alphabet
number or any underscore sign now if we
write here
instead of small w let's say we are
writing here capital w
and let's do something with the string
as well so let's put a space here again
and we are good to go we are not doing
anything more than that so it will
return null because before ber we have m
here right if we remove this m with us
sign let's say if we are removing this
with a dollar sign or with an empty one
like we are writing here space nothing
then it will return the index number and
the pattern
so let's do it save it
and here you can see it says dollar then
it says ber and index number is 14 you
can count the index number so 0 for u
and then similarly one for s two four e
three four r four for s up to fourteen
for dollar so dollar is present at index
fourteen it will return the index number
here now the plus operator also works
for this inverse character class as well
write here plus b er and we can insert
as many characters or as many symbols as
we want so like here we have inserted so
many symbols this doesn't mean anything
but we are inserting them for
example purposes or for practical
purpose so save it and here you can see
we have all the symbols present over
here in a array and the index number is
still 14. if we remove
these n and u from here now save it the
index number will change to 11
that's quite easy
now
the next class we have is the simplest
of all this class works for white spaces
only it means that it will return true
or give us the index number of the
expression
from the string only if a white space
exists before the pattern
it is denoted by small s and works for
spaces only now if we write here
let's say
backslash s
okay we have made a mistake we'll write
a backslashes
and we'll write your phone so
this is the pattern and this is the
character class backslash s is the
character class now what we'll do is
we'll
remove it from here and we'll
write the string
as this again we'll write a user's phone
number is this and this now for this
regular expression it will return the
index number of this space the space is
present at index 5
0 for u
1 for s 2 for e 3 for r 4 for s and this
space is present at index number 5 so it
will return index as 5 for this
particular space now don't get confused
guys for this index number s5 the index
number is for the space present in the
screen before the pattern phone
right
now if we try to do the same for users
as well
let's suppose if we write here
users it will return null in this case
because there's no space present before
users in the string right save it and
here you can see the output says null in
this case
fine
now we can also use the plus operator
here for more than one space is present
in the string it will return all the
spaces until it finds a character or
something other than the spaces like if
it finds any symbol or any character
then only it will return false otherwise
for spaces it will return true so if we
write here
too many spaces if we put too many
spaces before the word
phone or let's say we are changing this
word to
phone
save it and here you can see we have all
the spaces here it's denoted by a single
space but the index numbers is changed
to 19. now we have so many spaces
present here before the
pattern phone or before the word phone
so this is how we can use
space character class in javascript
now we have also the inverse class for
this character class as well it returns
true for everything other than empty
spaces if we write here
let's say we are removing this and let's
say we are right okay and let's say we
are
writing here users
and we are
giving so many spaces here before the
word users now it will return null in
this case because there are spaces
present in front of the word users
if we include a character or something
in front of this word then only the
output will change and return the index
number along with the string so save it
first and here you can see
okay we have used the smallest in place
of smallest we'll write here capital s
save it and you can see here the output
says null for capital s because this
capital s will return true for
everything other than spaces only now if
we put here any symbol let's say we have
these symbols here
save it and here you can see now we have
a hash symbol present before the word
users that's because we have used
capital s only now if we use a plus
operator save it and here you can see we
have all the symbols present in a array
we have the index number as 11 we have
dollar percentage carrot and hash
present over here right so this is how
the inverse of character spaces in
javascript actually work so these are
the character classes we have in
javascript we have come across almost
every important topic in javascript
whether it is an important one like
regular expressions in javascript or the
one mainly asked in interviews like
promises in javascript each topic has
its own value in javascript and every
topic is important
so in today's video we'll come across
two different types of games the first
one will be the one wherein we'll
recreate flappy words using javascript
now many of you guys must have heard
about this game already if not
we have to take a bird through a space
between two walls in this particular
game so let me just take you through the
game once
and
here we are so this is our game you can
see we have a bird over here and we have
to take this bird through this yellow
hole present in between the blue color
right the yellow holes are random and if
the bird strikes the blue wall or maybe
at the bottom of the screen
then the game will over fine so i hope
you guys understood what we have to do
in this particular game now we have to
press a key from the keyboard to make
the bird jump repeatedly and we have to
make the bird jump so that the bird will
go through the hole between the walls
without touching the boundaries of the
hole
so i hope you guys must have understood
the task here
now
let's try to recreate this game again
from scratch and we'll do everything by
ourselves we'll go through the html part
we'll go through the javascript and
we'll go through the css as well both
html and css will play a vital role in
making this game along with the
javascript part obviously
so let's start with the code we'll go
back to vs code and here you can see
we have a html file named
flappybird.html so we'll change the
title of this as well we'll write here
instead of document we'll write here
flappy bird fine save it
now first of all we'll take a container
for the game to run so
as you can see here we have a container
over here fine so this is our container
now we have to create this whole
container
now what we'll do for that is we'll go
to the body tag and we'll write here
div
id is let's say
game
and we'll close this day now inside this
particular div we'll create three more
div tags so we'll write here div
id is equals to
block or we can write here pipe as well
for the wall or for the pipe we can say
the next we'll write here div
id is equals to whole that is for the
whole
and the last one is for the
bird fine so we'll write it div
id is equals to
bird
we'll close this div and a fundamental
task is done here now we have a
container for the game we'll put the
game inside one single container
the next thing we need in a game is a
block which we'll use to create the
walls in the game followed by the hole
in the block for the bird to go through
it right and the last thing is the bird
itself so we'll add an image here for
the bird so let's do some styling for
all this that we have written over here
so what we'll do is we'll move to a css
file so this is a css file
and we'll write here
for the whole document the margin will
be
zero by default
okay so we'll write it as zero
and
the padding will be
zero as well fine
we're good to go that's a common thing
the margin and the padding will remain
zero for the whole html document
the next thing is to create the
background of whole document
so we'll do something creative here
something different from what we did
till now
so what we'll do is we'll create the
background with two different colors now
you might be thinking of
what these two different colors are so
what we'll do is we'll write here body
and then we'll write here
background color we'll take any
background color
let's say we are taking cadet blue
fine
now save it
save this part as well and open this on
live server
so here you can see we have a background
we have the background of html document
as cadet blue color
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
two different colors over this
background right so we'll write here
background
image and we'll write here
webkit
linear gradient and we'll write here rgb
comma 75 comma 75
then we'll write here
rgb so these are three particular colors
we'll write here
31 comma 31 comma 31 and the last one
will be
rgb
comma
153 comma
1 4 8.
fine
so here we are
and the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
min height
will be
800 pixels
now save it
and you can see here we have three
different colors over here we'll go to
our css file
and you can see this webkit linear
gradient over here is unknown to us
right so css gradients let us display
smooth transitions between two or more
specified colors
so we can do it radially or linearly
now let's see the difference and you can
spot the difference here in
the output
we have three different colors over here
we have red black and a little bit of
gray in between
right so let's move on to the first
container and will create the game area
now
now what we have to do is we have to
create the game area
so what we'll do is we'll access the div
tag with ids game
and let's start working on this div tag
and we'll understand it much better
so we'll write here
game
and we'll write here next up
height of this container will be let's
say 500 pixels
width
is let's say 400 pixels so guys remember
this height and width we'll need them
later
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here
border
and the border will be one pixel
solid
black in color fine
and we'll add a background image as well
we'll write a background image
or we'll write a background only
we'll write a url and inside this will
write
fine
save it now and
you can see here we have a container
over here
now it's not working it says there's no
such image present in a folder so what
we'll do is we'll check it from here
here we are
we have bg2 over here not bg1 so we'll
write here bg2.jpg save it now
and move back to the browser and here
you can see we have an image over here
so it's not quite visible till now
so what we'll do is
we'll write here
background size as
go fine save it now
and here you can see we have an image
over here now the image looks fine
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
margin
and we'll write here
and the margin will be
one ram
and
auto fine save it now
you can see we have the block in between
now the next thing we'll do is we'll use
the overflow property here and it will
not show the bird going out of the box
so we'll see it in a moment but this
overflow property will do so what we'll
do is we'll write here overflow
is equals
to hidden
save it now
you can see it's not making any
difference as of now but we'll
understand it later
now we have a box over here on the
browser and the game will be played
inside this particular box now we have
to work on the div for the block
so we have to create a block
and that block will move again and again
through the screen with holes present at
a random place every time
fine i hope you guys got it so let's
style the block now what we'll do is
we'll go to a css file and we'll write
here
hash
block fine so this is the id for the
block
now inside this will use
width
as
50 pixels
then we have
height
so the height will be
500 pixels equal to the height of the
whole container
the next thing we'll write here is
background
color and the background color will be
let's say
blue
fine
we will write here
position as
relative
and then we'll write here
left
400 pixels
fine
now we know that after saving this piece
of code the block will not be visible
anymore so why is it not visible it's a
question right
it arises in every person's mind save it
and here you can see the block is yet
not visible now what we have to do is we
have to set the left property as 200
let's try to do it 200 once so what
we'll do is we'll write here
200 pixels save it now
and here you can see we have a block or
a screen now the value of left property
is 200 means the block is present
to 200 pixels from the right most corner
of the container
if we write here 400
and save it
you can see we don't have any block here
it means that the block is present
right after this entire container the
block starts here and goes still here
it's a 50 pixels wide block and it's not
visible because we have set the left
property as 400
so
now the next thing we have to do is we
need some animation over this box right
or we can say we need some animation
over this block right so what we'll do
is
we'll write here
animation
and we'll
write here block we have
to perform it on a block
and the animation time will be two
seconds we'll write here
linear and
it will go to infinite fine
now this animation property will help us
in moving the box again and again after
every two seconds
and the moving points we have to define
here
so for that what we have to do is we
have to write here
at the rate
keyframes
after this we'll write here block
and inside this will write zero percent
left will be
pixels
and at 100 animation
what we'll do is we'll set the left
property as
minus 50 pixels
fine
now you guys might be wondering what we
are doing here but this keyframe here is
a rule that specifies the animation code
and it will help the block move again
and again from 400 pixel in the right to
minus 50 pixels in the left
fine save it
and we'll go to the browser
you can see the box is moving again and
again after every two seconds or two
milliseconds now the next thing we have
to do is with the hole in the block so
we have to put a hole here in the block
and for that we have to access another
div with ids whole
fine so we'll move to a css file and
we'll access that particular
element with ids whole so we'll write
here hash
whole
and inside this will write
height of the hole will be
150 pixels less than that of the block
width will be
50 pixels same as the block
and then we'll write here
background
color
fine so let's say the background color
is
yellow
this is for
practical purpose you can change it by
yourself
the next thing we'll write here is
position position will be
relative
left will be
400 pixels
and
top will be
minus five double zero pixels fine
then we'll write a animation
again we'll write a block
we'll write here two seconds we'll write
a linear
and we'll write here
infinite fine
now this hole will also go with the same
animations as the block save it
and open the
browser and here you can see the hole is
not properly over the block and they are
both at different locations so we can
try to refresh this code and here you
can see
the hole is now present at the top of
the block so here is the hole this
yellow part represents the hole for this
particular game
now it is working totally fine
and this is an empty space to make this
hole randomly come anywhere in the block
we have to do some magic with javascript
for that so we'll do it later in this
video
now if the hole is not placed over the
block in your code don't worry just
refresh the code or we can say just
refresh the home page it will be fine or
if not it will get fine once we go
through the javascript part that's not a
major deal
so let's move on to the bird now what
we'll do is we'll add an image to our
html file for the bird
so we'll write here
inside the html file we'll write here
where the id's bird will write here
img
okay we have
we'll write here src is equals to
bird
one dot
png
so let me check if this file exists in a
system or not
so here we are we have bird dot png not
bird one dot png
save it and what we'll do is we'll write
here
alt is
but we'll close this img tag save it
open the browser and you can see the
bird is not visible as of now to make
this image visible we have to work on
the styling so we'll access this image
with the id board
what we'll do is we'll go to the css
file again
and we'll write here
hash
board
the next thing we'll write here is
position
so position will be
fixed
and
top of bird will be
100 pixels
then we have
height as
50 pixels and
width will also be
50 pixels fine
we'll do the same for image tag as well
so we'll write here
bird
img
and inside this will write
height
as 50 pixels and we'll write a width
fine
is
50 pixels
right
now save it
and if we open the browser now
you can see we have a bird in our game
now we are halfway done in making our
game and we haven't used any javascript
until now right that's quite funny so
we'll use javascript now
let's move on to the javascript part
we'll go to the javascript file first
now first of all we'll access every
element of a javascript file that we can
access
so we'll use the getelementbyid method
to access every element of our html file
what we'll do is we'll write here where
whole so
whole
is the id of whole present in the block
so we can access that div tag here we'll
write here
document dot
get element by id and we'll write here
whole fine
the next thing is we'll write here where
game
is equal to document dot
get element by id the id will be
the id will be game fine
so for now we need to access these two
elements only we'll add some more
elements later and then we'll access
them so for now let's focus on these two
only
next up we need the hole to be placed in
random places in the block every time
for that we need an event listener so
we'll create a function that will change
the location of this hole every time
it will change the location on every
iteration of the block fine
so
we'll write here whole dot
add event listener
and we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a event
listener and we'll write here a function
name so let's say we are writing here
hole fine so this is a function it's
random hole so we'll write here rain
hole now we'll declare this function as
well we'll write here
function run whole and
inside of this function we'll take a
variable
random let's say so this is a variable
we'll write here
minus
math dot
random
so this is a function and we'll
multiply this value by
so this means that it will take any
random value between 0 and 350. fine and
then what we'll do is we'll add 150 to
that particular value and the whole
value will be changed to minus
we'll see it in a moment why we are
doing so so the next thing we'll write
here is
whole dot style dot
left
now whole dot style dot
top
is equals
to random
plus
pixels fine i hope you guys got it till
now
so this math dot random function will
pick any random value between 0 to 350
and 150 will be added to that particular
value because we don't want the value to
go down as low as 10 and the whole will
go out of the containers borders so the
initial value of the hole was let's
check it out
so here we are in a css file so you can
see the initial value of whole
was
minus 500 pixels for top fine
so the new value will be random plus
pixels
the value was 500 because we wanted the
hole at the top of the block and now it
will take any random value and the whole
will be placed according to that
particular random value
so let's save it
open the browser and here you can see
the hole is moving randomly now you can
see it was initially present at the top
now it is at the bottom here
so it will change the location randomly
according to the random number picked up
by the math.random function so let's get
back to the javascript part now before
we move on to the fall and game over
function
let's discuss the game over scenario
first and we'll finish out all the
necessary html and css tasks for the
game over
so the game will be over when the bird
strikes the pole or either the bird
falls down to the ground
on game over the score will be shown on
the screen with a restart button right
so the score will be counted on the
basis of blocks passed by the birds now
the number of blocks passed will be the
final score
so we'll take a variable score and
increase the value of this score
variable with each random block coming
through
so we'll take a variable score and we'll
write here
where
score
is equals to 0 the initial value will be
0. so let's do the html part wherein
we'll use a div tag to print the result
on the screen
what we'll do is we'll go to the html
file
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here after this particular div tag
we'll write
diff id is equals
to result
and here we have another div tag present
over here now inside this div tag
we'll use
h1 tag and we'll write here
game over
fine next thing we'll do here is we'll
use
p tag with ids
let's say text
fine we'll close the p tag here or the
paragraph tag we can say now we need a
button
so we'll write here button
id is equals to btn
we'll write here on click
is equals to location
dot
reload
and we'll write here
restart
fine
now the html part is done the paragraph
tag with ids text will be used to print
the score on the scoreboard
now this
location.reload method is used to reload
the whole web page on clicking the start
button the entire page will be reloaded
and the game will start again
fine we'll use css to style all of this
game over part
so we'll go to the css file and here is
the css file
now we'll write here
hash
result we are accessing the div tag with
id as a result
so the height will be
let's say 200 pixels for result
and the width
is let's say
500 pixels right
so
if i show you once again so here is the
block for game over scenario so the
height is 200 pixels and the width is
500 pixels basically we need to create a
card right or we can say a rectangle
so we'll move back to the css file and
we'll write here
background color is
let's say
down
margin will be
five frame or two
so
margin top will be five rip and then it
will do it automatically
then we'll write here
border
so border will be 2 pixels
solid
and the color will be white fine
we'll write here
border
radius
so the border radius will be let's say
20 pixels we want rounded borders
and the display will be
none
fine
the last thing we'll do is we'll write
here text
align
as center it will align the text in the
center
and the next thing we are left with is
the
button fine so we'll write here
hash btn
because the id of button element is btn
so we'll write here
padding 0.5
ram
and 1 ram
fine
the border
will be
none
because we don't need any border for
this button
we of course want the button to be round
from the corners so we'll write your
border radius as 11 pixels
background color is
green
color is
white
font size is
1.5 ram
we'll write here text
transform
uppercase
we'll write here margin top
one rim
so guys you can see we are using this
ram again and again so i might wonder
that if any one of you knows the exact
definition of this word ram if yes then
do let us know in the comments below and
let's see how many of you guys know the
actual definition of this term
so the last thing we'll do is we'll
write here cursor is equals to point
and we are good to go fine the next
thing is we'll write here
hash text
margin
top will be
one ram
and
font size will be
two ram fine
we'll do one more thing
we'll write here
color is
c shell so this will be the color of our
text so we are now totally done with the
html and css part
the only thing remaining now is the
javascript part and we have to work on
that only
so just a few more files statements and
all and we are done with the game
now moving back to the javascript part
but before we go there let me just
show you how this works
save it and go to the browser so this is
our game
and you can't see any
game over scenario here right so for
that what we have to do is we have
to go here in result and we have to
comment this
particular statement fine
display has done we have to comment out
this statement save it now
and it's not working
now as well okay here's a mistake in
this div tag
what we did wrong here is
so this was a mistake save it now
and now here you can see we have a card
for game over here and if you click on
this restart button you can see the page
is reloading again and again
so it's working totally fine we'll move
back to the css file
and we'll
remove this fine
save it now
and let's go back to the javascript part
now we'll access two more html elements
that we just created so what we'll do is
we'll
write here
where
a result is equals
document dot get element by id and the
id is
a result fine
and then finally we'll write here where
text is equals to
document.getelementbyid
and id is
text fine
so the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here where
jumping is equals to zero we'll take
another variable for the bird to jump
now we'll need all these elements
further in the video now we have to
create functions for falling and we have
to mention the conditions for game over
as well so what we'll do is we'll write
here after this renault function
we'll write here where fall
is equals to
set interval will set an interval so
we'll write here
function
and
then we have the body of this function
so
the next thing we'll do is we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals to percent
we'll write a window
dot
get computed style
and will pass bird here
then we'll write here dot
get
property value and the property value
will be
top
fine
now the next thing we'll do is
we'll write here if
jumping
is equals to is equals to zero
the body of if statement will write here
mer dot style
dot top is equals to bird top
plus
two
after this will
make them in pixels fine
now we have to mention the time in
milliseconds here so we'll write here 10
and we are good to go so here in this
function we are using the top value
provided to the bird so we have used
these two functions window dot get
computed style and get property value to
get the elements style property with ids
bird and the top value we need will be
passed to the following function the
value of jumping is zero so the style
dot top will be set to birth top plus
two pixels
now the initial value was 100 pixels
from the top
and two pixels will be added to the
value after every 10 milliseconds now
save it
and here you can see a bird will fall
eventually
fine so what's happening here is
two pixels will be added to this value
of top after every 10 milliseconds now
fine
now we have to define those conditions
here wherein we'll check if the bird
touches the ground then game over for
that we have to write inside the same
function only so we'll move back to a
function
and we'll write inside this particular
function only
we'll write here where block
left
will take the left value of block
and we'll write here percent window dot
get computed style so we need the
computed style
for block now
and we'll write here dot get
property value
fine
so we'll write here
left because we need the left value
and the value will be stored inside
block left and then we have where
whole top
fine
will write here percent window dot
get computed style we'll write here
whole and then we'll write here get
property value and we'll write here
top
fine
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where
h top
so this is another variable
so the value of h top will be
plus
up
so any value returned to the whole top
variable will be added to 500 and that
value will be assigned to h top variable
fine
now we have to write your conditions so
the conditions will be if bur top is
greater than 450 or block
left
so we've made a mistake here
we have to put one more bracket away and
then we'll write your block left
is
less than 50
and it
we'll write here block left
greater than minus 50
then we have
bert top
is less than h top
or
but top
is
greater than h top
plus hundred
fine
i'll explain it to you in a moment
now what we have to do is we have to
write here
result dot style
dot display we have to change this style
to
block now which was none till now so
then we'll write here text
dot
inner text
is equals to
your final
score is
colin will use rear dollar and then
we'll print the
score here fine now the next thing we'll
do is we'll write here
game
dot style dot
display is equals to
none which was block until now
now the last thing we have to do is we
have to change the value of score to
zero again so that the game will restart
from zero
now let me explain this to you guys
so we have to write here bird top first
not birdy up
so now if bird top is greater than 450
means that the bird is touching the
ground or we can say the bottom part of
the container
now you can get all these values correct
by going through the inspect elements
and i hope you guys already know how to
use it in javascript to get the exact
values in pixels so i want you guys to
check it to cross check it once if it's
fine or not
now if the block left is less than 50
and greater than minus 50 means if the
bird is colloiding with the block or not
and the bird top is less than h top
means the bird is hitting with the top
of the block
or the bottom of the hole we can say
the last one is for the bird to collide
from the upper part of the block
now in all these cases the result box
will appear and style of the result box
will be blocked
the paragraph tag with ids text will
show the score here and the game dot
style will change to none
now the game will disappear and the
game over scenario will come forward now
score will be again zero as if the user
wants to restart the game then he can
restart it from zero again
so save it once and let's see if it's
working or not
save it
and go to the browser
close it
okay
you can see it's working totally fine
but it says your final score is dollar
score so we have made a mistake over
here
now what we'll do is we'll go back here
and we'll check
what's wrong here fine okay the mistake
here is of single inverted comma instead
of single inverted comma we have to put
this sign over here
now save it
go back to the browser
restart the game and you can see it's
working totally fine it says your final
score is zero
restart it again and here you can see
it's working totally fine now we are
left with only one thing
and that thing is
quite easy so what we have to do now is
we have to make the bird jump on button
press so we have to create one last
function for this event so what we'll do
is we'll write here after this
window
dot add event listener
will add an event key down
and then we'll write here
hop so hop will be a function
op is basically a synonym for jump as
well
so we'll define this hop function now
we'll write here
function hop and then we have the body
of this function
so jumping
will set to 1
on calling this function and we'll write
here where
bird top
is equals
to percent
will again write here
window dot
get computed style
and the style will get from bird
and the property we want is
top
fine
now i will write here if
top
is greater than 6
then we'll write here bird
dot style
dot
top
minus
fine
okay so we'll write here
is equals to
word
top
minus 60.
so we'll put all this inside a bracket
and will convert it to
pixels so for that we have to write your
pixels inside double inverted comma
fine
now what we have to do next is
we have to write here
set
timeout
and we have to create
an anonymous function over here
so we'll write here function and we'll
again set the value of jumping to
0 after every
100 milliseconds fine
so every time a key is pressed the hop
function will be called and the value of
jumping will change to 1
it will again take the bird top value
and check if the value of bird top is
greater than 6
and if yes then subtract 60 from it and
save it inside the top of
the bird then again the bird will try to
go down after every 100 milliseconds but
the bird will also go up by 60 pixels
on each button press right now save it
and our game is ready so we are done
with creating the game now what we'll do
is we'll go to the browser and we'll
restart the game
so here you can see our bird is jumping
and
we can take the bird
from the holes so
here you can see
we have a bird and it's working
fine
so we have to take the word through
these holes so here you can see it says
your final score is zero every time
fine so let's check out for this ones
okay so we have forgot to mention here
score plus plus now save it
go back to the browser
now
we'll play this game again once
so we have to take this part through
these gaps in between the blocks
see how long it
goes so here you can see it says your
final score is 5 and then again the
value of score is set to 0 after some
time
that's because if the person want to
restart the game then the value of score
will be 0 for that restart
now here you guys just saw me playing
this exciting game and i want you guys
to try it it's fun and you'll enjoy the
game more after creating it by yourself
today we'll create a car game in which
we have to save our car from obstacles
coming towards our vehicle
i don't know the exact name for this
game but let me give you an overview of
this game real quick so here is the game
you can see over the screen wherein we
have a red car on the road and we have
to protect this car by moving to the
left or right
all we have to do is to protect this red
car from collision with the blue one
now i know the graphics for these games
are not too much appealing but if you
want to make a high-end graphics game
then javascript is not the only language
you can use
we have to use many different js
libraries and maybe several other
programming languages along with
javascript to achieve this task
so let's focus on these small games for
now and we'll go ahead step by step
now in this particular game if you see
here we have three images one is of red
car the other one is of blue car and a
road behind them right so let's move on
to the programming part directly and
most of the parts will remain the same
like that of flappy birds let's move on
to vs code
so here is our game this is the html
file and then we have a css file and a
javascript file for this game now what
we'll do first is we'll create a div tag
we have to protect a block right we have
to move the container either to the left
or to the right so for that we have to
create div tags so first of all we'll
write here div we'll take this
particular div tag for the game
and we'll write here another div with
id as
game fine
now we have two div tags over here now
what we'll do first is we'll add images
for
red car and for blue car right so what
we'll do is we'll take two div tags and
we'll write here id
as
blue car
for the blue car
and then we'll write here
img
src the source will be
blue dot png so we have a file named
blue dot png which is actually an image
and what we'll do is we'll write here
alt
so the alternate will be
blue car fine
we'll copy this piece of code and we'll
do the same for red vehicle as well so
instead of blue car we'll name the id as
red car
the image source we have in our computer
is red dot png
and alternate will be
red car fine
now we have added the two cars toward
div tag or we can say to a html file
save it go to the browser so this is our
document you can see here we have a blue
car and we have a red car you can see we
have both images over here but the size
is different the blue car looks big and
the red one is pretty small right not to
worry we'll figure it out in the css
part
so let's do the rest of the html part
here what we'll do is we'll move to our
html file again and
now one thing you might have noticed in
the game here is
on collision we are getting a card for
game over so we have to create this div
tag as well so let's finish the html
part first what we'll do is
we'll write here div again
and this time the id will be
resolved so we are
preparing for the game over part right
now what we'll do is we'll write here h1
heading
so inside h1 will write
game over so let me show you why we are
doing this so if you can see here on
collision we have game over right so
game over we have to write here now what
we'll do is we'll write here
game over like this
the next thing we need is the score so
what we'll do is we'll write here p
so we'll use the paragraph tag the id
will be score
and the score will do in javascript part
now what we have to do is we have to add
the restart button as well so for that
we'll write here button
id is equals to
let's say btn
and we'll use the on click event so on
click we'll write here
location dot
reload
we'll call this function so this is a
built-in function in javascript what
this function will do is it will refresh
the whole page fine the game will start
again
so
we have added another div tag for the
score here we have a heading game over
and a paragraph with ids score and then
we have a button to reload the web page
now let's style these elements and make
them look like a game so what we'll do
is
we'll move to the css file now here's a
css file we'll
first write here some code for the whole
html document so for inside this we'll
define margin
and the default margin will be 0.
similarly we'll define padding as well
so the default padding will also be zero
now
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write here
some code for the body
fine here what we'll do is we'll use two
colors at a specific angle of 45 degrees
we have already been through the webcam
linear gradient property in the previous
game which is flappy bird so what we'll
do is we'll write here let's take a
background color let's say the
background color is this kind of sky
blue now the next thing we'll do is
we'll take a background image and inside
this we'll write
webkit linear gradient we have already
been through this in the previous game
so we'll write here 45 degree
this is the angle and then we'll define
two colors here
so our two colors will be
gray
and the next one will also be gray but a
little bit different from this one so
we'll write here 45 percent it will take
45 percent of the screen
and then we'll write here hash so this
is the code for dark gray color and it
will take the rest 55 of the screen fine
save it for now
go to the web browser so you can see
here we have two different colors
present over here in a web browser the
colors are divided at an angle of 45
degree what we can do here is we can
write here
50 50 instead for both the colors
save it now move to the browser and here
you can see
you can clearly spot the difference here
so here you can see these two colors are
different now
we'll leave it here you can do this
thing as you wish so
moving ahead we'll write here min
height will be
800 pixels
fine save it now move to the browser and
here you can see we have a
background color set for this particular
web page
now
so after the body tag we'll do some
styling for the game content so here you
can see we have the ids game for the
first div tag so what we'll do is we'll
write here
game we'll
we'll write some properties here we'll
write here height so the height will be
500 pixels
then we'll write here
width the width of the box is let's say
300 pixels
and the border will also define so the
border will be black
and
border will be one pixel thick
solid and black in color fine save it
you can see over here
so we can't see anything for now so
let's style this first completely
what we'll do is we'll write here margin
so the margin will be
one ram
auto
now
right here we'll write background image
so the background image is the one we
already have in a folder the name for
that image is road1.png
now i will write here background
size so we'll write here
contain to fit this image inside the
container and we'll write here overflow
as
hidden
fine
save it
move to the browser and here you can see
now we have a div tag present over here
we have a container over here and we
have the blue image only for now
now what we'll do next is
we'll style these images as well so
first we'll do the same for
blue car we'll write here
blue car
and inside this will write
height as 100 pixels
width
will be 130 pixels so there is a
specific reason behind writing this 130
pixel will understand it later
now the background color for this car
will be let's say blue for the blue one
and we'll write here
position
so the position will be
relative
next up we'll write here
top
top will be
zero pixels so remember the value for
these properties we'll need them later
in the javascript part
now what we'll do next is we'll write
here left as
0 pixels
now next up
we'll write here text align as
center
and
animation so this animation we have
already been through it
now what we'll do is we'll write here
move
after one second the animation should be
linear
and
it should be infinite fine
now this animation we have to define but
before that we'll write here blue car
img so
here what we'll do is we'll define the
height of image
we'll write a height as 100 pixels
fine
now save this go to the browser and here
you can see we have a blue car present
at the top left corner of a container
now what we'll do is we'll define the
animation for this particular div tag
right so here is our car present at the
top left corner so what we'll do is
we'll move this box to the middle of the
screen so we have already done it i
guess but there is some mistake
so here you can see we have given space
between one ramp save it now
and here you can see we have a box
present at the center of our screen
now we are good to go next up we'll
define the animation so we'll write here
at the rate
keyframe
and
instead of identifier the identifier we
have here is
move
fine
so inside this will write here
zero percent at zero percent
the top will be
zero fine 0 pixels
and at 100 percent the top will be
501 pixels
fine
now one thing to notice here is
the total height of the container is 500
pixels and the animation will go till
501 pixels save it now
move to the browser and here you can see
the car is still not moving
so we have made a mistake here so here's
a mistake we have to write here move
only save it now
and here you can see the animation is
going swiftly now so the car starts from
0 pixel and goes to 501 pixel so it will
happen infinitely because we have
used a infinite inside the animation
property
what we'll do next is we'll do the same
for
red car as well fine so here you can see
we have a red car the id is red car for
this so what we'll do is we'll write
here
hash red car
and we'll start styling this
red car as well the height will remain
the same the height will be
100 pixels
and then we have the width
the width will be 130 pixels for this
car as well
the background color will be
red because the color color is also red
position will be relative for this as
well
the top will be 250 pixels let's say
and the left will be
130 pixels fine
now what we are doing here is we are
taking the
left as 130 pixels why so because what
we want is we want the car to be present
at 130 pixels away from the left corner
of the box so that's why we have written
130 pixels over here inside the left
property
now the next thing we'll write here is
text align and text line will be sent
fine
we'll do the same thing for red car as
well here we'll write here red car
img
we have to write here hash as well
now inside this will define the height
of this image
will write here height as 100 pixels
fine
save it now
go to the browser and here you can see
we have a red and blue car over here now
the box seems to be a little bit less
wide for these two cars so what we'll do
is
we'll
write the width here as 390 pixels
so that it will be divided equally in
three parts save it now
and here you can see now this box looks
totally fine we have a red car present
in the center we can move it to the left
and to the right
so we are done with styling these three
images next up we have to style the
result part as well right so here you
can see in this particular game we have
a card over here with
a different background the game over
color is white
and this color is gray i guess the
button color is black and the restart
color is
sky blue fine so we have to keep all
these things in mind we have to style
this box as well so what we'll do is
we'll write here
result
and inside this will write
height height will be
200 pixels for this box
then we'll write here
width
and width will be 400 pixels so we want
a rectangle for this
next up we'll write here background
color
so let's define the rgb value
the rgb value for this particular color
is 231
comma 1 0 5 comma one zero five
that's because we want to make the exact
same game so that's why we are using the
rgb values here save it now
move to the browser
and here you can see we have the game
over card over here and the game over
color is black and the card color is
pinkish we can say
now we'll move to a css file we'll write
here
margin and the margin will be 1 ram
auto
next up we'll write here
border radius so we want the box to be a
little bit round from the edges
so for that we'll write here border
radius as 20 pixels
and then we have
font size as
30 pixels for game over
then we'll write here
text align we want to align the text at
the center of this box
game over color will be white fine so
we'll write here white and we are done
with it
save it
and here you can see we have a box over
here we have a game over card over here
now what we want is we want to hide this
thing right so for that we have to write
here
display as none save it now and you can
see we don't have this game over box
over here anymore
now moving back to our css file what
we'll do is
we'll remove this particular statement
for now save it and here's our box again
we'll add this property later so for now
what we'll do is we'll write here
score
now
what we have to do is we have to write
here
font
size
as
2.2 ram
i hope you guys must have searched for
the ram keyword
now we'll discuss this keyword again in
the next video
so for now we'll write here
color and the color will be
let's say
take any color of your choice
so we'll write here gray
or we can say let's take golden rod i
don't know which color is it but let's
take it once
save it
and you are not getting anything over
here because we haven't defined it yet
so we'll see it later now the last thing
we have to do here is with the button
right so we'll use the button id for
that we'll write here btn
and inside this will write padding
so padding will be 0.5 ram
and
1 ram for left
now we'll write here
border radius for this button is 20
pixels because the button is a little
bit round at the corners
next up we'll write here
border is
none we don't need any border for this
particular button
then we'll write here background color
is let's say
black we'll write here
the color as
which color we should take let's take
this one
now we'll write here margin
top so let's say the margin top will be
10 pixels
next up we'll write here
cursor
so cursor will be
point fine cursor will change to pointer
on taking it over the restart button
will write here
text
transform we want to transform this text
to uppercase
fine save it now move back to the
browser and here you can see we have a
game over here
but this tag is not working for now
so let's see what's wrong here
okay so we have to write here restart
save it now
and here you can see we have a button
over here we have a restart button over
here
the button looks a little bit small
so what we have to do is we have to do
some styling change here
we'll take
let's say the font size
so we'll write here
font size is let's say 25 pixels
save it now
and here you can see the button is quite
right now
so we are done with it what we'll do is
we'll add the display property here
we'll write here display
none save it
and the box is gone fine
now we are done with the css part as
well now we have to make this game
responsive only that will do with the
help of javascript
so let's move on to the javascript file
first
here's a javascript file now we'll
access all the html elements here in the
javascript file
because we need them so what we'll do is
we'll write here where blue car is
equals to document
dot get element by id so the id for blue
car is
blue car
we'll write here where
red car
document dot get element by id
so the id is red car for the red one
next up
we'll write here where
our result will
get result as well we'll write your
document dot
get element by id and inside this will
write
a result fine we are accessing all the
elements with the help of get element by
id method
now what we'll do is we'll write here
where score
so the score will write your
document.getelementbyid and again we'll
write here score
then we'll write here where
game document dot
get element by id the id4 game is
game
fine
we'll take another variable here let's
say the variable name is variable
counter
to count the number of cards passing
through the red one to get the final
score basically so we'll initialize the
value as 0 for this counter variable
now the next thing we have to do is to
make the blue car move randomly in three
positions right
for that we'll use math.random function
again we have used this function
previously in the flappy birds game
so we'll write here
blue car dot ad event listener will add
an event
so we'll write here
animation iteration so this is a
predefined event listener in javascript
so for this we'll create a function here
we'll write here function
and we'll define the function as well
fine
so we'll take a variable let's say
random
and we'll write here math dot
floor
math dot random
so this is a predefined function in
javascript we'll write here into 3
and right here we'll write
130 fine
why 130 because 130 is the default width
which we have taken in a css file so
we'll write here
blue car
dot
style
left
is equals
to the value of random in
pixels fine
then we'll increase the value of counter
after every car passes through after
every blue car passes through the red
one save it and move to the browser
you can see
the blue car has three positions over
here can either come from the left
right or from the center any random
number from these three numbers will get
multiplied to 130 so we have three
positions only any random position let's
say the position is 1 it means that the
car is present at the left
so that particular number will be
multiplied with 130 and the left value
of the blue car will change to that
particular number
the logic is simple if the number
randomly taken is 2 then the random
value will become 260 in that case and
the blue car will have a distance of 260
pixels from the left side of the
container
so this was the reason behind taking the
width of container as 390. i hope you
guys can relate to it now so let's move
ahead and write the code for moving the
red car as well so you can see the red
car is not moving as of now will make it
move so let's write the code for that as
well
we'll move to a javascript file
and we'll write here
window dot ad event listener will add an
event here
we'll write here
key down
and we'll define a function here fine
so we'll take a parameter inside this
function
now what we'll do is we'll
write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
and then what will happen is
we'll take a variable where
red car
left is equals to
we'll write here power sent
window
dot
get
computed style
will get the computed style of
red car
and we'll write here get
property value
fine we'll take the property value here
we'll take the left value so we'll write
here left
and we'll write here if
red car left
is less than
260 pixels
then
red car
dot style
dot left
will change to red car left
plus
and the value will change to
pixels as well fine
now we'll write the code for another key
as well so we have to add two keys over
here
what we'll do is
we'll write here if
e dot
key code
is equals to is equals to
this key code over here represents the
left and the right arrow key of our
keyboard so that's why we are using here
key code as 37 and 39
39 is the default key code for the right
arrow key and 37 is for the left arrow
key
so what we'll do here is we'll write
here where red car left
is equals to percent so what we'll do is
we'll copy this from here
and we'll paste it here fine
this will remain the same
now what we'll do is we'll write here if
red car left is greater than 0
then
it will change the
style so we'll write here
this
and here what we'll do is we'll change
the value of red car to red car left
minus 130 pixels so we are moving the
car to the left or to the right fine
now we are done with it
now save it and move to the browser and
now here you can see we are able to move
the red car to the left or to the right
as well fine now we are good to go so
the next thing we have to do is to write
the code for collision of these two cars
or we can say the function for game over
as well fine
so let's head back to our javascript
file and we'll create another function
over here
so what we'll do is we'll take certain
values and pass them through some
conditions if any of the requirements
fail then the game is over the logic is
simple let's implement this logic so
what we'll do is we'll write here set
interval so we'll use the set interval
method
and we'll write here
function
so let's say the function name is
game over will
now define the body of this function
now let's discuss some things what we
need is we need the top property of blue
car we need the left property of blue
car
and then we need the left property of a
red car fine so we'll take three
variables we'll write here
where
blue car top
then we'll take where
blue car left
and then we'll take where red car left
fine
so we have these three variables over
here now what we'll do is we'll write
we'll get these values first so we'll
again use the get computed style
property and the get property value
we'll write here percent and inside this
will write
window dot
get computed style so the computed style
is of the blue car
then we'll write here
get property value will write here
top because we need the top value we'll
do the same thing for
blue car left and for
red car left fine so we'll change the
values here
we'll write here left
for the blue car left
and we'll write here
left
for the
red car
fine
we are good to go we have these three
variables
and we have the properties right we have
the value of these particular properties
now we'll write here certain conditions
we'll use the if statement again
we'll write here if
blue car left
is equals to
red car left
let's replace this left with a capital l
and we'll write here and then blue car
top
is greater than
and
blue car top is also less than 450 so we
need the blue car in between 250 and 450
for collision right what we'll do is
we'll write here result dot
style
dot display so we'll change the display
property of a result element will write
here
is equals to
block
now we need a game over card over the
game and we'll also change the display
property of game as well we'll write
here game dot
style dot display
as
none fine we don't want the game for
this now the next thing we'll do is
we'll write here score so for that we'll
write it score
dot inner html
is equals to
let's say it says
your score is
and we'll write here
dollar we have a variable counter right
we'll print the value of
counter here fine
now there is an error over here you can
see so what we have to do is
we have to put them
inside this
will not use
the double inverted commas we'll use
this instead and you can see the error
over here is gone now
so we are good to go
now after that we'll change the value of
counter to 0 again in case the user
wants to restart the game
the value of counter will start from 0
again now we want to call this function
after a certain interval of time so
we'll write here 10
and we are good too
so the set interval method will be
called after 10 milliseconds
now the same thing we did for flappy
birds as well so some conditions here
are almost same and the output is also
the same as we had for flappy birds
now
save it and you can see on the browser
that our game is completely fine now
it's working totally fine so we can play
this game
now let's play it once so here you can
see we can move our red car and the blue
car is coming randomly from any of the
three directions it means that it can
either come from the left or from the
center or from the right fine on
collision you can see it shows that the
game is over and the score is 13. now
when clicking the restart button we can
restart the game the page reloads again
and it's working totally fine now
we have to create this particular game
and we can see that the game is
completely done we can play this game
anytime
and it's fun as well of course
so we can do certain things with the
graphics as well i want you guys to do
that thing and let us know in the
comments below what else can we do to
make this game more appealing to the
user
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application there
is also responsible for how the app
looks and feels fun fact react was built
by jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discreet components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements unidirectional flow
which makes it easier to understand what
actually is going on now let's see how
it works when we trigger an action the
dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html don't worry if you
feel like you're not good at them once
you start working on them you'll get a
good hang of it finally let's go through
the impact of react on the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers statistics show that
react developers earn way more than
other web developers according to pay
scale the average salary for a react
developer in the united states is a
whopping 91 000 us dollars the average
salary for a react developer in india is
7.25 lakhs per annum over the recent
years react has gained immense
popularity and is being adopted by many
companies according to the data by
google trends react has had a better
growth scale compared to other
frameworks like angular and vue
statistics show that front-end
developers have wholeheartedly adopted
this lightweight framework forgoing
other available options if you are
skilled and have a knack for front-end
development react can help you gain
fantastic career opportunities lastly
talking about a few companies that use
react devotionally we have facebook
instagram netflix dropbox whatsapp among
others in today's video we'll be
learning all about react installation on
windows so without further ado let's get
started to set up the react development
environment we need two things installed
node and a text editor of your choice so
let's begin by installing node.js we can
head to the official node.js website
save download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
[Music]
users
first yeah now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react app okay so this command installs
all the necessary react.js modules now
to check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react
app version so you can see the version
here now let's continue and develop your
react application type in the command
create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd
my app and npm start this should
typically start your application
and here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks all right reusability is one
of the salient features of react
components one component can be reused
several times across the application and
this improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or a dot jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components alright so
i've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application also i
suggest you watch the react installation
on windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
i've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder i have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
react dom so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibley let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this video is about
components
let me save it and let me check the
browser it gives you an error so jsx
uses a conventional rule which states
that all html tags have to be enclosed
within a div tag so for example i say
div
and i enclose it so let me save and
check my browser again here you go so
multiple html tags have to be enclosed
within the div tag moving on let's
create a first functional component to
do that i'll first create a folder in my
source folder say components within that
i'll create a file say functional
component dot js all right so the first
thing we have to do is import react so i
say import react from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react.component
so going ahead i say class class
component extends react dot component
now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
features used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary files here
now let's define functional component in
our app.js component so here i say
functional com let's compile it and
check our browser here it says this is a
functional component moving on to my
class component it's the same syntax
here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i say so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same name and
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there is literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
comp one and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp one and then again i define
it here class comp one let's compile it
and run it and here we go here you can
see hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
here another class the second class got
imported while the first class that was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now i won't get into
the nitty-gritties of it because they're
advanced topics but to give you a brief
insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this snippet rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals
this
dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals is going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state
is nothing but count this top
state dot account plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
com now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component
that's going to be an arrow function
again and within curly braces i define
my class that is class say new component
extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented 2 i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to 0 okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say pureform.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regular component.js and here i'm going
to use a snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to three seconds now within
the arrow function i'll make use of the
set state function to set the state of
my property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply on itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from your component and then i say
import
regular com from regular com.js and here
let's say regular comp name equals this
dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state and
we're going to set the state for search
results to whatever is passed by the
system so the search results are going
to be returned as a callback and that's
what we store as an updated state now
coming to the add track method so let's
scroll up and we'll say add track and
this will take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks
array and then update the state so we
want to set the state of the playlist
tracks and this is how uh your state
management that we discussed in detail
is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now
let's talk about the remove track so
that's the remove track function and
that's the track that we want to remove
so let's let tracks equal to this dot
state dot playlist tracks those the set
of current tracks that we have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is not equal to the
track dot id which means this particular
track is not there in the list
okay so you need to remove that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array and then we've got to so
we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of search results and
then we are going to say tracks equal to
tracks dot filter current track current
track dot id not be equal to the track
dot id and then this is where we would
want to say this dot set
state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making the change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track
is now the remove track in the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks that will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update playlist name which will take
the name of the track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so
here let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
with v dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot url so
we actually want to go and
now save this on a spotify so that's the
reason we'll access
spotify's save playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom
name that i want to provide and the
playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view and react
simplifies this by having the javascript
and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective so even
though everything is in the same file
it's well classified and differentiated
into different code blocks so we'll add
the anchor tag and we'll say href is
http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run okay and we want to give it a
custom url name of musical file so the
h1 terminates will then say div class
name equal to app within that this is
how we're going to inject a search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component injected here and on search so
that's the custom event we will call a
method called search so on search we
just call we bind to a method called
this dot search then we'll open up
another div here we'll have class name
equal to app dash playlist and if you
remember that's exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file
we have another component called search
results that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
so it will add that new track to the
playlist by calling binding to the 2ds
function and it will remove it from the
search results text box then we have
another component called playlist and
here the playlist tracks will be bound
to this dot state dot playlist tracks
okay so on the top if you look here we
started with defining all the function
declarations in the constructor then we
provided the function definitions okay
that's how and this that we passed
refers to the context of the current uh
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etcetera that
you provide
in other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be
for the search bar so we'll name it
search bar we'll add two files within it
the search bar dot css okay and another
file that we'll need here is
search bar dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
[Music]
and margin bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.880
the border should be 1 pixel solid white
the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge to give
a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll set up
the border radius then we've got
margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of center and let's add
up a font size
of one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
uh on input and if the input is
focus so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and 0 the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well-defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 db954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got
our font
family let's set up the font family to
the same standard font 80 and it's a
part of the sans serif family then we'll
set up the font size
to 0.833
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else let me scroll up uh let's also
provide a border here so we'll remove in
fact let's remove the border we would
not want a border on the button that
would look odd so i'll get rid of the
border and color we'll specify as per
our standard color that we've been using
okay so that's the color we've specified
and then i've got font weight of 500.
finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want
the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and the rgb
combination so that completes
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and
get the code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search bar first thing let's go and
import
react from
react next thing we would want to do is
import
the search bar dot css file then we
define a class called search bar which
extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state we just need one variable here
which is the term to search for in the
search bar and then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot
search so that's the search function and
we'll have it bind to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot
set state and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get the value that is there inside that
text box the moment the search term the
user is entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update the local property props dot
on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates that's the ascii
key code for the enter button so if the
enter is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where we
write our render method that's going to
render the html view and we return the
complete view here so that's the view
now that we want to return let's say
diff class name equal to search bar then
on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i have to put up here
so in the render function uh we're going
to return a value i shouldn't forget to
export the search bar okay so that's uh
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the pattern tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with uh
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up are
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
had actually written
so two things we've completed now
in the app class okay if you look at the
app class we've actually defined a set
of functions here that deal with the
playlist and adding applications etc
adding tracks removing tracks then we've
created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core uh concept when
you're working with react where you
would actually have every separate uh
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components uh good to go
so we've got to start up on the next set
of components that we will need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder a new file called
track.css
and
track.js so that's going to manage
the tracks for us
so let's start with dot track we would
say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba
to 56 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes uh when we write up the
html view we'll add a padding here of
0.5 we'll set up a font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s
order of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265
265 5 is the last paragraph so that's
the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we need a
margin bottom of 0.22
rem finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of 0.83
rem and a font weight of 300 and a color
as well that we'll add so let's add up a
color here rgba 26 256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the javascript
file so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar i'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is remove track change
this to remove track get rid of this and
that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props so we'll
modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is
removal so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view action method that we are adding
which is going to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is
what it's going to map to let's close
this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and the binding is
what we have done to this dot
remove track and
we will terminate this
here so now the render action uh let's
also have the return here and we just
add up the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic
in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added this button with
the hyphen is going to remove the track
this button uh with the plus sign is
going to add the track and you can
actually see how simply it was done in a
render action function so the render
action function actually helped
with uh checking that if uh
on the value of the props
and if the user uh depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh the class name here is now going to
be track the class name for uh the
enclosing div inside it so let me get
rid of this the class name for the
enclosing div here
is going to be
track dash
information within it we'll add h3 we'll
bind to this dot props dot track dot
name so the name of the track is going
to get bound here then in the paragraph
we will bind to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot algo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe and iframe
allows us to
very easily inject some content into the
page within a small embedded window the
source parameter of the frame is going
to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed slash track and
close this so that's the spotify stream
that we are going to connect to and this
dot props dot track dot id so that's the
track id the width is going to be 300
the height parameter this the height
parameter is going to be 80 of the
iframe and
the frame border is going to be zero
and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method uh which will actually
give us plus minus button to add and
remove a
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good uh in terms of the
track component now and uh we have all
of the functions in place it's now time
to jump into the uh next component that
we would require after the track
component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track
css
and it's going to have track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much so let's
just say track list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need uh in the css so
let me add this in the css file save
this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on add defined so that's
what we connect to we add up my base
bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove will do this
dot prop start on remove so that's for
the track removal and
so we've got our track list oh yes we'll
have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export
the track
list so we've got one more component
done which is track lists and let's move
on to the next component now so we've
got app which is root we've got the
search bar that takes care of entering
the search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a track list that manages
a set of track records so the track is
more relevant to the playlist and then
we've got the search results also to
manage once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we'll say search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels
we'll say
overflow y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide a shadow dropping shadow of zero
four pixels to pixels to pixels ash
and then uh
let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozad are the constants specific to
mozilla and
chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
width is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of two
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with
the css i need to get to the uh js file
now let's move to the search results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list add it up
here this will be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list this will be track list
and
i'm just going to return class name will
also be
search results so that's the component
and this is going to export out search
results so it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results let's go and create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props dot
search results and on the on add we are
going to bind to this dot props dot on
add so we already have that so that uh
basically completes
search results and uh that leaves us
with the last component which is going
to manage the playlist for us so we'll
add up a new books we'll add up a new
folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
wheels first set up
the css that we will need uh to add up
to the playlist and i'm just going to
pick that up from
my code snippet so that's my playlist
and let me get all of that css here so
that's uh just the css for the playlist
nothing to do with react again pure css
let me get
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes this is going to be
playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we leave
this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot
target dot value so we get the updated
playlist name
coming to the render we now need the
input
input uh is going to be on change equal
to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is what i will
add the tracks i'm going to bind to this
dot props dot playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll find that to this dot
props
dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we need to
do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in uh and create
an id it takes us to our dashboard uh
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musical file okay and we'll say that we
are building uh some kind of desktop app
for example for which we want to uh
connect this to and we'll also need to
provide
so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's uh
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration agree with the
terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique so i'll just copy that up let me
come up to my application under the
source folder i'm going to add a new
folder called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at the source of that as we go
through the demo the next variable that
we'll create is the redirect url or
let's call it redirect uri and that will
equate to localhost colon3000 which is
the port and we'll create another
variable called the access token let's
also create another constant variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression so we'll equate it
to a function called get access token
and we will say if access token is true
then return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match
which will be equal to window dot
location dot href dot match and we will
say this is equal to access token which
will be equal to and we will give a
regex expression to do a pattern match
ampersand so that we can actually get
into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence
the patent match is crucial here another
constant
variable called
expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another edge x
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case
the access token should be equal to
access token match of one then we create
a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say window dot
set timeout and we are going to say
access token equal to comma expires in
multiplied by thousand then we will say
window dot history dot push state and we
will say access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client underscore id equal to dollar
client id ampersand response type equal
to token ampersand scope equal to
playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we
will say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass https
api dot spotify.com
slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response and then we
will say
return response dot json after that
another then block so we'll now say json
response
and if
not
json response dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else we will return json
response dot tracks dot items dot and we
will pass
we'll create track as
a variable with a lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary json object
with id and that's where we want to
associate track dot id that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artist of zero dot name the
album is going to be track dot album dot
name and the uri we will equate track
dot url so that completes uh this block
will open the next and we this will be
the save playlist which will take the
name and the track uris and here we will
check if not
name or
not track uris dot len in that case we
simply return out of the code and then
we declare a constant variable called
access token which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token we then
declare headers
authorization bearer is going to be
dollar access token and we'll create a
user id and now we will return the fetch
result where we will pass https
api dot spotify.com
slash v1 slash me so that's the url
comma headers will be the header
information then we call the then
function declare response as a variable
use the lambda expression and access
response dot json we use the then block
to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 slash users slash dollar of user id
slash
playlist so this is how we have
constructed uh the urls manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as post so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the url and as the body
we will say json.stringify
to convert this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable to
response dot json and then we'll create
json response with the lambda operation
we'll create a constant playlist id
which is equal to json response dot id
we will return fetch
https
api dot spotify
v1 users
dollar user id slash
playlist slash dollar again we are
constructing the url so playlist id will
be replaced here then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers variable be constant headers and
this
flows here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method is going to be post and the
body is going to be json dot stringify
uris
track urls and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we'll have
to do which is export this class out so
export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is
the client id that we'll have to exactly
match so i'll copy this client id and
provide it here so that's the client id
that we actually need and we could also
store it
out here
so that's the client id and that's the
redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if
the access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from
the moment we try and connect with this
particular url and you can look here
that this is the access url that we are
trying to connect with okay with the
client id and post fixed with the
redirect url right and then i've got a
simple search function which returns an
observable so we try to fetch data using
the search term that we provided okay we
try to fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this json object to the track
id name artist information album name
etc and here
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service
by using this client id
and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and
bring out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is uh
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of tracks which are maintained by
the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them into the
playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here i am just going to
search for an artist
and we click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions and i've just agreed to that
so the very fact that it actually uh
gave us
a confirmation link the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected to the service there
and tried to return a value to us
so this is what we did we just added an
artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on developers.spotify
it's blank so now i'm going to click on
save to spotify okay and that clears the
playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got successfully connected out
here now i'll have to log in to so this
was the development app that we actually
created on the developers portal of
spotify now we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs that i'd actually added to
the playlist and you can see here those
four songs have got added out here okay
so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist uh the playlist has
got generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity uh that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks
then we created the search results which
will generate a list of results which
further contains a track list and this
is the embedded iframe which gave us the
response which is scrollable here and
you can see that the iframes we created
allowed us to scroll this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and re-testing the entire
application as a whole in this session
we'll be comparing the three
cutting-edge ui development technologies
that is react js angular and vue we
learn about the key differences that
make them so distinct all of these
technology stacks have been replacing
pure server-side technologies and we've
slowly progressed from server-side
applications to more distributed
applications where a part of the job is
done on the client side and apart on the
server side and now we've transitioned
to something known as single page
applications or sba and all of these
technologies that you see on your screen
right now are based purely on javascript
as a result they're lightweight and
aren't dependent on any third-party
runtime tools so let's compare the three
technologies and learn about the factors
that make them stand out so let's see
what's in it for you we learn about
their features use cases and where
they're applied their performance how
they handle data the languages they use
and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react as extremely
fast on the other hand real dom updation
is time consuming risky and error pro
vue also ensures faster and bug free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an ecommerce
website as the user one then you should
be able to see the items in your
shopping cart while user two would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help of data binding data binding is
a process that allows an internet user
to manipulate web page elements using a
web browser now it is used in
interactive components such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar 2v data binding in react every
time the model state updates the view
changes accordingly however the reverse
is not true in case of angular any
changes made to the view are immediately
reflected in the model part of the
architecture view follows the same
principle now this hugely influences the
performance due to one way data binding
react is modular and fast improving the
performance angular's two-way data
binding adversely affects the
performance and view on the other hand
performs according to the input type
moving on to scripting languages react
combines ui templates and javascript
logic resulting in a new language called
jsx so react only requires a knowledge
of javascript angular uses templates
again in html you can also inject
javascript code into html using a clever
implementation in angular called
directives so you can create a class and
then inject it into html angular also
does something better you can also write
code for an angular application using a
newer language developed by microsoft
called typescript it is a compiled
language and is very similar to java and
c-sharp in terms of syntax now vue again
uses html based template it uses html5
throughout for the ui and the
combination of javascript for business
logic all view templates are valid html
and can be passed by html parsers let's
move on to testing now just is a
framework or an api that is developed by
facebook and is used to run tests on
react applications to ensure that they
are bug free now it is embedded
typically in every react library and
requires zero configuration now angular
on the other hand uses the jasmine
framework now this framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is free the
view cli or the command line interpreter
has built-in options for unit testing
with the help of jest or moca now view
typically has single file components and
hence these components can be tested in
isolation this makes it modular and
extremely fast now let's talk about
community support since all these tools
are open source they have a large
developer community there are a few
popular github repositories for react
such as react.js 101 react.js.org and so
on you can raise queries solve a few and
connect with the larger community that's
working on react here are a few
repositories for angular view also has a
few popular repositories you can commit
download third party plugins and also
explore these stacks even deeper all of
them surely have a very happening
community at the time of writing there
were about 1 million repositories 5
million comments and 1 million issues
with respect to react here are the
figures for angular and here are the
figures for view according to npm stat
over the past two years there have been
approximately 360 million react.js
downloads there have been around 38
million downloads for angular and around
63 million downloads for vue now let's
look at the future scope learning a new
technology always comes with questions
like what's in it for me what's its
growth potential how far will it take me
in my career and so on so let's go ahead
and see the growth rate of react angular
and vue according to google trends over
the past 12 months react has been on a
way faster upward trajectory than
angular and view which have considerably
lost their momentum now this indicates
that react is growing faster than the
other two with respect to popularity
industry adoption and community support
welcome to this session on how to
connect react.js with node.js and in
this session uh we are actually going to
look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an express.js application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and
let's start with creating our client and
node express applications and see how to
set them up and then get them connected
to each other let's start with our
hands-on demo and we will first go to
the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it within our
editor so we'll give it time uh so that
the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
is now completed and let's
go and open up this project so i will
say file and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us uh our startup page the sample
uh default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go and try
to create uh the backend uh application
which is going to be another application
that we will set up and to create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will create
an express application on node.js called
api and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done clear
this screen we'll come out here we'll
open another instance of the editor
we'll say open folder and that's the api
application we'll say select folder and
the api application is opened let's go
to the terminal now in the terminal we
will attempt to install all of the
packages that are required that would be
logged in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be listed
so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates uh the client
application that was executing and now
we will say npm start so that this
application executes and let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route root route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends
react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props here i would pass props
to the superclass constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that
api url which was http localhost 9000
was the port and test api was the url
once this is called we will then call
the then function declare response
generate a call to response.txt and then
we will again say this dot set state api
response
is going to be equal to the response
that comes in from that url which is
nothing but a string which says api is
working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name as app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done uh
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a
lifecycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when we have actually gone and executed
the call api custom function let's go to
the api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this and we'll clear the
screen let's go to the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use cars so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's uh fire up this
application with an npm start let's also
fire up client with an npm start and now
when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is written there could be in string text
or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux and what are those
pillars that drive what you're doing
redux and then finally what are the pros
and cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using uh redux so you
can actually see how this would all look
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux is that
redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know
take a
large application that you could create
with app with a react and breaks it down
to several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-rendered which
reduces the efficiency of your
application
and so this is why redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
state container for your javascript
applications and allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key
elements that i like about redux is that
it's really easy to test and so with
redux you're able to manage the state of
your tool uh you can actually use it to
work with any javascript framework or
library
and you can actually then store the um
the application
and the components in a state store
which makes it easy to be able to manage
the state of your application so in
simple words redux stores all the state
objects in a single store and organizes
it it provides information about the
current state of the application any
changes in the state the application can
be described to the store by the user
and then it notifies any modifications
made to the state of that application so
let's jump into the key principles of
redux and there's three key areas i want
to focus in so the first one is that
redux provides a single source of truth
and that source of truth is being able
to store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect
components of your application
also enables you to be able to persist
your app state for development and
improve fastest development cycles the
second principle is that state is read
only and that's why you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application
and that object actions have become then
just plain objects
and then finally changes are made with
pure functions and so what do we mean by
this
so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree with pure reducers and we'll go
into a demo electron to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to a previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into a
smaller reducers
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
and there are four key
states there's get state which turns the
current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window
the second state is dispatch and this is
a an action it's the only way to update
the application state and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe and these are our ways in
which you can actually change the
listener to the state so an action is a
plain object that represents an
intention to change the state so with
actions you have payloads of information
that send data back and forth to your
application store
so you can send any kind of data and
they can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a tight
field that indicates the type of action
that has been performed then finally
with reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make your solution really
optimized as an experience and then
finally developers can track everything
that's going on inside the app in real
time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but the component cells can access data
and they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is
strict in its setup and it is memory
intensive so with that let's go in and
look at a demo of using redux to
reformat a react application so in this
demo we're going to use react to show
how redux can work first thing we want
to do is go ahead and download node.js
we're going to go to
nodejs.org to get the latest download
the downloads are available in windows
mac os and linux you can also download
and recompile the source code if you
want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node
version it's going to give me the
version number so that shows it's
installed and we'll also use npm which
is node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm dash dash version so
okay so looking good and we're going to
go ahead and create a folder um on our
desktop um normally you wouldn't put a
project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're going to call this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being taken through
redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax
and we're going to do create dash react
dash app so we're going to create a
default react app and then we'll also
install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to
build out our solution one is react and
it's react.js and the second is redux
and we hit return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
i'll just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we have everything installed
great and these are just different
commands you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so i'm
going to use visual studio code to do
most of our work here vs code
is open source solution for
scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source and uh there's just a ton
of stuff here but we're going to go
ahead and open up the folder we just
created on our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder just getting
rid of the welcome screen we don't need
that anymore uh you'll see there's some
commands we can use we do uh
control plus
um i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the product
files is just the application itself so
here on the index.html you see the index
file there and we're going to actually
show what this looks like inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now uh we're going to create a
very simple application here
and the application is going to look
exactly the same in both um
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's going to be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's going to take us to local
host call on 3000 give it a moment and
then we should get our
floating uh logo showing that the
application is up and running up there
we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're gonna go
into app.js
and we are gonna create an application
called
new comp
dot js and we actually have some code
that we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component
from
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the bat shop yes
and then rerun
npm
install
dash dash save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show
how you can optimize your solution with
redux for the uh using the store and
reduces in redux
now again
the the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app
don't forget to save your work as you go
along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
like italics
then we're gonna
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call
reference this styles for
this h3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribe
to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style
i'm going to add in a button
one click
action
subscribe
and don't change too many s's
save that
all right save now let's run
the script
and we're going to actually import that
into
our app.js script
okay
rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
the newscorp js
component into here
player in
font style here
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
now playing from use call
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run that
npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and
let's see now oh yeah this is good
now we actually can show you that uh we
didn't actually write all our code
correctly so let's go back and fix that
it's newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we have a correct export feature
here so that the image that
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
problem hey there we are so welcome and
then we have the standard set object of
subscribe to simplyline hit subscribe
and we change the text to thank you for
subscribing
okay so let's kind of
go in and modify this now so it goes
from being a standard state object to
one that uses store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and essentially reset everything
and we're going to do now is install
redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
and here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
cont store
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and
we're gonna
pull in
strict mode
okay juicer is not defined let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to props
equals
state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
[Music]
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to
return
and we have our button
change
for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so pass the value over
all right
and now we actually
connect
as parabolic export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here so serve to
button change we're going to do props
dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
you go ahead and create a new folder and
then this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
i'm going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and
constant new state
it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm going to change the message
so it's unused comp
so that's the
action there we
pull that
so it's identical
and then new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default now we have the new
message
again this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start let's see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
and this again this is all part of your
standard coding is just hunting down
errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
looks like
we're going to pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be spelled correctly there we
go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back
recompile
let's
rerun our
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying making main
chart provider
store
[Music]
is referenced correctly
okay let's rerun our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now we're able to manage our changes and
our elements for our applications
different objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
solutions how this becomes useful and
you can start using the different
components you create
for your
whole solution
and that's our demo hi guys welcome to
this video on react native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used offlinely
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross
cross-platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform
next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides a
strong developer and debugging tools
with meaningful error messages so
working with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook stack
overflow is an excellent website with
several developers interacting about
issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience now since
react native applications run on both
ios and android devices there's a huge
user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform specific
applications as discussed earlier react
applications work on multiple platforms
while in the case of platform-specific
applications as the name suggests these
applications are built for the specific
platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background in this case when you
consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform-specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform-specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites for
building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong hold
in programming concepts like functions
objects arrays and to lesser extent
classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic concepts
like view state props and styling in
react native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties
now props are passed from one container
to another as a way of passing data
between them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how we can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last and final
section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native welcome
to this session on react native versus
flutter in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be
that at the end you should be able to
decide and make an informed decision as
to which framework is the best among
those available let's start from a
language perspective now if you look at
react react is basically completely
written and built in javascript using
the react.js api on the other hand if
you look at flutter it is basically
written in a very new language called as
start and we do not have uh too many
developers that are skilled on dart
however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with uh an
in-built javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice for
developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer would have
inbuilt support for executing javascript
programs similarly most popular
platforms mobility platforms like
android and ios have default support for
executing javascript programs and that's
the reason when you compare this with
flutter flutter uses dart which is
predominantly a newer language and we
really do not have too many developers
who are skilled on this so actually is
the selling point
and the usb of react native because when
you work with react native you really do
not have to relearn a lot you don't have
a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with means tag already working with html
css and dhtml can easily align to this
that as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based
pretty much on native components for the
android and the ios platform and flutter
on the other hand uses a very
proprietary uh set of widgets and it has
its own page structure that needs to be
set up so it's a closed ecosystem as
compared to an open ecosystem in react
native which allows you to go and
implement third party widgets and ui
frameworks as well now this is really
what allows you to pick and choose with
react native because
you can go and decide whether you want
to use kendo ui or a set of generic
controls or any other third party ui
framework can be implemented but for
flutter you have a pretty closed
ecosystem and that's the reason the ui
components that are available out of the
box and built into the platform are all
that you can use from a performance
perspective when you talk about react
native it basically is built and uses
javascript out of the box and that's the
reason when you want to write any code
in javascript that connects and tries to
access native services on that specific
platform it uses a bridge to do that but
when you're using flutter on the other
hand flutter does not need any kind of
bridge so there's no concept of you
write flutter code and then it uses a
bridge to go and connect to the native
set of components to interact with and
this is what really impacts the speed
and the performance aspect of developing
and executing applications between both
these frameworks because if you look at
react the speed of development is a
little bit slower when you compare that
with flutter and that's because it has
an intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well-defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
coming to the community to go and find
out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
natively there for a while now it's been
around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css and building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends
you could actually look at both of the
lines here the red line indicating
flutter it started on a very positive
note and then there was a plateau and
then suddenly a spike react native has
been much more steady in terms of its
growth and ultimately if you look at it
now both of them seem to be trending at
par with each other so the community
support as we were speaking about if you
look at stack overflow which is one of
the most popular websites to go for any
kind of uh developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and uh also
react native is part of
github as it's open source it was
released in 2015 and it's because of the
huge community support that it becomes
easier to implement this you have a lot
of confidence as a developer when you
start building on this stack because if
you're stuck somewhere you will have a
lot of help available on the way on the
other hand if you compare that with
flutter you can look at the question
count here on stack overflow and this
being a new entrant in the market uh it
has a smaller footprint on the community
aspect but of course that keeps
increasing every day again from a react
native perspective and you talk about
stability in terms of stable releases
there again you would see that react
native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really
move ahead on our career graphs in terms
of the opportunities market the job
market etc so again getting back to
stack overflow which is the benchmark
for understanding technology trends in
ide sphere and software development if
you look at a recent survey conducted in
2019 uh 62.5 percent of developers uh
seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg
you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not locked any longer
required in flatter and hence the
performance is impacted because of the
additional layer in between the
documentation much much better in
flutter because it's a closed ecosystem
and they can control what you can use
react native being open-ended it really
has a lot of third-party integration you
can do and hence the documentation is
not really well organized the popularity
perspective react native much more
popular among html5 css three mer mean
stack developers since it's all
javascript flutter needs you to learn
new skills and you need to spend
additional time for that from a
community support react native has been
there for a longer time as compared to
flutter and hence has a stronger
community support as compared to flutter
and that translates into better job
prospects in the industry for react
native as compared to flutter so if we
were to give it a score react scores
much better with a total score of five
leaving flutter with a total score of
two so i hope we were able to understand
the differences between the react native
and flutter and this will help you make
better decisions with planning your
career and deciding which technology you
should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so we'll be using javascript
to be installing react and installing
the various components such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see my calculator
works just fine and now let's go ahead
and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms uh it comes with a ton of
extensions so you can get up and running
really quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to download
it again you also want to make sure that
you have the latest version of node.js
installed now with that node package
manager so we're just going to open up
our terminal window and validate which
version that we have running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and the
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and they'll give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to uh
do that and we're gonna also now create
a react app so we're gonna do install
and then it's gonna be create dash react
dash app that's the command to create a
new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react
code and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and
that will take a few minutes just to
install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be saved on
the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have uh our new folder right
there
uh on our desktop um but we're actually
gonna go now into visual studio and if
you've seen any of the other
uh node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code um because
i can run terminal window right there so
i'm going to open up the folder that we
just created that's
called calculator i want to open up the
whole folder
not a file but the whole folder and
here's our folder on the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default
uh element
and as you can see because we're using
react it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference um some
uh class files that we create and so the
app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to
our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001.
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh let's
see now yep everything's running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the app or you can
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just
restart our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default react app
[Music]
there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
i'm putting a default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
select import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
components
layout you need so we have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that
so dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
and constantly making sure that we're
saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're going to have to type that in
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
you can
show up correctly
okay so we'll go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to
update uh yep i know we have to go back
to layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we go okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
and
put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a
css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but
as bottom line is that the calculator
really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons on the screen but we
use css to reformat them so it looks
more like a traditional calculator
that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same button elements
which consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command
um this is some basic javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete
now we have an unclick event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
making sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just going to copy everything over
just make it a little bit easier
ourselves
and then we're just going to pipe in the
numbers
7 8
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay i can get
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
now
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just going
to pull those
over um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create csc css files and
um you know we'll certainly do that but
i think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the watercolor et cetera et cetera
and so i'm going to do that
here we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css then we just
have basic buttons we have the css link
back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the result
screen and the
uh default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets from the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then just
reference that in our image reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we go to amg which we
have our image
and then we'll do the path for the logo
dot
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
don't generally normally do this i
normally have all my styling in my css
folder
but
in this instance because we're just
putting up a solution i want you to be
able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are how about
that logo
okay so now we need to have the results
screen make sure that looks correct
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue
screen and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and
now
row
and we're gonna
put our instructions here so we're gonna
like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct our solution
now i'm going to update the output
row.js file and
we're going to
add in our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field
that will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to go out formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row dot
css we're going to add in our specific
css
for
this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go to our css file and we'll update that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will
play in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring our text size for our output
flow here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rows
save that
and
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm going to
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css
styling to this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is nothing no rocket science
here and we've done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
we have to
pull that font over um and
it's just a ttf font true type font
now you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our
font so that the second row the text is
a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so net
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the result
the you state
the initial release date will be just
blank
there we go
this is what you'd expect to see
so the results
are blank and this is just when you run
the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together our
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application
putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as
images
fonts
css files
laying out our core structure in html
form elements
and now um the part that we're doing at
the end here
is putting together the script that will
actually write
that actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a
base for what we're doing here
there we have an if there's an error
we'll do math error result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
there are different results
so depending on
um
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign
and
we have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
and
but if the string is
zero then put
that as the value
all right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands or your variables lining
up
correctly
eliminate those
now make sure we have the answer
and the user
entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over and this is now this is
our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we will restart the services
say yes
i'm running out of another port because
we already have an app running on
another port so it's going to run on
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good
working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
make it a native application as well
right now we're just using as a web
application
and we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app
all up and running
hello everybody and welcome you all
so
we're going to talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is once called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens
when we work on react-based development
so in react 16.8
we have introduced a new feature called
react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks we
were writing so much of code because of
that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way this we're gonna see it now in
those slides
now what are the react hooks
see the react hook is a special feature
that lets you
hook intro
now what is this
see they say few important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
stateful logic without changing your
component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hooks let you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle management
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards a
state
less or functional component so by
adding those hooks features so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you'll be having some
add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks
so there are few rules of the react
hooks which you need to understand
and what those are
number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hooks only call hooks from the
react function component don't call
hooks from the regular javascript
function instead you can call hook from
the react function component or call
hooks from the custom box so there are
multiple options are available which you
can expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used straight hooks event hooks and
create customized hook and we will see
some demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of oxy
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
event based host we're talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
prob start
count so my question is like what do you
mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name called
obstacle
dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces and after this curly braces
here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we are giving count
initial value equal to what a zero now
and
post this
this value whichever we are giving it so
what we also do in the same line is uh
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way
i can say set count count plus 1
okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was zero
that's why if you see initial value was
zero
so now because of getting the initial
value called props dot count and now i
can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say one and this value rather
than say count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hopes of an option which
is available called life cycle hooks
life cycle hooks are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to learn
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it
so are you going to be making it now
let's take a look now so initially what
i'm doing is
i'm just creating a new function called
use because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16.
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property from react and
under this use effect what i will do is
i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see it is saying called every
time even if i say increment it is
getting called even decremented is
getting called and reset it will get
called
because this is a life cycle method
and the life cycle method means it will
get called
normally in a react we have a call
component dead mount and component did
update so it is a combi of both
okay
however
you can
stick this particular use effect to the
specific need only like if you do not
want this to be get called
on updates only when the component
launches so what you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this is square bracket will contain
those values which you would like to
watch for those changes
so if you do not keep it anything by
default it will be what blank so now if
i just go ahead and start it is saying
called every time and now i can say
it is not getting called at all because
now
it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching
not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not every
time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect and
say called
on update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see the state is getting
changed for this count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the count and this you
are not listening to anything so you are
making it a supply
i hope you are clear about what use
effect is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
straight hook where we have seen use
effect we have also seen another feature
that is known as called use state and
now we're going to be talking about our
next okay everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as caller use
context see when we talk about react use
context we always have a very special
feature coming up with us where the
reusability comes as in priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem and
then we discuss about the solution so
now here
i'm going to say
use
context structures and in this use
context.js
what are we doing it i'll be creating
some few functions here i'm saying
function
name
okay
so in this manner i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
use state admin
and now after this
i'm using return
and in this return
with my div tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name call
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise
if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use
that's an important thing i would like
to consider right now so this is my
first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this i can copy
and say
um
user2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
users in parameter
okay so return
you can define it anything i can say
paragraph
and this i can say
user to
component
okay and i'm saying
component to and now i would like to
pass this value further to the another
component now
so what i'm trying to say now here if i
say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space
user
equal to
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this
functionality
so we are having this function user2
okay so after this
we are taking function 3 and adding the
data right over there
okay so this div tag
whichever you're taking it
so we will call main app we can say
user two and forward per user three so
the data we can keep on passing from one
component to another component
so we have got this component with me
user 2 and same time we have called
user3 now
okay and this user 2 whichever is
available to me
ok when you're saying hello user
this user 2 i can provide this data
right over here
okay so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay
and with this we can provide the value
called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are
utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what you'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app wants to pass the data directly to
the user three it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user
three only from its immediate child
which is a user tool
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called lean app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
approaches
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome admin commandments
so that's pretty fine
components are basically rendered but
there is no reusability if you see like
it is a plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
app context equal to
create
context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
a create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this
context so anyways i'm having this dev
tag so i'll be using this option i can
use a context
or the context which you have created
that is called app content so we are
saying what
app context here
okay
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context
i would like to cut it
okay and paste it after here
okay and here
user to equal user to whatever it is the
value is there so you are passing it to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whoever wants to access your
context
it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap this second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
video to the user three also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay
so
you say value equal to what
user here
so after that you are saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it
okay and say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user two
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected
okay so that becomes the idea of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay user f is basically what the user
you can say it is the kind of hook which
allows you to persist value between the
renders
again i'm telling you user f allows
actually to persist the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a re-render when
updated
okay
that means
you can purchase that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example so you all
can understand how we can utilize this
okay
so i'm gonna create another one here
name call use
ref dot
cheers
inside this use ref.js so let's get
started with this implementations the
one which we are looking at it now
so called users so once again i am
creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl
comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
prep value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use
ref you can see it is coming once again
from the where from the react here in
this user we can pass initial value
blank we do not have initial values so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
value
okay dot
current
equal to
input val
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
be get updated so we are passing
input value for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i'll be
saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
dev tag
and here in this directive we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready
i just want to use the
s3 tag
to show what is the current value we can
say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we are saying
last value of
using
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what the kind
of value you are actually expecting into
your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist
use reference value between the render
so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name of
app
and this app i'm using it here in my
app.js
app
let me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's say
blue color 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure we'll be able to see the outcome
soon into our system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value when i said three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value
that's where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you
so everyone we have already seen like
our previous example like how we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in
hooke's continuation to this
and that we're talking about called
working with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook which is as same as like
an user state
okay it allows for
custom state logic
unlike
the normal state how we maintain using
new state allows to help
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where if you have
multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contain
the centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can really do this and
how we can utilize that so in hooks demo
i i'm going to create a new file here
i'm going to give the name call
not
app.js
and in this node.js i would like to have
some initialize state i won't like to
make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic called
const
node reducer
node
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like in normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition client so client is ready to
invoke i'm saying action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
which all the existing nodes are
available populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
nodes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of states are available which i
would like to show it back to the client
so we are using this option like it
const
let's create a states first so we are
saying const
nodes
comma
dispatch equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is user
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken as
an action here
and comma the initial state which i'm
making it is a blank
i do not have any states i'm making it
as a blank again i'm using this option
again const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank
so that's how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically
display the list of nodes back to my
application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write okay so let's check in case if
i want to return
the bulk of notes how do i do this
so here
let's try to create
the
notes app so
this i would to make it
that was the reducer for us
now here we gonna create const
node
tab equal to
and i'm closing it here
okay
so we are having these two properties
with me
and
we can have n number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the dip tag
inside this tab tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
dot
map in case if i'm having a array of
nodes map is a predefined function
for me so here we're using what
note
okay so
so inside this you would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
we can just use
the default sheet which is available
called nodes
equal to what nodes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is
and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
note app
and this note up i'll be making it as a
child of app.js
okay
you can see i have got initial data
displaying here so in case if i have few
more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see our got
list of records are available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about what
in case if i want to use
you know this reducer so how we can
further utilize it to initialize
the data with this but later on if i
want to some add some actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm going to tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular
tool so what is the user memo it is
again another hook
so
use memo hook returns some memorized
value what it was the previous value was
so you can
say think of
uh
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value it's in that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function okay so it is
used memo can be used to keep expensive
and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running so we will
see how this
use memo can work so let's check this
out and see see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
uh calculations so that it doesn't need
to run unnecessary every time okay so it
does a kind of caching behavior for you
to make your life even more simple so
let's see how it works so accordingly
you will also get the implementations
okay
so you need to understand the use memo
hook accept the second parameter
okay to declare it dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
okay so inside your memo app.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here you see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say zero for a time being i'm
trying to use now
okay
and uh
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform
this job only okay count and set count
according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
equal to use state
i'm making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation
equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal to
set count
c
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to do's here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions will basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i am having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another div tag here and here we're
using
my
after this h2 we would like to use
toodles dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here here
sorry
equal to what
index here
and here
totals
[Music]
okay
who do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
will be calling
add task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so here after this
div tag is getting closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another tip tag
here
and here we are saying
count and here we're using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here and
call something called
calculation
just like a normal message
and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done so your dip tag
is also close
both the two tags are kind of getting
close
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so
let's see what we are trying to do
so here i am saying
power running calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button insert this lock button i'm
saying
calculating here and post this
this thing is called for
let
i equal to zero
i is
less than
[Music]
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
now
equal to 1
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay
so this would be my application here
okay so
now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function
okay will only run when the count is
changed
and not when the to do's are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we're using this statement
and
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long-running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to declare
a dependency this exp so the long
running functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's the whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo is really performing some job
the one which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and uh
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is called use
imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look
when we talk about use imperative
handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use reparative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code
okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js
and after this we are writing
function
converter
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props
and seconds called what ref two
parameters we are passing it now here we
are saying
const
user if
okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
impellative handler and here we are
passing what
refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality coupler
okay and here with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
customer is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return
we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props
we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay
that's it and
once it is done then
we would like to use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application system
so once it is ready i would like to
make it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here you are passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here
i will be making it as a child off but
[Music]
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
uh i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react and
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having we
just said cut
and passing it here
and this under this written keyword i'm
using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yeah
so inside this button using
one click
equal to
we are saying vtn
okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class we have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
so we're providing what btn dot current
dot
blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the options
were so you understand in this
particular example we have developed a
custom button component that has a user
defined instance attached to the
reference object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed the
button component that has a user defined
instance
attached to the reference object so
button component is the child component
of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called
user defined blur function which is
attached to the pass reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't written anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
username parity reference so we have a
call function button
we are passing two parameter props and
ref
so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as in the kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and we're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const button equal to use
returning this button
one click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot
current dot blur
and uh after that is getting close using
ref equal to what btn whichever you're
referring it and that's it so the job is
done
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all loading
is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all norm
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise to block
so the use
layout effect
okay works in the same phase as
component did mount and component did
update methods we should only use use
effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example the one which we are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're going to give the new file name
called use
layout
and here we're using const
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
[Music]
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this length is saying
use layout is working
okay
with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the value history
okay so we say
return
inside this tip we will say
value
that's it
and after this
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
okay we need to check
[Music]
so
value okay all right so here i need to
use
to make it okay so now
i go to inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected
used out is working well it is working
to the react it's perfect so that's
where the idea of this particular
example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react-based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what use double value actually does
and
what we uh really do with the use debug
value this we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the developing custom books so use debug
value is a simple in build hook that
provides more information about the
logical of a custom hook within a
reactive tool so react dev tool is a
tool which you can
get it uh downloaded for your chrome
extension okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react views debug values basically be
useful for
now
how you basically use this so you can
just consider in this way
if i just go back and create a new file
and give the name called usable value
use
double dodges
okay
so inside this youtuber.js
here we would like to use function
and in function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
and here we can use const
is
online
set
debug value and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option i can watch
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the regular users
hello everybody and welcome you all
so today we have a very interesting
session coming up for this react which
is called react router so let's get
started with react router and see what
it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing as we know it
very well the routing is synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to another part like you have called
login page registration page and you've
got a lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js based
application which is you know it is
designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react networks once again for
mobile-based
environment for react applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
apis so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something
from where
okay it uses the traditional html5
history api which is one of the main
component so
it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate route will get loaded for
you so-called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like
ahrefs how we used in html pages
so
to different uh from the traditional
react replica application so it is
mainly designed focus on navigation
throughout the applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create reactor so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook and the router hyphen
tutorial is the name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen now to ripen down so this
dependence you need to install post
first
uh i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
dom so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router top is already
there in place so we would like to start
now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder named
components
okay and inside this components
we will create some file name called
login
dot
js
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
one more
name call
um
yeah
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay out of which i want the first
components to be get launched here that
is known as call a landing page so here
i will also create
landing page.js so let's go back and
create a new components here which will
be helping us to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new
functional component so i just copy the
same
and here in login.js we paste it
and give the name to login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted in the portfolio
so you call portfolio welcome to
portfolio
register
login you know call user details
okay so we have got these components
with us
i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class based
component here
so
import
react
from
now
4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this is
the one that we call tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on
so
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is
this landing page in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in our previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable
landing page we would like to create
some more
dependency we are saying import
from
react hyphen router hyphen dom so we'll
be choosing those dependencies one by
one but from there
we want to start working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as we discussed with you that is we
would like to start with the browser
router
okay
so
from this point onwards you would like
to start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is
login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here i'll say c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we work on login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
we would like to say
login
and in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called login and
second score register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes
that's it
so once this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs
so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back okay nothing is shown
so now we have to manually type by
saying
login you can see i've got this message
go welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
[Music]
portfolio
so
okay
and last
we have a call a user details
import name call
user details here
so we got to use the details let me copy
these two
so register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all the registers
successfully
well in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is
like here itself you create a new
component called
header
okay
so this is how we're going to create the
new component called header
okay
so within this
you're gonna add
the new
tag call header within this you will be
using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like in 2
equal to
login
and
along with this
you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
we also have call
last we have
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that
this component whichever we are talking
about okay
this component we can attach
to one of
my base component when my components
start it should work automatically so i
can do one thing like my login command
to be the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's how
your url works
okay everybody so in the previous
examples we have seen how the links are
working but these links are all internal
links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open
up i'm opening up simply learn link and
i'm clicking on this
the url is right now https simply
done.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
and i give the name call
simpler
and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it's asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that'll be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now
so you can see we have a call simply
done the moment i click it here
so it will somehow try to take me
towards where
this external website the one which
we're actually looking forward for
okay so this is the way
through which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and
[Music]
refresh this and click on simply and you
can see now it took me to an external
location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply do
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the link
which is available right you can see
right now we have recorded
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more let's say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided let's just copy this link
and
paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
i can say simply learn youtube i click
it
and you can see it took me two way to
the other
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they are simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
and with that we have come to the end of
this full course tutorial if you enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will answer them for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you